WELCOMING ALL OF YOU TO THE
SSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION TODAY
IS APRIL TWENTY SECOND. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE LET ME BEGIN BY.
TAKING CARE OF SOME
HOUSEKEEPING. ITEMS OUT. WE
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO
ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ME WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE SAYING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR ANY VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MOUSE WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS- CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
UTTERING LOUTH THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED.
GIVEN INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD. THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE DESTRUCTIVE
CONDUCT I MAY TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING IT TO
CONDUCT THIS NOT STOP I WILL
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS IN ESCORTING THE IN
THE INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COOPERATION AND NOW WE
CAN TURN TO THE ITEMS BEFORE US
TODAY. HI IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO
NOT HAVE QUORUM YET SO WE'LL
PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
TODAY WE HAVE A VERY FULL
AGENDA SO WE HAVE PASSED THE
AUTHORS TO BE BRIEF AND HAVE
LIMITED PRIMARY WITNESS
TESTIMONY TO- TWO MINUTES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION. REGARDLESS OF HOW
MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE
TESTIFYING. WITNESSES MAY
TESTIFY BY PHONE OR FROM THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM.
OR IN PERSON IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE THE CALL THE NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO AGAIN ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND HIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY PRIVACY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO. AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
ARE YOU ARE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING- ARE THERE BILL
PRESENTATION. NOW THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST YOUR
SMART DEVICE. TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US I AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS- TO CONTINUE.
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHY. THE NINE OH
ONE TEN AB TEN SEVENTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY. AND WITH THAT I
DON'T LIKE TO ACTUALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL CAN COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR WORK. AND
IT IS BECAUSE OF THEIR WORK WE
WERE ABLE TO- HASHED OUT A LOT
OF THE ISSUES BEFORE TODAY'S
HEARING. AND THAT MAKES OUR JOB
A LOT EASIER SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WITH THAT WE CAN NOW
TURN TO THE BILLS BEFORE US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE SAID SHE
HAS REQUESTED THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA- PRESENT AB
THIRTY FOUR TODAY. AND HAS BEEN
GRANTED PERMISSION TO GO FIRST
TO ACCOMMODATE HIS PRIMARY
WITNESSES. AND I SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA HERE SO
WELCOME TO OUR COMMUNITY- I'D
LIKE TO INVITE YOU UP TO THE
PODIUM ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR TEST-
PRESENTATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COLLEAGUES IT'S A GREAT
HONOR TO BE ABLE TO. PINCH HIT
ON A BILL THAT OF BOTH MYSELF-
SOME MEMBERS SU CHI AS WELL AS
A SUMMER SANTIAGO HAVE. AGREED
TO JOIN NOT THEY'RE PROUD TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB THIRTY FOUR
TODAY THE BROADBAND FOR ALL
BOND ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THIS BILL WILL PLACE A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO BALLOT TO BUILD MORE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
STATE TO HELP CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. COVA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS HIGHLIGHTED ENORMOUS
DISPARITIES. IN ACCESS TO
RELIABLE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ESPECIALLY. IN RURAL AND LOW
INCOME URBAN COMMUNITIES. MANY
OF US HAVE PERSONALLY SEEN THE
NECESSITY OF BROADBAND ACCESS
AS MANY OF OUR KIDS HAVE BEEN.
DOING DISTANCE LEARNING FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR. MANY
CALIFORNIANS TELECOMMUTERS AND
HAVE WORK FROM HOME. AND MANY
NEEDED TO USE TELEHEALTH TO
TALK TO THEIR MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
HAVING ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INSURERS ALL OF THESE IMPORTANT
ASPECTS OF OUR DAILY LIVES CAN
OCCUR. THIS PANDEMIC HAS MADE
IT MORE APPARENT BUT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN OUR ON SERVE
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IN ORDER
FOR CALIFORNIA TO COMPETE IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
ECONOMY. WE MUST MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
ENSURING WE ARE ALL CONNECTED.
THIS BOND WILL ALLOW CITIES
COUNTIES CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND OTHER
PUBLIC AGENCIES. TO APPLY FOR
BOND FUNDING TO BUILD THEIR OWN
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
GOAL OF THE MEASURE TO INVEST
IN BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
STATEWIDE SPECIFICALLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. TO INCREASE ACCESS
ANDCOMPETITION TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IN UNDER SERVED AND
UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO MEET
THE CHALLENGE OF CLOTHING OR
DIGITAL DIVIDE THE STATE MUST
MAKE BOLD SOLUTIONS AND
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
PRIORITIZE AXES AND
AFFORDABILITY FOR BROADBAND.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AND
STAYING CONNECTED IS ESSENTIAL
TO MODERN LIFE WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES- ONE IS- THE
SUPERVISOR OF MONTEREY COUNTY
AND A FORMER COLLEAGUE OF OURS-
WE WERE TOLD THAT THE THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN A CHANGE WE WERE
GOING TO HAVE THE
SUPERINTENDENT BUT INSTEAD I
THINK WE HAVE. SOME FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION BUT I MAY BE WRONG
SO I'M I'M GONNA WAIT AND SEE
WHAT. WHO. LOUISA MANNER WHO WE-
ABSOLUTELY FINE. OUR NOT GO TO
AN ATTORNEY YEAR FOLLOWING
GOING PLEASE- LET'S WITH UP
YEAH GO AHEAD PLEASE A FIRST.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I TOLD
THURMOND SUPER OF PUBLIC-
HONORED TO GIVE A CALL YEAH. ON
BEHALF OF A THIRTY. I'D LIKE
TO. OF THE ALL SO FOR A PREMIUM
FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SU CHI
GARCIA AND I'M TRYING TO.
PLEASE RESPOND TO BILL AS YOU-
IT WILL- PUT A HAVE A BALLOT
MEASURE- BEFORE THE- THE TO
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THE
VOTERS WHICH- BOB. A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR BOND THE PURPOSE
OF BILLS CAMPUS. OPERA PROVIDER
BROAD- NEWS TO SAY THIS IS A
CRUCIAL INTEREST- TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THAT IT WOULD
AUTHORIZES YOU HURT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES
ENABLE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
MINUTES APOLOGIES TO- TO SEE
FUNDS FOR BUILDING OUT. THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE THE PANDEMIC HAS
EXPLOITED IN A COMPOSED THAT
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE GONE WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET EVEN
THOUGH WE WERE ABLE TO HELP-
PROVIDE A MILLION DEVICES TO
STUDENTS. AND MANY HOT SPOTS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE USED OUR-
ASK FOR SOME- CLOSING THE DEAL
DIVIDE TO DO THIS WE EVEN GOT.
DISCOUNTS FROM ALL THE AYE IT'S
MANY OF OUR FAMILY COULD
RECEIVE INTERNET CLOSED.
DOLLARS A MONTH THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
THE IN. IN THERE EVEN BROUGHT.
BUSINESSMAN ARE STILL AND OF.
IT HINDERS OUR PUBLIC I. AM
PERSONNEL WHO DO NOT HAVE AN-
TO- CABLE INTERNET AND SO THIS
IS A GREAT SOLUTION COULD OUT
THAT IN- THE IT. WOULD PUT IT
ON THE BALLOT FOR THE VOTER- TO
VOTE FOR IT WE KNOW THAT EVEN
OUR- ARE WE IN INSTRUCTION DAY
NEED TO HAVE HIGH SPEED. TO
PREPARE THEM THE JOBS OF THE
FUTURE. HI THIS IS A WIN FOR-
IN COMMUNITY- AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MR
SUPERINTENDENT FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING AS
WELL. OUR NEXT WE HAVE OUR
SUPERVISOR AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS ALEJO
REPRESENTING. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. MISTER
ARE YOU AVAIL TO YOU. YEAH YES
I AM THANK YOU MISS CARE ACT
MEMBER THIS IS NOT ACCOUNT
PEOPLE THAT KNOW WE SAW. AND
I'M HERE AT THE- THAT THAT YOU
HAVE MEMBER OF THE CULT STATUS
OF COUNTIES ALSO ELEVEN O'CLOCK
AT THE COUNTIES ARE I'LL BE
HAPPY OUR BORDERS SUPER- WE ARE
KNOW THAT A TWENTY THE DIGITAL
IN CALIFORNIA IS THE MORE AND A
MAJOR CIVIL IF YOU OUR TIME.
THE GLARING. THIRTY TWO GONE UP
WITH TOO LONG AND WE MUST DO
BETTER HERE IN THE- CAP OF THE
WORLD IT WAS HARD TO SEE OUR
STUDENTS HUDDLED AT THAT
ADDRESS. LIKE THAT THE YOU CAN
LOOK RIGHT IN THE SALINAS IN MY
DESK LAST AUGUST WHEN THAT WHEN
VIRAL BECAUSE THE WITH THE-
ONLY PLACE THE COULD I IF THEY
DON'T FOR THE- AND JANA THE
INTERNET IS NOT A ANYMORE JUST
FOR THOSE WHO CAN IT. IT IS AND
IT'S VERY DELIGHT AND IT MUST
BE THE AS A F. THIRTY JUST LIKE
WATER ELECTRIC HERE. THE
TELEPHONE TRULY CARE ABOUT TAX
THIS ISSUE WE MUST TAKE A
BROADBAND BOND ON THE NEXT YEAR
AND LOCAL ARE THE BEST PARTNER
LISTING THE- TO MOVE PROJECTS.
MORE IT'S BEEN A TO. AND REVIEW
WE LOOK AT WHERE IT'S AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING TO WORK-
WERE DONE TO GET HIM TO TURN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SUPERVISE- AT THIS
TIME LIKE TO ASK YOU A- TO OPEN
THE PHONE THANKS WILL CALLERS.
OF IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I
WOULD LIKE SHOW SUPPORT THIS
BILL. PRESS ONE DOLLAR BY THE-
NINETY. OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
LINE. ON FILE. PLACE YOU BACK
INTO THE QUEUE. SO THIS SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS FOLLOWED BY ZERO
THIS TIME. AND ARE FOR.
PURCHASE WILL BE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE CALL AT. ERICA HOPPING
ON THE OF THE- SCHOOL BOARDS.
VERY MUCH IN. WHERE I BELT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH NEXT.
THANK YOU I NEED THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TURN MEMBERS WILL BE
AT THE SHOT BEHALF OF THE K.
FACULTY FIFTEEN AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT PLACE.
WE'LL GO ONLINE TO FIVE OFFER.
THIS IS YOUR STERLING SHARE OF
THIS WORLD CAUCUS VOICE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE
SIGN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
MISTER CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN YOU CAN CARTER ON BEHALF OF
THE L. FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. PINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS GREG
COOK FROM GOLD STATE POWER
COOPERATIVE- THE ANALYSIS ON
PAGE EIGHT RECOMMENDS THE IN A
MEMO TO INCLUDE RURAL
COOPERATIVES WITH THAT
AMENDMENT WE WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THAT I KNOW
THE FINALLY TO SHOWS ON THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NOW WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
SURE M. LINE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THINK LINE EIGHTY
SIX YOU MIGHT IT TAKE YOURSELF
ARGUE PLEASE RE QUEUE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE. SHOW SUPPORT AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE. NINETY ONE.
MY NINETY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
YES- MY IS REVEREND COMPOSED
NASH ACTS NETWORK. INTERESTED
IN THIS AND- OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SIR. RIGHT NOW WITH DOING
WHEN WE SUPPORT BUT WILL LOOK
YOUR COMMENTS THANK SIR. THANK
YOU FOR. IN WE WILL GO TO LAW
EIGHTY SIX GO AHEAD. YES PLEASE
FEEL CARTER WITH THE- SAYS OF
NONPROFIT INTO. THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK. RESEARCHER THERE NO OTHER
PURCHASE CUTE AT THIS VERY GOOD
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE. CAROLYN
MCINTYRE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE UNTIL- TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK- ON THE LINE WITH US I.
E. MS MCINTYRE ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. I AM. THANK YOU MADE
CHAIR. I'M IN THAT MEMBER- THE
CCP. APPRECIATE SAID FACT THAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON. I DID BRIDGE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AN INCH.
THAT EVERY HAS THAT. TO THE
INTERNET- HOWEVER WE HAVE. A
AND M. TO THIRTY FOUR. TWO
ENSURE THAT. FAT AND IF
APPROVED BY VOTERS ARE. MADE
AVAILABLE TO YOU I DON'T THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND WE ALSO A PRE
THE FACT THAT THE OP DIDN'T
FACTOR TIM TO INCLUDE. JEFF I
AN ANSWER. HOWEVER IT IS NOT
CLEAR AND IT DID. APPLY TO
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE BILL. WITH
AS IT RELATES TO PRIORITIZE
DISADVANTAGED. AND WE WOULD
LIKE CLARIFY THAT THE COMMUNITY
WITH ALL. I NEED TO BE A
COMMUNITY WITH THAT. CCG ABLE
REMOVE OUR TEN ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON THE MCINTYRE AT
THIS I'D SEE ANY IN THE- I WHO
WISH TO SEE UP. A OPEN UP THE
LINE OFFER PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE FOR CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION TO BILL. WHICH IS AB
FOUR. AB THIRTY FOUR YOU'D LIKE
SHOW YOUR I. PLEASE PRAY ONE
FOR BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO LINE
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
MOMENT I APOLOGIZE- MISTER
SHARED. BUT NO WORRIES. OKAY
SYSTEM CLICK HERE I APOLOGIZE
GIVE ME ONE SECOND PLEASE IF
YOU I'M SO SORRY NOT A PROBLEM.
OKAY YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE WILL WITH A LINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WILL CRIED
LINE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NOT NOT
ANYMORE AGAIN I APOLOGIZE- I'LL
I NEED ONE SECOND I AM JUST
HAVING A LITTLE SYSTEM ISSUE
HERE I REALLY APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT'S OKAY. ONE SECOND. THANK
YOUNG. THERE YOU GO.
MR ROBERT
ARE WE STILL WAITING FOR THE
LINE TO CLEAR UP. YES ONE
SECOND PLEASE I'M IN. ROB GO
AHEAD PER SECOND WOULD YOU
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. IT'S
CANNELLA NAY OF MISTRUST RADIO
IS IT OKAY IF I CIRCLE BACK
WITH YOU AFTER WE'VE HAD A
DISCUSSION HERE- WITHIN
OURSELVES PLEASE DO THAT'LL
GIVE US TIME TO. PICTUS
QUESTIONING SO MUCH THE CASE
AND LET'S CELEBRATE TO OURCOMMUNITY MR CAN'T GO HAD
QUESTIONS COMMENT. YEAH I.
SUPPORT THE- I THINK THE VOTERS
SHOULD A CHANCE TO. WHETHER
IT'S WORTH- TAKING ON SOME BOND
DEBT FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS NATURE- I
AM CURIOUS ABOUT THE CONCERN
RAISED BY CC TA- BECAUSE AT IS
AS UP AS I READ IT IT LOOKS
LIKE. DEFINITION ONLY- GROUPS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED QUOTE
UNQUOTE UNSERVED AND GROUPS ARE
CONSIDERED QUOTE UNQUOTE- AREAS
NOT GROUPS- QUOTE UNQUOTE
DISADVANTAGE OR SORT OF LUMPED
TOGETHER- I'VE SEEN THE CHARTS
ON WHERE BROADBAND ACCESS IS AT
ITS BIGGEST DEFICIT ANDS
PREDOMINATELY RURAL
PARTICULARLY VERY RURAL AREAS-
ALSO SOME CITIES IN MY DISTRICT
ACTUALLY AS WELL- I'M JUST
CURIOUS AS TO WHAT. WHETHER
THERE'S OPENNESS TO MAYBE
TIGHTENING UP THOSE DEFINITIONS
OR DOING. SOME SORT OF
DIFFERENT THING DEFINITIONAL
LEASE OF THE WE KNOW THE
MONEY'S GOING TO. AREAS THAT
DON'T HAVE THIS STUFF DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND NOT
GOING TO MAYBE REDUNDANCIES IN
PLACES THAT ARE ALREADY SERVED
BECAUSE OF THE DEFINITIONAL
THING. SO LET'S ALL START BY
SAYING THAT- I KNOW THAT IF FOR
THE PRINCIPAL AUTHOR WAS HERE
HE WOULD MAKE IT VERY CLEAR.
THAT HIS GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT
UNSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE
PLACES LIKE THE ONES THAT BOTH
YOU AND I REPRESENT- VERY
DIFFERENT IN THEIR AREAS THAT
HE REPRESENTS A REDONDO BEACH.
AT THAT ARIAS ARE HIS PRIORITY
AND I KNOW THAT HE CONTINUES IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH OPPOSITION- TO
TRY TO CLARIFY THOSE
DEFINITIONS IN THIS BUILDING
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. THE
DEFINITION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAS COME UP AS A
POINT OF CONTENTION AND DEBATE.
WHAT DOES THAT REALLY MEAN WHO
DOES THAT REALLY ENCOMPASS. AND
SO I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S SOME
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT
DEFINITION. I SHOULD BE
UTILIZED SO THAT WE'RE NOT
EXCLUDING OUT FOLKS FROM THE
ABILITY TO EITHER ADDRESS THE
UNSERVED. COMPONENT OR IN SOME
CASES THE UNDERSERVED WHERE
THEIR NEEDS ARE NOT SO MUCH
ABOUT BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PER SE BUT TO
INCREASE. CAPACITY AND SPEED
RIGHT SO I THINK HE IS AN
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS BUT I WILL
START. I WILL REITERATE AGAIN
THAT IF HE WAS HERE HE WOULD BE
SAYING TO YOU TO ME. I AM
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
AREAS- GET THE INVESTMENT
BEFORE AREAS LIKE MINE IN THE
IN THE HIS CASE. AT REDONDO
BEACH- GET THE PRIORITIZATION
FIRST SO I'LL- STOP THERE. AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE'S
GOOD FAITH- EFFORT TO TRY TO
CLARIFY THAT. I THINK I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT ANSWER ACTUALLY
LIKE YOUR IDEA OF MAYBE
DEFINING IT AS- UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED THAT MIGHT BE SORT
OF A CLEANER. MAYBE WAY TO DO
IT JUST. SOMETHING FOR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR. GREAT THANK YOU. IT'S
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED DOUBT
LET ME CIRCLE BACK TO THE
OPERATOR TO SEE IF I ANYONE
ELSE IS STILL ON THE QUEUE
THERE. MIZRAAB WRITER ON. HOW
WE LOOKING SO FAR. LET'S TRY
THIS AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
SHO. LISA PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR- I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHORS AS
WELL AS- THE PINCH HITTER GREAT
PENSION ABOUT A WEEK. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS AND PENSION-
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL I
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
BROADBAND IS A GOAL THAT WE ALL
SHARE AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. NOW
BEING THAT BEING SAID GOING
FORWARD I AM INTERESTED TO HEAR
MORE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THEIR ANALYSIS
OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF- SB
THIRTY FOUR THAT'S GOING TO BE
ASSIGNED TO THEM. I ALSO WANNA
NOTE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE AND SPEND RESOURCES
WISELY AND I DO ENCOURAGED ALL
OF THE AUTHORS TO CONTINUE
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT THE VOTERS ARE
PRESENTED WITH A SOLID PLAN.
THAT WILL BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS
SO WITHOUT DOUBT PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES FOR
UP FOR THE QUESTIONS THIS
PANDEMIC IS HIGHLIGHTED
ENORMOUS DISPARITIES IN ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE RELIABLE HIGH
SPEED INTERNET. SPECIALLY IN.
RURAL AND LOW INCOME.
COMMUNITIES AS THE INNOVATION
STATE CAL. SHOULD LEAD BY.
INCREASING ITS INVEST OF POP.
BROADBAND AND FOR. CALIFORNIA
MUST INVEST FOR FUTURE. AND
MEET THE CHALLENGES THAT FACE
OF PROVIDING AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET. FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
I WILL JUST SAY. MIKE MY
PIECES- WE CANNOT- WAIT ANY
LONGER. AND WE CAN'T EXPECT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
KINDA HOT SPOT. OUR WAY OUT OF
YOU KNOW ADDRESSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I WOULD
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IDOL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN- STILL I THINK WE CAN
ESTABLISH QUORUM IF YOU LIKE
THE STATE YOU'RE WELCOME TO DO
SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. I JUST TIME
ELECTED TURNED OVER TO OUR
CONSULTANTS SLASH- SECRETARY
ACTING SECRETARY PLEASE
ESTABLISH A CALL I'LL CALL THE
ROLL PLACE OF. FOR PURPOSES TAP
HERE. KILEY. PARA QUE HAN.
SENATE HERE CORREA. CUNNINGHAM
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER IRWIN WE
WICKS. WE HAVE QUORUM ARE LIKE
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO PASS
IS BUILT AB. THIRTY FOUR- YOU
DID ALREADY. SO ARE SO-
OPTIMISTIC THREE CALL THE ROLL
INDUSTRY. CHAPTER ALL RIGHT
CHAO HI KYLE. OUR K. SENATE.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU GO. OUT AT THIS TIME
CAN WE- DO A MOTION TO PASSED
THE CONSENT AGENDA- MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA. CHAFF HI
CHARLES HI KILEY. PARA QUE HAN.
SENATE SENATE I CARILLO
CUNNINGHAM. GABRIEL GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I IRWIN. LEE HI WE
AYE WICKS WICKS HI. SO WE'VE
GOT WITH TO THE CONSENT AGENDA
IS ADOPTED- SO LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT TO BILL AND I DON'T SEE
MISS POLLOCK K. AND YET DOES SO
BUT I DO SEE MISTER BLOOM SO MR
BLOOM WHICH LIKE TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL. AND THAT WOULD BE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB NINE ONE
SEVEN. AND WELCOME TO OUR
MEETINGS TO BLOOM THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB NINE SEVENTEEN WILL
ALLOW TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
CAPTURE IMAGES OF VEHICLES WHO
ARE VIOLATING TRANSIT ONLY
LANES AND BLOCKING BUS STOPS.
DESPITE CLEAR MARKINGS AND
SIGNAGE TRANSIT ONLY LANES ARE
FREQUENTLY IGNORED
UNFORTUNATELY. FOR EXAMPLE
FIELD OBSERVATIONS OF WILSHIRE
BOULEVARD IN WEST LOS ANGELES
AND MY DISTRICT FOUND ONE
VIOLATION EVERY FOUR MINUTES.
PLUS ONLY LANE VIOLATIONS OF
PARKED VEHICLES FORCED TRANSIT
OPERATORS TO MANEUVER AROUND
CONGESTED LANES AND MAKE DROP
OFFS FURTHER FROM THE CURB.
THIS REDUCES EFFICIENCY AND
POSES SAFETY ISSUES. TO COMBAT
THESE VIOLATIONS AND- THE AND-
SAFETY ISSUES THAT ARE ANCHORED
SAN FRANCISCO ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED CAMERA
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS. FORWARD
FACING CAMERAS ARE ATTACHED TO
THE BUSES AND ONLY RECORD
LICENSE PLATES OF VEHICLES THAT
ARE BLOCKING BUS LANES IMAGES
ARE THEN SENT TO THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO REVIEW
AND ISSUE A CITATION. IN THE
PILOT PHASE SAN FRANCISCO
SHOWED A 20% REDUCTION IN
DELAYS AND EVEN FEWER REPEAT
CITATIONS IN ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AC TRANSIT SAW A
21% IMPROVEMENT IN ON TIME
PERFORMANCE. AB NINE SEVENTEEN
HAS NUMEROUS GUARDRAILS FOR
CONSUMER AND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS NEW ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS MUST GIVE NOTICE TO
THE PUBLIC IN ISSUE ONLY
WARNING NOTICES FOR THIRTY DAYS
BEFORE FULL IMPLEMENTATION. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES IMAGES TO BE
DISPOSED OF SIXTY DAYS AFTER
THE CITATION HAS BEEN
FINALIZED. IMAGES CAN BE RETAIN
NO MORE THAN SIX MONTHS FROM
THE DATE THEY WERE FIRST TAKEN
AND IMAGES THAT DO NOT SHOW
VIOLATE. RIGHT NOW IN FIFTEEN
DAYS. THESE IMAGES CAN ONLY BE
USED FOR PURPOSES OF PARKING
ENFORCEMENT NOTHING ELSE AB
NINE SEVENTEEN WILL PROVIDE
RIDERS WITH ACCESS TO SAFE AND
RAPID BUS SERVICE AND ENSURE
PUBLIC TRANSIT REMAINS
COMPETITIVE IN ATTRACTING MORE
RIDERS. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE TO STRENGTHEN
THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN AB
NINE SEVENTEEN WE WILL AMEND
THE BILL TO INCLUDE THE
LANGUAGE NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
AB NINE SEVENTEEN HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND WAS VOTED OUT OF
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
<c.green>OMMITTEE WITH- NO NO VOTES TO</c>
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AT LEAST I HOPE- PARK MICHAEL
TURNER THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT LA METRO. AND
STEPHENJONES WHO IS EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS REPRESENTATIVE AC
TRANSIT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UP MISTER TURNER ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES I AM
WELCOME INCREASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU SHARON MEMBERS- AND THIS IS
MICHAEL TURNER ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION AND
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ALL OF US TO MAKE
THIS A BETTER BILL. AB NINE ONE
SEVEN WOULD AUTHORIZE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO INSTALL
FRONT FACING CAMERAS TO OUR
VEHICLES TO ASSIST WITH
ENFORCEMENT OF PARKING
VIOLATION IN TRANSIT ONLY LANES
AND AT BUS STOPS WITH THIS AT
THE ALREADY METRO AND OTHER
AGENCIES CAN PARTNER WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALREADY HAVE
PARKING ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WE WITNESSED METRO WOULD
NOT BE ISSUING PARKING
CITATIONS UNDER THIS PROGRAM
WILL BE UTILIZING THE CITY'S
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
PARKING ON THEIR STREET. AB
NINE ONE SEVEN SIMPLY CREATES
AN ADDITIONAL TOOL TO ASSIST IN
THIS EFFORT TO KEEP BOTH PLANES
CLEAR AND KEEP BUSES MOVING
WE'RE SPONSORING AB NINE ONE
SEVEN TO AUTHORIZE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF A TRANSIT LANE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND CITY OF SANTA
MONICA WHERE WE CURRENTLY
OPERATE BUS LANES AND ALLOW FOR
FUTURE EXPANSION IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OTHER CITIES. WE CURRENTLY
OPERATE BUSES ON OVER TWENTY
NINE MILES OF TRANSIT ONLY
LANES AND THESE HELP TO SERVE
THE TEN MILLION RESIDENTS OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ONE OF THE
KEY IMPROVEMENTS WE EXPECT TO
pRELIABILITY BUT I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE SAFETY ISSUE HERE
ILLEGALLY PARKED CARS AND BUS
LANES ARE A SAFETY HAZARD. AND
WE ESTIMATE THAT ABOUT EIGHTY
WRITERS BUS OR DELAYED FOR EACH
MINUTE GOT A CARS BLOCKING. A
LANE. BIGELOW SOMETHING OTHER I
WENT DOWN. WHERE THEY HELD
PLEASE BE YOUR LINE THIS
WITNESSES PLEASE ME TO I. THE
NEW YORK WE'LL FIND OUT LINE
OKAY I KNOW HAPPENED OKAY HE
SAID. US REP UP QUICKLY- IS
THIS ALL A SIMILAR A PRO. GOOD
MISRABA REITER QUE YOU HELP OUT
RUSSIAN ARE CLOSED YEAH. GO
AHEAD SIR OKAY THANK YOU YEAH-
I JUST WANNA TO KNOW DO IT TO
THE CONCLUDE THAT WE WILL TO
BUILD A OF THIS OF THE PROGRAM
THAT HAVE BEEN OUT I AM IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND ALLEN COUNTY AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR PARTNER
TO ENSURE THAT WE DO THIS SAFE
TO SAY ENOUGH THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR HOW SECOND
WITNESS MISTRESS JONES THE ALUM
CON COSTA TRANSIT- DISTRICT OUT
ARE YOU AVAILABLE MISTER JOE.
YES SIR. PLEASE AHEAD THE WALK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- DO MORNING
JONES EXTERNAL FOR AT EIGHT
ENTRANCE SPEAKING INCOME OF A
NINE SEVEN. AB SEVENTY BILL
UPON EXIST LAW AND ALLOWS ALL
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
USE CAMERAS MOUNTED ON TRANSIT
VEHICLES TO DETER PEOPLE FROM
PARKING AND TRANSIT ONLY LANES
AND A TRANSIT STOPS. CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS AC TRANSIT TO USE
CAMERAS TO DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL
PARKING IN THE TRANSIT ONLY
LANES OF OUR NEW BUS RAPID
TRANSIT SYSTEM. SHARES DEPUTIES
REVIEW VIDEO IMAGES FLAGGED BY
BUS OPERATORS AND ISSUE
CITATIONS WHERE WARRANTED THE
DATE WE'VE RECEIVED ZERO
PRIVACY CAN- ON ALL REGULAR
SERVICE- IT'S ALSO FREQUENTLY.
WHEN VEHICLES PARKED IN BUS
STOPS WHAT A BUS OPERATOR CAN'T
REACH THE CURB WRITERS ARE THEN
FORCED TO LOAD OR UNLOAD IN THE
STREET FOR THEY HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE THE LARGE GAP THAT'S
CREATED BETWEEN THE BUS AND THE
CURB. THIS IS A POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS MANEUVER FOR WRITERS
TO MAKE- AND INTERNAL AND IT'S
AN IMPOSSIBLE ONE FOR THOSE
WITH A DISABILITY OR MOBILITY
ISSUES LIKE SENIORS. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTEEN WILL HELP
IMPROVE TRANSIT SYSTEM
ACCESSIBILITY SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY WHILE ADVANCING
EQUITY FOR TRANSIT RIDERS I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
HERE IN THE ROOM- WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY OR THE REMOTE LOCATION
SO AT THIS TIME MISTER OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES.
FOR CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF. AB
NINE SEVENTEEN. SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THE ZERO AND- MISTER CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE BUT THERE MIGHT BE A
PERSONAL TO THAT- TESTED THAT
WE ARE HAVING A SYSTEM PROBLEM.
THANK EVERYTHING STRAIGHTENED
OUT NOW SO AGAIN I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT THERE'S A FEW. FROM
THE LAST BILL WILL OVER LINE
FORTY ONE START PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FORTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
MOVING ALONG WITH A LINE
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NOT ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE A
HELICOPTER ON THIS MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
GUY BROKE THROUGH THIS BEFORE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE SEVENTY TWO- GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THE WALK ON THE ALCATEL
PRETTY SITUATION RECORDED
TRANSIT- CAL ACT ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HONORED
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK Y. ONE FIFTEEN YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE IS TO
TSHOMBE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSIT
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WE HAVE
NOT HAD A SINGLE PRIVACY
COMPLAINT IN OVER A DECADE-
OVER OVER THIS DECADE LONG
PROGRAM'S HISTORY I DON'T LIKE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
ARTICULATE BUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND ACCESS. JUST
PLEASE TELL US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU REPRESENT
IF. ALCOHOL THANK YOU. WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE ELEVEN MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTHEW FIVE
RULING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC PARKING
ASSOCIATION BOARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ENTRY WE ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
TRANSACTION. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
OH SIX THAT IF YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD IF IS THIS PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION- YES MA'AM
I COMMITTEE YES MA'AM WE'RE ON.
IT WORKS I. TIME I A TIME
GETTING ON THE PHONE. AND IT
MAKES YOU ME WANT HOW MANY
OTHER TELL. ARE STRONG. I'M
CALLING ABOUT NOW THREE FOUR
BUT I HAVE JUST. TRIED GETTING
THROUGH AN THIS KEEPS HAPPENING
IT HAPPENS IN CAN WITH LOWER
NOT IT HAPPENS INCOME WITHOUT.
AND I'M TO BACK FILL OUT THE OP
ON AB. THIRTY I MY OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTY FOR. LUTEGO TWO GO
TO CLIENTS THANK YOU MA'AM. WE
WILL GO TO A ONE OUT ONE ON
NEXT THANK YOU SO. GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- AND IF COUPLE
CHECK WITH. VISOR ON THE OF THE
ANTICLERICAL TRANSIT AT THE ON.
OF AB NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH NEXT. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL. IN THE- SO THIS
BILL PLEASE ONE FOR BY ZERO AND
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI IS- JOHN IT-
UNDER OF THE DEBATE RIGHT UNION
WE ARE IN STRONG SO. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLACE. THANK YOU WILL
ALLOW ONE THIRD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS GATHERED IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN.
TRANSIT THAT BIG. AND WE ARE
VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS KEY NEED
IN ORDER FOR TO MAKE BUSES TO
WORK ONE. AND OF SIR WITH THE
OF THEIR- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE VERY MUCH- EACH YEAR YOU
VOTE THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MISTER OPERATOR
AT THIS POINT- LET'S TRY TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO REGISTER
OPPOSITION SO. I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SO LET'S GO TO PHONE
LINES- ONE MORE TIME MISTER
UPGRADED PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES. YOU TO SHOW OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE WE ARE ON
A BEAN NINE SEVENTEEN IS THAT
CORRECT MR SURE THAT IS CORRECT
THEM IS RAFI. THANK YOU. I
THINK IT. SHOWS PRESERVATION TO
EIGHT EIGHT NINE SEVENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GOOD LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
SEEING LOOKS GREAT THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UP IN THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM FOR- CARRYING THIS
BILL IS NOT ALWAYS EASY TO
BALANCE TRANSPORTATION
INNOVATION I WOULD PRIVACY BUT
I THINK YOU HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB SO- AND- IS THIS IS A VERY
COMMONSENSICAL BILL. AND THE
BILL LIMITS THE PURPOSES FOR
WHICH WHICH CAN BE USED AND HAS
REASONABLE DELETION
REQUIREMENTS I'D LIKE THAT A
LOT SO WITH THE AMENDMENTS SO
THAT YOU ARE ACCEPTING TODAY I
AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
SO WITHOUT DOUBT WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS THE BILL
BEEN MOVED YET. I LIKE
ENTERTAIN HIM. WE DON'T WITH
YEAH. SAID HAS BEEN MOVED DO I
HAVE A SET. CANSECO AT THE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS AB NINE SEVEN IN THE
MOTION IS DUE AS A TO FLOOR.
CHAP HIGH CHAO I HIGHLY. KILEY
I PARA QUE HAN BARRICADE I'VE
BEEN IT ON BENNETT AYE.
CUNNINGHAM KINDA I GAVE GABRIEL
I GALLAGHER. IRWIN HI- WHEN I.
LEE WITH. US EIGHT AND THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE- NECK
WE HAVE FAR LET'S GO BACK TO
NUMBER ONE OKAY HAVE THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER AB THIRTEEN SO. SIX
YES BACK TO YOUR- OKAY FINE.
WELCOME ANYTIME YOU'RE TO
PURSUE. THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS
FOR I WANT TO THE AND HE STAFF
WITH TIME ON THE IMPORTANT. AND
FOR PROCESSING AGREED AMEND
FROM THE PA SAFETY THAT REFLECT
IN THE BILL YOU SEE TODAY.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT A
THIRTEEN FIFTY. AND THAT
UPDATES ARE LAWSUIT. THE
INSIDIOUS THREATS PATIENTS AND-
AT A REPRESSED HEALTH IN. ARE
FOR. ROBY WEIGHT IS THE- PEOPLE
HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL TO SIX.
REFERRED HEALTH CLINIC. WITHOUT
THEIR- WELL BE. AND BEING
VIOLATED WITHOUT THREAT. AND
THE ASSAULTS THAT ARE COMING
WITH SHOWING UP TO GET THE
HEALTHCARE THEY HAVE A RIGHT
TO. LAWS REGULATING SHARING
PERSONAL INFORMATION ONLINE
WERE LAST UPDATED IN THE MID
TWO THOUSANDS AND THE FACE ACT
PROTECTING CLINICS IS WRITTEN
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. CENTS
THEN PROTESTERS A CLINICS HAVE
BECOME DRASTICALLY MORE EXTREME
IN THEIR TACTICS AND POWERED BY
ADVANCES IN TECHNOLOGY.
PROTESTERS RETURNED DAY AFTER
DAY HARASSING PATIENTS AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER EGGS
WEARING THEM DOWN MENTALLY AND
OFTEN CONFRONTING THEM
PHYSICALLY. NEW CAMERA VIDEO
CAPABILITIES ALLOW THEM TO FILM
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS IN
DETAIL. THEY POST THESE IMAGES
ON WEBSITES WITH PROVIDERS
PERSONAL INFORMATIONAL
INFORMATION SEARCHABLE FOR
MILLIONS OF USERS. THE ONLINE
HARASSMENT AND DOXING THREATENS
PATIENTS LIVES. CURRENT LAW IN
THE FACE ACTORS NOT REFLECT THE
SEVERITY OF THIS THREAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS DETERRED FROM
MAKING ARRESTS POLICE ARE
FRUSTRATED BY THE
RELENTLESSNESS OF THESE GROUPS
AND THEY LACK SUFFICIENT
TRAINING TO ADDRESS THE FRAUGHT
SITUATION. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE. PRIVACY AND
PHYSICAL SAFETY ARE PRE
REQUISITES FOR ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. ESPECIALLY REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WHEN A PATIENT
FACES UNMITIGATED HARASSMENT IN
THEIR MOST VULNERABLE MOMENT.
THEY'RE BEING ROBBED OF THAT
RIGHT TO HEALTH CARE OUR LAWS
ARE FAILING TO PROTECT THEM.
HARASSING IN PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
AGAINST REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
DOCTORS CARRIED LOWER PENALTIES
THAN DOG FIGHTING. LO FI AND
MISDEMEANOR DO NOT TURKEY THAT
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO PAY DEFEND
THEMSELVES SOMEHOW WE'VE
ACCEPTED THE STATUS QUO THAT
OVER PENALIZES MARIJUANA
POSSESSION BELIEVES YOUNG WOMEN
VICTIMS OF DEATH THREATS.
SIMPLY FOR SEEKING HEALTH CARE.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX UPDATES
ARE LOST TO INCREASE FINES FOR
ONLINE HARASSMENT AND
INTENTIONALLY TERRORIZING
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS. AND
INCREASES PENALTIES FOR REPEAT
VIOLENT OFFENSES. IT ALSO
INCLUDES NEEDED TRAINING FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ACTUALLY
PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES AND
PROTECT CLINICS. THIS IS NOT
ARBITRARY PUNISHMENT IT IS
ABOUT FINDING A SOLUTION
THEREFORE THE PENALTIES WILL
HAVE A SENSITIVE THREE YEARS
WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO ASSESS
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE LAW.
IN DETERRING EXTREMISTS AND
ADAPT FUTURE LET LEGISLATION TO
BEST PROTECT PATIENTS. TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX R. MACHEL SEMANSKY DIRECTOR
OF SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD MAR MONTE
AND LISA MASA GORA PPO POLICY
AND GENERAL COUNSEL AT PEAPACK
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
UP BEFORE WE GO TO A WITNESSES-
JUST A REMINDER THAT THE PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO EXPRESS
YOUR OPINION ON THIS BUILT. UP
THE HAS BEEN AND- LET'S GO TO A
WITNESSES SO STARTING WITH
FIRST ONE- WITNESS A MISS-
SEMANSKY. ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
I ONLINE I CAN'T. YEAH KAREN
MEMBERS I AM THE MAN HIS
ADDRESS THANK YOU YEAH PARENT
LEVINE THE COURT AT EIGHT
THIRTY WILL GET YOU SET. AND
LOCAL WORKING HARD TIME AT INTO
ASPEN HEARING IT IN OTHER
QUESTION ABOUT YOUR ATTACKING.
NUMBERS I PLANNED PARENTHOOD
MONTE HOUSE AND PUBLICLY IMAD
OF LAST THREE MONTHS IN. WE HAD
DOCUMENTED TO AND FORTY THREE
IN FACT. WE DOCUMENTED TAKE
FROM AND THIRTY TWO AND YET THE
CLASS MONTH AND WE ONE TWO
HUNDRED AND. SEVEN FIVE. THE
BILL. THEY ARE MURDERED AND
FAST BUT THEY'RE PAID BACK
THEIR FIND IN BLOOD PROTECTIVE
WEAR BODY CAMERAS BASICALLY
GRAPPLER CAST BUT BETTER FIVE
FIVE LOCATIONS IN BATH AND BAY
AND THE CENTER. MONDAY I DOCTOR
RECORDED PURPOSES BUT I AM NOT
GOING INTO THE PARKING LOT AND
SOME PARKING IN ENTERING THE
BUILDING LAST MONTH A PATIENT
OVER CELEBS INSPECTION THOUGHT
HE WAS BEING BLOWN BY A
PROTESTER AND WHAT THE PHRASE
THEY WOULD POST HER PICTURE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE GOT THE GRANDPARENTS
HAD FRIEND OF WORKING. HE ASKED.
ABOUT FILMING BUT THEY WERE.
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE CHARACTER.
AT THE VISIT GRANDPARENTS
CENTER AND POST. AND VIDEOS
PEOPLE BACK ON THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA. BUT PEOPLE BEING FOUND
ARE NOT. AND YOUR OVER HOW
THEIR AND ARE YOU. OKAY BACK ON
THE RIGHT TO PRIVATE AND HOW
CENTER AND TO BE FREE OF
PAINFUL CARE TACTIC FOR THESE.
I STRONGLY PEOPLE A THIRTEEN
PEOPLE ARE ONE OF OUR CLASS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ON SECOND ONE. NEWS SO LEASE
IT'S TO BUY. GENERAL COUNTS AT
PARA A PLANT. AFFILIATES CAL. I
YOU ON THE LINE SOON AS PART.
YES I AM CHAIRMAN THAN IN THE
INTEREST TIME WILL AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US AT
THIS POINT I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM OR THE REMOTE
LOCATION WHO WISH TO SPEAK UP.
SO LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MISTER OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR CALLERS IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE
WILL START TODAY WITH WIND ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MOLLY OR UPSET WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE PROBABLY
SPONSORING THE TOWN AFTER YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE WILL GO TO I ONE
MOMENT THERE WITH AN OPERATOR
SHOULD BE WITH US MOMENTARILY.
WELL I'M ONE OF SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE OH SIX AM I WON
ONE OF SIX I'M TRYING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX AM I IN THE RIGHT
PLACE. YEAH WE ARE NOT ON THAT
ONE RIGHT. WHEN YOU'RE ON THAT
BILL BUT I'M IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU WANT TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES BILL. BUT OUR
TURNING BALAKAN BUT I'M IN
OPPOSITION SAID YOU NEED TO
KEEP ME BACK UP YOU HAVING
SERIOUS BONUS YOU REALIZE. MY
POINT MA'AM I SEE YOU CAN JUST
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION IT
JUST OR CALL BACK LATER.
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO SPEAK I'D
LIKE TWO MINUTES THE OTHER SIDE
GETS TWO MINUTES I'D LIKE TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK SO IF YOU
COULD KEEP ME OCCUPIED LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. ARGUMENT
IF YOU CAN GO BACK TO THE
QUEUE- WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU
THANK YOU WHAT DO I DO I DON'T
THINK IT'S NOT USE THE WIND AND
YOU. YOU ARE. CAN YOU HELP HER
OUT ONE POINT. YEAH ONE ONE TWO
PLEASE GO. YES GOOD THIS IS
TRACY ROSENBERG I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE MEDIA ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THREE FIVE SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
AGAIN WE ARE SHOWING SUPPORT
FOR AB ONE THREE FIVE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO WILL COLLIDE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR KAREN
MEMBERS WITH ERIN ON BEHALF OF
NAY AROUND PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MATCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR WE WILL GO
TO A ONE OH SIX AND FOR A
FINAL- THE FINAL REMINDER ON
HOW TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT ONLY FOR AB ONE THREE
FIVE SIX AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. ONE ALL SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY I BACK HERE I WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE-
SENATE LIKE TWO MINUTES WE LIKE
THE OTHER PEOPLE WERE GETTING.
PLEASE MA'AM I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. WE ARE STILL.
MA'AM WE STILL ON STARBOARD AND
WE ONLY ALLOW ME IN. MA'AM WE
STILL DOING SUPPORT CALLERS AND
WE ONLY ALLOW TWO MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE I THINK THERE IS A
PRIMARY WITNESS FOR OPPOSITION
ALREADY SO BUT PLEASE STAY ON
THE QUEUE IF YOU LIKE. AND
EXPRESS YOUR POSITION A BIT
LATER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
MUCH ROBERT OR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL CALLERS SO TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. NO INTO THE
PREVIOUS PERSON JUST WHEN WE
ASK FOR OPPOSITION FOR THAT
BUILDING GO AHEAD AND QUEUE UP
THANK YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR VERY
GOOD LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT- WE HEALTH. WE HAVE-
SUSAN OR NOW. IF I MISPRONOUNCE
YOUR NAME I APOLOGIZE SO WITH
THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAK OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. MISS ARE
NOW ARE YOU ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM SUSAN ARNOLD AN ATTORNEY ON
BEHALF OF THE RIGHT TO LIKELY
GET SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX AS AMENDED.
WE IN NO WAY CONDONE VIOLENCE
OR HARASSMENT OF ANY PERSON FOR
ANY REASON DESPITE THE VERY
GOOD INTENTIONS OF THE BILL IT
GOES TOO FAR. THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS THE LAW. IT'S
PRESERVES THE RIGHT TO TAKE
PHOTOGRAPHS OR VIDEOS WHILE IN
THE PUBLIC SQUARE USING NORMAL
PHOTOGRAPHIC EQUIPMENT LIKE
CELL PHONES. IT PROVIDES NO
EXCEPTIONS FOR JOURNALISTIC
WORK OR FOR EVEN FOR SELF
DEFENSE EIGHTY THIRD THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX PROVIDES NO
EXCEPTIONS. IT WILL MAKE IT A
CRIME TO FILM A CRIME COMMITTED
IN PUBLIC AGAINST PRO LIFE
DEMONSTRATORS OUTSIDE ABORTION
FACILITIES THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE
WITHIN THE LAST TWO MONTHS
ALONE OUR VOLUNTEERS WHO WERE
SIMPLY HOLDING SIGNS. AND
QUIETLY STANDING IN FRONT OF AN
ABORTION FACILITY WERE
THREATENED WITH A YARDSTICK AND
THE NICE HELP COULD WITH RAW
EGGS AND HAD THEIR SIGNS
FORCIBLY RIPPED FROM THEIR
HANDS. THIS BILL WOULD
CRIMINALIZE THESE PEOPLE
PROTESTERS FOR FILMING AND
PUBLICIZING THESE ASSAULTS.
COMMITTED IN BROAD DAYLIGHT AND
IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY OCCURRED.
IF THESE EVENTS HAPPENED
ANYWHERE ELSE VICTIMS COULD
FILM AND PUBLICIZE THE CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR WE SEE THAT EVERY DAY
MOST RECENTLY IN THE TRAGIC
EXAMPLE OF GEORGE FLOYD. WHAT
IF WE MADE IT A CRIME
PUNISHABLE BY JAIL HUGE FINES
AND LAWSUITS TO RECORD AND POST
ON SOCIAL MEDIA. VIDEO OF
POLICE MISCONDUCT. BECAUSE OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX VICTIMS
OF CRIME WILL BE UNABLE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES PUBLICLY
WITHOUT FEAR OF JAIL HUGE FINES
OR LAWSUITS. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX SALES THE THREE PRONGED
TEST FOR FIRST AMENDMENT. TIME
AND PLACE AND MANNER. ON THE
BILL DOES NOT IS. CONTENT
NEUTRAL IT IS NOT NARROWLY
TAILORED AND IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE CHANNELS
FOR COMMUNICATING A PRO LIFE
MESSAGE RECENT MODIFICATIONS DO
NOT CURE IT'S FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS
IT WILL CHILL THE EXERCISE OF
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM OR
AT THE REMOTE LOCATION WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SO. A
MISTER OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR A
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO URGE ALL THE
CALLERS AT THIS POINT TO JUST
IDENTIFY YOURSELF TELL US YOUR
NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION THAT
YOU REPRESENT IF APPLICABLE.
BECAUSE WE ALREADY TAKEN
TESTIMONY. FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESS THANK YOU. MR ROBERT
ARE YOU. STILL OKAY THANK YOU
S. YES WE ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AS- THE MISSED CARE SAID
CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX SIMPLY PRESS ONE ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ONE THAT
SELLS A SERVICE THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO COMMITTEE CHAIR MY NAME
IS ROBERT BYRD I'M AN ORGANIZER
WITH PRO LIFE SAN FRANCISCO
NONPROFIT ACTORS ORGANIZATION
OPERATING IN THE STATE OF
PALESTINE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU OUR- NEXT ON
THE LINE ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE ON MUTE. HI MY
NAME IS CHECK OUT YELL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I NEXT PLEASE. I NEXT LEVEL I'M
ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOU ARE OPEN ONE THIRTY
TWO. OKAY THANK YOU MY NAME IS
PAUL COOL THAT I'M A PRIVATE
CITIZEN IN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX. PROTECTED BECAUSE OF
THE THREAT OF VIOLENCE AT A
PRACTICE THANK YOU SIR-
REPRESENT EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR- NEXT THANK YOU. WE
WILL ALIGN ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI PAIDEIA PASADENA
CALIFORNIA A PRIVATE CITIZEN
STRONGLY OPPOSING THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL COUNTY THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT PLACE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WILL ALIGN ONE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
GOING ONE OF SIX AND I AM- A
REPEAT CUSTOMER- CLIENT AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD I'M VERY
VERY PRO CHOICE AND I'M AGAIN
BILL AND  DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU'RE NOT GIVING MORE VOICE TO
THE OPPOSING SIDE WHY DO THE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF THIS YOU
GET MULTIPLE WITNESSES I'D LIKE
TO ASK MA'AM I MAY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO DESK PLEASE.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GIVING EQUAL
AIR TIME THIS ISN'T FAIR WELL
MA'AM. I'M VERY. MA'AM ARE GIVE
ONE TO ME. MA'AM GIVING TWO
MINUTES TO EACH SIDE. AND THE
OPPOSITION THAT WE HEARD FROM
EARLIER HAS TAKEN UP MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES ALREADY SO PLEASE
TELL US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION. AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU REPRESENT IF
APPLICABLE AND THAT'S ALL WE
CAN DO AT THIS POINT SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL. WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN- HI MY NAME IS EVELYN SET
UP A AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
THIS BILL AB ONE THREE FIVE SIX
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS EILEEN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT SPENCER WITH
AMERICAN CULTURE OBGYN TONIGHT
APOLOGIZE WERE ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WASN'T
ABLE TO QUEUE UP FOR THE SPORT
TESTIMONY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR FOR YOUR CALL NEXT PLEASE.
LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM READY HOOKED ON THE
SPORT IS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU ARE WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO GO BACK TO ONE OH SIX AGAIN-
COMMITMENTS AT THE LAST MOMENT.
IF YOU HAS ALREADY CALLED ONE
OF THE STEPS ARE QUITE A FEW
TIMES- I THINK WE HAVE HEARD
ALREADY FROM HER A FEW TIMES I
THINK SHE'S IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. RIGHT. WE GOT WE
DON'T THE LINER OF. LOS ANGELES
CA ARE. I DON'T ONE OTHER
PERSON OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
OTHER PERSON FIRST PLEASE. OKAY
NINE ONE FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS EARL
GONZALEZ AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MUCH.
WHICH I DON'T WANT- SIX ONE OH
SIX THIS YOU GIVE US HER NAME A
PLACE SO MAYBE WE CAN GIVE HER
A CHANCE TO TELL US HER NAME.
AND THEY WILL THAT WILL LEAVE
IT AT THAT. JUST QUICKLY TELL
IT OKAY ONE OH SIX IF YOU WOULD
LIKE. TO TELL YOU ANYONE ELSE
SIX IF YOU'D LIKE TO STATE YOUR
NAME. STATE YOUR NAME PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT ONE OF
SIX I AM A REPEAT CALLER I AM
ANDREA HAD STRUCK THE FIRST
AMENDMENT STILL MATTERS. WAS
RIDICULOUS I AM PRO CHOICE. AND
OPEN THE DESK. THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS I MEAN CALLERS SO
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE-
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR- ARE VICE CHAIR
KILEY GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING- SOMEONE OUR OKAY AND I
KNOW THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF OPPOSITION- BECAUSE
THIS BILL RADICALLY INCREASES
CRIMINAL PENALTIES AND- UNDULY
INTERFERES WITH CIVIL LIBERTIES
DO YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE STILL
OPPOSED. THE I DO NOT DO NOT
LEAVE A SUBMITTED ANOTHER
LETTER I DO NOT KNOW AS MUCH OF
OR DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT
STATUS OF THE SILLIEST. I DO
NOT- HOWEVER I WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ACLU TO- THAT WORK OUT LANGUAGE
AND AMENDMENTS. IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE THEIR OPPOSITION. I SEE
WHAT WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
POINT ABOUT INCREASING CRIMINAL
PENALTIES NOT BEING THE ANSWER
BECAUSE I HEAR THAT THAT
ARGUMENT MADE A LOT IN THIS
CAPITAL- I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR
POSITION IS BEEN ON THE VARIOUS
OTHER BILLS WITH THAT'S COME
UP- BUT YOU KNOW WHY IS THAT.
THE ANSWER HERE WHEN IT'S NOT
THE ANSWER OF WITH. ALL THESE
OTHER CRIMES. YES THE
PROVISION. I YEAH THAT'S JUST
SO- I TAKE AN AWESOME PERSON
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT EVERY.
RECORD ON PUBLIC SAFETY- BUT I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS A
TIME AND PLACE TO LOOK AT
INCREASED. PENALTIES AND
INCREASED FINES ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE HEARING FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I THINK. THAT
IF YOU ARE IN YOUR COMMUNITY
BUT I KNOW IN MY COMMUNITY
ARTISTS AND WE TALK ABOUT A
LOT. OF IN PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS A LONG PERSON
OFTEN SAYS IF IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR IT'S NOT GOING TO
CHARGE FOR THE DA AND- SO
THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO AND SO
PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS. ENSURE THAT THERE'S A
RESPONSE THAT IS APPROPRIATE TO
THESE THREATS AND VIOLENCE TO
BE ACCESS TO HEALTH AND SO
THAT'S WHY THESE ARE BEING
INCREASED FOR MISDEMEANORS.
THANK YOU. BILL THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED IN THIS YEAR IT'S
BEEN MOVED SECONDED- OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING OH SORRY MR
GALLAGHER GARCIA GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY. YEAH JUST A COMMENT AYE
AYE I DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING
THAT- A BILL MOVED OUT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT ACTUALLY
TAKES THINGS FROM A MISDEMEANOR
TO A FELONY BECAUSE AND MANY
OTHER CASES THAT IS NOT BEEN
THE CASE. I FIND IT IRONIC THAT
WERE ALSO CONSIDERED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE ABILITY TO-
DECRIMINALIZING MAKE
MISDEMEANORS. OR REDUCE THE
CRIMINALITY OF ACTUAL
ROBBERIES. WE'RE AS WE'RE
TRYING TO CRIMINALIZE WHAT IS
CLEARLY PROTECTED SPEECH. AND
IT'S BEEN MADE VERY CLEAR UNDER
THE SUPREME COURT- DECISIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN HANDED DOWN ON
THIS ISSUE- JUST LIKE- AB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE- FROM. WHAT FOUR
YEARS AGO. IF THIS BILL PASSES
ALONG TO ABSOLUTELY BE STRUCK
DOWN AS UNCONSTITUTIONAL- AND
SO I THINK WE SHOULD YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY IN THESE COMMITTEES
WERE IT WERE CONSIDER PEOPLE'S.
RIGHTS WE SHOULD NOT CONTINUE
TO PROCEED WITH BILLS THAT WE
KNOW ARE ABSOLUTELY. NOT
CONSTITUTIONAL BASED ON LAWS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN. STRUCK
DOWN BY THE COURTS IN BY
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN HANDED
DOWN BY OUR HIGHEST COURT- SO I
WOULD JUST REALLY ENCOURAGES
COMMITTEE- TO NOT GET WRAPPED
UP IN THE EMOTION MAYBE OF THIS
ISSUE BUT ACTUALLY LOOK AT IT-
FROM THE- PERSPECTIVE OF THE-
OF THE CLEAR LAW ON THIS THAT
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WITHIN A
HUNDRED FEET THERE. AND ALMOST
ALL THOSE- SITUATIONS ARE
LIKELY GOING TO BE ON A PUBLIC
STREET OR A PUBLIC SIDEWALK-
ARE ABSOLUTELY LOUD TO
VIDEOTAPE. AND I THINK THAT THE
POINT THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION IS A GOOD MORNING.
WOULD YOU AND IN THE SAME CASE
SAY THAT SOMEONE COULD
VIDEOTAPE POLICE. ARRES OF THE
CITIZEN. AND IF YOU IF YOU
WOULD BE OPPOSED IF YOU WOULD
ACTUALLY BE OPPOSED TO BANNING
THAT RIGHT OF PEOPLE TO DO THAT
HOW CAN YOU THEN BE OKAY WITH
BANNING SOMEONE'S RIGHT TO DO
IT IN THIS SITUATION. WE HAVE
TO BE CONSISTENT. THE LAW IS
CONSISTENT. IT'S BEEN
CONSIDERED AND WE SHOULD BE.
ABIDING BY OUR OATH TO UPHOLD.
THE CONSTITUTION AND THE CLEAR
LAW THAT'S BEEN THAT IS COME
DOWN AND IN IN THE STATE AND IN
THIS NATION. ON THIS VERY ISSUE.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MISS WHICH COULD HAVE. I WAS
GONNA TALK BUT- YEAH JAMES HE
PULLED ME IN- THIS BILL SUPPORT
I WOULD FOR THIS BILL AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND I VOTED FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
DEMONSTRATE AND PROTEST IN THIS
ALSO ALLOWS FOR THAT. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO DO IS IF
AS SOMEONE WHO WAS WALKED INTO
A PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINIC TO
GET AN ABORTION TO BE
VIDEOTAPED WHILE I'M ENTERING
THAT BUILDING TO HAVE THAT THEN.
PLACED WHEREVER ON THE INTERNET
AND THAT IS AN INVASION OF
PRIVACY IN MY OPINION AND IT IS
IN THOSE MOMENTS OF TIME WHEN
WE NEED TO RESPECT A WOMAN'S.
RIGHT TO HEALTH CARE RIGHT TO
PRIVACY AT CENTER AND I THINK
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR. THE
NECESSARY- OUR RIGHTS TO
PROTEST DEMONSTRATE WHILE STILL
WOMEN WHO. NEED THIS CARE AND
ARE ENTITLED TO THIS HERE. SO I
WILL. DEFINITELY BE VOTING FOR
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR-
QUESTIONS I BELIEVE ABOUT THE
AUTHOR TO HAVE TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS IN PUBLIC SAFETY TO
REDUCE THE CRIME SOIF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. SO SO WITH THAT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE MEASURE IS
NARROWLY TAILORED AND- THERE IS
A COMPELLING GOVERNMENT
INTERESTS AND THAT WHICH I NOTE
A DRAWS SO WITH THAT- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLIP WHICH I COULD
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YES I AGREE WITH YOU AND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS SOMETHING I
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT I BELIEVE
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT AND
ONE THAT SHOULD BE PROTECTED
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE WORKED TO
MISTER KYLIE'S POINT WITH THE
ACLU. TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING THE CIVIL LIBERTIES
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT BEING
SAID AS THE LAWYERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE NO TRUE THREATS ARE
NOT PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND THIS IS A
NARROWLY TAILORED BILL THAT
ENSURES THE SAFETY AND SECURITY
OF THOSE THAT ARE SEEKING
HEALTHCARE AND I KNOW EVERYONE
ON THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORTS HIT
BY THE PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
PATIENCE. AND THE LAWS AROUND
THAT AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY IS THE
PRIVATE IN SURPRISE SEEN
SECURITY OF WORKERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO DO THEIR JOB OF
PATIENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO SEEK
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED AND
THEY HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD ALL SUPPORT. PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE LAW
ABIDING AND GOING ABOUT THEIR
WAY AND ENSURE THAT THEIR FOR
FROM US. AND BILE OF THE. KILEY
NO PARA QUE HAN HI ARE QUE HAND
I'VE DONE IT BENNETT I CARILLO.
CUNNINGHAM GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO IRWIN-
WHEN I LEE. LEE HIGHWAY SIX
WICKS HI YOU HAVE SEVEN VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE HOUSE- C. HEALTH
MINISTER. I THINK WE HAVE
MISTER GRAYSON NEXT YES.
WELCOME MR GRAYSON YOUR HOUSE
ITEMS FOURTEEN AND THAT IS A.
B.
TEN EIGHTY NINE. YES PLEASE
BEGIN GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL THE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS MOST OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THE
OTHERS AS THE BILL PROGRESSES.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
AB TEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH WILL
UPDATE AND MODERNIZE THE CREDIT
SERVICES ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR TO EXPAND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHEN CONTRACTING
WITH A CREDIT SERVICE
ORGANIZATION ALSO KNOWN AS CSO.
THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF A
MEASURE THAT THE COMMITTEE SAW
LAST YEAR WHICH PASSED THIS
HOUSE UNANIMOUSLY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THE BILL DID
NOT MOVE IN THE SENATE DUE TO
THE TRUNCATED SESSION BECAUSE
OF PROBITY. HAS POINTED OUT IN
THE ANALYSIS CREDIT REPAIR
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN WIDELY
CRITICIZED FOR ENGAGING IN
UNFAIR AND DECEPTIVE MARKETING
AND BUSINESS PRACTICES AND FOR
CHARGING HIGH FEES FOR SERVICES
THAT CONSUMERS CAN OFTEN
PERFORM THEMSELVES IT IS WORTH
NOTING THAT THE SCRUTINY HAS
COME FROM BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND CONSUMER
WATCHDOGS. AS SUCH IT IS
CRITICAL TO ADVANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN THIS AREA SINCE
THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN AND USE
CREDIT HAS BECOME OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO CONSUMERS WHO
HAVE A VITAL INTEREST IN
ESTABLISHING AND MAINTAINING
THEIR CREDIT WORTHINESS AND
CREDIT STANDING. WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
STRONGEST CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
IN THE NATION FOR OTHER
INDUSTRIES CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE CSOS TO PROVIDE EVEN
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SERVICES THEY WILL RENDER OR
HAVE RENDERED HOW MUCH THE
SERVICES ARE LIKELY TO COST
WHEN THEY COMMUNICATE WITH
THIRD PARTIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER OR A TIMELINE FOR WHEN
THEIR SERVICES WILL BE
COMPLETE. THIS IS WHY AB TEN
EIGHTY THAT IS NEEDED TO
ENHANCE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BY
REQUIRING CSOS PATEL BECAUSE
CONSUMERS WHAT THEY INTEND TO
DO AND THE RESULTS TO BE
EXPECTED. PROVIDE DID TAKE
DETAILED MONTHLY STATEMENTS OF
THE ACTIONS THE CSO HAS TAKEN.
AND DISCLOSED TO CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDE COPIES OF ALL
COMMUNICATIONS SENT BY A SEE A
SOUL ON BEHALF OF A CLIENT.
THIS IS A SIMPLE MEASURE
STRICTLY FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR A FOR
WELL DOCUMENTED UNFAIR AND
DECEPTIVE MARKETING AND
BUSINESS PRACTICES OF CSOS. I
DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES TODAY
MISTER CHAIR TOM GRIFFIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS AND CINDY YACKTMAN
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF.
COLLECTORS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S START WITH MISTER GRIFFIN.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE MISTER
GRIFFIN. I AM ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME MR TRUMP YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND THE MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOM
GRIFFIN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COLLECTORS. NOW WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR A. B. HEY NINE AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON. DOES
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO AB SIX
NINE NINE FROM LAST SESSION.
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE PASSED THE
PORT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE'RE
OPEN NOT. BEGIN YOUR SUPPORT
HERE TODAY AB TEN EIGHTY NINE
SIX TO PROVIDE. RIGOBERTA
ACTIONS AND GREATER
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS MAY
DECIDE TO CONTACT. A CREDIT
SERVICE ORGANIZATION- WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- OBVIOUSLY
THE AUTHORS OFTEN WE HAVE
AGREED TO TAKE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE SUGGESTED.
IN THE LAST DAY OR TWO. AS
POINTED OUT IN AN HOUR WILL
STATEMENT LAW PROVIDE A NUMBER
OF PROTECTIONS TO CONSUMERS WHO
SEEK THE SERVICES OF CSOS
DESPITE THESE LAWS SOME CREDIT
REPAIR COMPANIES TO OPERATE IN
A WAY THAT- TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF GLOBAL INDIVIDUALS AND OR
VIOLATE THE LAW. BUT ALL WHERE
SHE TO DO WITH THIS BILL IS TO
FILL THE GAPS CONSUMER ARE
ADDICT PROTECTED. I'M ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND I REQUEST YOU'RE
ABLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUT LET'S NOW GO TO CINDY
ACT WHEN ARE YOU ON THE LINE
MISCALCULATION. YES GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
WITHIN THE AUCKLAND I'M
CURRENTLY. THANKSGIVING SERVING
AS THE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS AND I'M A SECOND
GENERATION COLLECTION AGENCY
OWNER HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AB
TEN EIGHTY NINE IS FUNDED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS AS A DIRECT RESULT
OF CONSUMER PROTECTION ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
OUR MEMBERS. IN ON BEHALF OF
COLLECTION AGENCIES NATIONWIDE.
CONSISTENTLY OUR MEMBERS HAVE
REPORTED THAT CONSUMERS DID NOT
ACTUALLY DISPUTE THE AMOUNT THE
FINE. THEY INDICATE THE
SIGNATURE IN A LETTER SENT BY
THE DE ESTO IT'S NOT THEIR
SIGNATURE. CONSUMERS HAVE
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION AND ANGER
AT THEIR CREDIT SCORE DID NOT
INCREASE AS THE CSO HAD
REPRESENTED. THEY HAVE PAID FOR
SERVICES TO A THEATER WITH NO
RESULTS. THEY ARE UNAWARE THAT
THE LETTER THE DISPUTE ARE
BEING SPENT ON PAID ACCOUNT.
AND IT MULTIPLE LETTERS ARE
MAILED AT THEIR COST FOR
ACCOUNTS PREVIOUSLY VALIDATED.
IN ORDER TO ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHEN CONTRACTING
WITH THE CSO WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN YOUR
IPHONE TODAY ON EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY NINE. THIS BILL IS
CRITICALLY NEEDED TO UPDATE THE
CREDIT SERVICES ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURES TO
CONSUMERS FOR THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE C. IT SAYS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM OR THE
REMOTE LOCATION WILL WISH TO
SPEAK SO LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR CALLERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AN
OPERATOR'S GONNA GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER. OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUES TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN.
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MMHM PLEASE. GO AHEAD THE NEXT
CALLER MISTER CHAIR. YEAH BUT
HE IS GOING UP GOT IT THAT'S
GOOD OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE TO WIN THIS IS STARTING
WITH ERIC ALL COMRADES WITH
LEXINGTON LAW ARE YOU AVAILABLE
ON THE LINE MISTER CALLER OF. I
AM. PLEASE GO AHEAD WE CAN HEAR
YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY-
STATED MY NAME IS ERIC CAMERAS
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF LEXINGTON
LAW IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
EIGHTY NINE. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE- AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS BOTTLE
ANALYSIS. THE AUTHORS GOAL AND
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
BENEFITS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS- SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF TEN EIGHTY
NINE ON OUR ABILITY TO ASSIST
CONSUMERS. AGAINST DEBT
COLLECTORS TO SPONSOR THIS
BILL. UNLIKE DEBT COLLECTION
THIS IS NOT AN AREA OF CONSUMER
FINANCE WORK THERE HAVE BEEN
OVERWHELMING ISSUES OF CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS REVIEWS- AS
EVIDENCED BY BOTH- RECENT CFPB
FINDINGS. AND THE LACK OF ANY
CONSUMER GROUPS. SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. WHILE MANY OF THE
MEN IN THE ANALYSIS HELP TO
WOULD SOME CONSUMER CONCERNS
OUR POSITION REMAINS SIMPLE. AB
TWENTY NINE BENEFITS THAT
COLLECTORS AND HARMS CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. ADMITTEDLY IT SOUNDS
REASONABLE IT'S AFFECTS ARE NOT.
ROUTINELY EVERY CONSUMER
CRITICISM IS ALREADY COVERED BY
EXISTING STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO WALK ANY
NUMBER THREE THE LEGISLATION
AND SHOW HOW THAT IS THE CASE-
ONE FINAL NOTE SIMILAR
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN INTRODUCED
IN OTHER STATES. MOST RECENTLY
MARYLAND AND EACH OF THOSE
LEGISLATURES HAVE DETERMINED
THAT SHIFTING THE BALANCE OF
POWER IN FAVOR OF DEBT
COLLECTORS IS BAD POLICY. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
MUST ASK YOU BOTH KNOW TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT WE HAVE-
ISRAEL ACT A FELONY ON BEHALF
OF LEXINGTON LAW AND
PROGRESSION ARE YOU THERE
MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE KNOCKING ON THE FROM
THE AFTERMARKET HERE ON BEHALF
OF CREDIT REPAIR ORGANIZATIONS
PROGRESSION BACK INTO LAW WE
ALSO THINK DOCTOR NEXT. AFTER
THEIR TIME IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND ITS STAFF OR TWO THOUSAND
AND THE AMENDMENTS WELL WE
OPPOSE EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY NINE
WE AGREE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE CONSUMER HAVE CLARITY ABOUT
THE SERVICES THEY ARE GETTING
AND HOW THEY ARE GETTING THEM.
SO WE DO NOT OBJECTTO
PROTECTIONS AND OVERSIGHT ON
PRINCIPLE HOWEVER WE FIND IT
DISCONCERTING TO BE THE SUBJECT
OF RESTRICTIONS CRAFTED BY THE
DEBT COLLECTOR TO GET TRULY
REPRESENT CONSUMERS. AS OPPOSED
TO AN OBJECTIVE REGULATED
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE FBI OUR
OVERARCHING CONCERN HERE RELATE
TURRITELLIDAE TO CONTINUE TEXAS
CONSUMERS EFFECTIVELY LOOKING
FORWARD EVEN WITH THAT MANAGE
PROPOSED TODAY AT TEN THE NINE
WITH FINALLY A ROAD THAT
ABILITY BY SEPARATING BAGHDAD
THE OBJECT OF COMBATIVITY
GENERALLY REPRESENTS. SENDING
COMMUNICATIONS OF THE CONSUMER
IS NOT IDEAL BUT IT IS A
FUNCTION OF FEDERAL LAW THAT
COULD BE CLEAR AS LONG AS
FEDERAL LAW REMAINS THE SAME
AMENDING CALIFORNIA LOTS
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL WOULD
ONLY SERVE AS A GIFTED THAT
COLLECTOR. AND HER CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS OPT FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU. TO
VOTE NOW TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUT. ADDITIONAL
CALLERS. MISTER WRITER PLEASE
HELP UP THE PHONE LINES FOR.
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO SHOW THEIR OPPOSITION
FOR A BEACON EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB TEN
EIGHTY NINE AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE. ONE FIFTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. YOUNG YOU ONE FIFTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO ADMIN I
THINK ABOUT CHRISTIANITY ON
BEHALF OF ENCORE CAPITAL GROUP
INC MY APOLOGIES I WAS HAVING
DIFFICULTY GETTING ON DURING
THE SUPPORT PORTION. ENCORE
CAPITAL GROUP INC IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR TEN EIGHTY NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. C. NINE
I WANNA I WANNA THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON THIS IS THE
SECOND TIME IN FACT THAT WE
HAVE SEEN THIS BILL. IN TWO
YEARS AND EACH TIME IT GETS A
LITTLE BIT BETTER SO I THINK
YOU I THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M VERY HAPPY
DISAPPOINTED TODAY SO WITH
THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION CHEN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ADVICE THANK YOU I BELIEVE THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED-
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS AB TEN EIGHTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAP
HI CHAO I KILEY. KILEY NO POWER
QUE HAN. BENNETT OKAY SENATE HI
CORREA CUNNINGHAM- CUNNINGHAM
HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER IN NOT VOTING IRWIN
HI EVERYONE I LEE. LEE NOT
VOTING WITH WICKS AT. WITH THE
LOCALE MISTER SECTOR AT SIX
FORTY SIX FOR THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK. NEXT
LET'S FIGURE OUT WHO LET'S SEE
IS HERE- LOOKS LIKE MR BERMAN
IS HERE YOUR NUMBER TWO ON THE
LIST. SO WELCOME. AND MR BERMAN
HAS SOUGHT AB. THREE NINETY.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED. AND THIRD IT. IS
THEREFORE SUCH AS THIRTY SIX- I
WILL KEEP THIS AS SHORT AS
POSSIBLE IT IS A BIT OF A
COMPLICATED BILL- I'D LIKE TO
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FIRSTLY FOR THE HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE FOR TWO YEARS IN A
ROW AS SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL I
AUTHORED A SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR THAT
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND OFF OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR.
WITH OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL STALLED IN
THE SENATE DUE TO COVE IT- AB
THREE NINETY WOULD IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS
ABOUT WHEN AND HOW THEIR CHARGE
FOR SUBSCRIPTIONS AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR CONSUMERS TO CANCEL
THEIR SUBSCRIPTIONS ONLINE
WITHOUT HAVING TO JUMP THROUGH
TOO MANY HOOPS. AB THREE NINETY
WOULD DO TWO THINGS FIRST WOULD
REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO NOTIFY
CONSUMERS BEFORE THE EXPIRATION
OF A FREE GIFT TRAWLER
PROMOTIONAL OR DISCOUNTED PRICE
THAT IS LONGER THAN THIRTY ONE
DAYS BEFORE THE EXPIRATION OF A
SUBSCRIPTION THAT AUTOMATICALLY
RENEWS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS OR
LESS FREQUENTLY. SECOND TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS DO NOT
HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH TOO MANY
HOOPS IN A DOOR LIKE THE
CANCELLATION PROCESS THE BILL
SPECIFIES A CONSUMERS MUST BE
ABLE TO CANCEL THEIR
SUBSCRIPTIONS ONLINE AT WILL
AND WITHOUT ANY FURTHER STEPS
THAT OBSTRUCT OR DELAY THEIR
ABILITY TO CANCEL IMMEDIATELY.
I'VE GOT A WHOLE LIST OF THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION I'M
GONNA SKIP THEM FOR NOW HAPPY
TO DIVE INTO THEM IF ANYBODY
HAS ANY QUESTIONS WITH ME TODAY
BY PHONE IS MATT BELTRAME- THE
HEAD OF CONSUMER PROTECTION IN
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S. OFFICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK VERY MUCH I- LET'S
GO OUR FIRST WITNESS MISS OFF
MATTHEW ABOUT TRYING TO BECOME
MORE I'M SORRY WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEPUTY DA ARE YOU ON THE
LINE SIR. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT
BELTRAME WELL I'M AN ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NOW ME COUNTY
I SPEAK TODAY. ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTED DISTRICT THREE. NOW A-
PART OF AB THREE NINETY AYE SIR
FOR TWELVE YEARS THE IS OFFICE
IN THE CONSUMER PROTECTION UNIT.
AND LINK SEVERAL CASES ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE SAY THE
CALIFORNIA. AMONG THE STATUTE
ARE PRETTY CLEAR RISE IN OUR
CASES CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMATIC
RENEWAL LAW. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEGISLATION
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL CONTRACT CAN
IN MY EXPERIENCE BE TRAPS FOR
THE UNWARY WHICH CAN RESULT IN
BONTA SOMETIMES YEARS OF I
NOTICED CREDIT CARD CHARGES. C.
A. R. L. REQUIRES COMPANIES
THAT WISH TO ENTERTAIN SUCH
CONTRACTS WITH CONSUMERS TO
MAKE CERTAIN DISCLOSURES AND
THEN CAME AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT.
PERSONALLY HANDLE THE NUMBER OF
CIVIL IN WHICH COMPANIES WERE
LEADS TO HAVE VIOLATED THIS
LAW. MY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
COLLEAGUES AROUND THE STATE
PARTICULARLY THOSE- IN THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOMATIC RENEWAL
TASK FORCE HAVE BROUGHT OTHER
ACTIONS AGAINST LARGE COMPANIES
AS WELL. THE AUTOMATIC RENEWAL
LAW HAS BEEN A REAL ASSET TO
CONSUMERS IN OUR STATE IT
EXEMPLIFIED CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
AS A LEADER IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION. OVER TIME PROPERLY
COUNCIL BUSINESSES HAVE COME.
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOLLOWING ALONG. THE A. R. L.
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN HOWEVER IS
NOT PERFECT. SOME OLDER MAIN
FOR EXAMPLE NOTHING CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES COMPANIES TO NOTIFY
CONSUMERS WHEN THEY'RE ABOUT TO
BE CHARGED EITHER AT THE END OF
A FREE TRIAL PERIOD. OR AT THE
TIME OF AN ANNUAL RENEWAL I
THINK THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CONSUMER TRANSACTIONS THESE
DAYS ARE COMPLETED ONLINE SUCH
NOTIFICATIONS WOULD BE
INEXPENSIVE AND EASY TO
AUTOMATE. ALSO ALTHOUGH THE
STATUTE IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
REQUIRES A COMPANY THAT OFFERS
AN AUTOMATIC RENEWAL CONTRACT
ONLINE ALSO TO MAKE
CANCELLATION ONLINE. WE'VE SEEN
THAT MANY COMPANIES MAKE
CANCELLATION TRICKY OR TIME
CONSUMING REQUIRED CONSUMERS TO
JUMP THROUGH HOOPS TO STOP. THE
CHARGES TO THEIR CREDIT CARD
ACCOUNTS. DISTRICT ATTORNEY
O'MALLEY SAID AB THREE NINETY
BE IT'S- THE SIMPLER CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAW. BY HELPING TO
PLUG THE HOLES. FIRST IT
REQUIRES A BUSINESS NOTIFIED
CUSTOMERS BEFORE HIS OR HER
CREDIT CARD IS CHARGED EITHER
AT THE CONCLUSION OF A FREE
TRIAL PERIOD. OR DURING THE ON
ANNUAL RENEWAL PERIOD. GIVING
CONSUMERS SUCH NOTICE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THEY KNOW WHEN AND
HOW MUCH THEY WILL BE CHARGED.
IN AVOID THE SURPRISES THAT
AUTHORIZED WHEN BUSY CONSUMERS
FORGET THEY HAVE ROLLED AND
SOMETIMES EXPENSIVE PROGRAMS.
SECOND THE BILL MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT CONSUMERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CANCEL AUTOMATICALLY A
CONTRACT AT WILL. WITHOUT
HAVING TO ENGAGE IN STEPS THAT
WILL DISTRACT OR DELAY THEIR
ABILITY TO DO SO. YOUR REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE A METHOD
OF TERMINATION THAT IS NOT
HIDDEN OR HARD TO FIND. AND IT
WILL HELP CLOSE THOSE WHO. AT
SOME CONSUMER THAT SOME
BUSINESSES REQUIRE CONSUMERS TO
JUMP THROUGH IN ORDER TO
CANCEL. THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE LAW. VANCE
THE INTERESTS IF YOU WERE
PROTECTION WITHOUT PLACING AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON INDUSTRY. ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
RESPECTFULLY. I DOUBT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCHSIR-
SEEING NOBODY HERE IN THE ROOM
OR AT THE REMOTELOCATION A%
WISH TO TESTIFY. LET'S. GO TO
OUR PHONE LINE. UP MISTER
REITER OPEN UP THE LINES A- TO
CALLERS PLEASE YOUR AND ALSO
WITH THE ORGAN YOU REPRESENT IF
APPLICABLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I LADIES
DON'T YOU LIKE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THREE NINE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE A
PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL BEGIN WITH- ONE POINT
FIFTY SIX PLEASE CALL AT. HELLO
KAREN EMBERS DANIELLE CANDOR
CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. OVERLIE. ONE
EIGHTEEN. I COULD BE A
COCKROACH CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND JUNK REPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. AS A
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY JURY SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB THREE NINETY.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET US GO TO
OPPOSITION BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
pWITNESSES- IT'S IN OPPOSITION
FIRST. OF CAMERON- DIMITRI WITH
TECHNIP ARE YOU ON THE LINE
MISDEMEANOR. YES I AM SURE TO
HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY EGGMAN SHARED
MEMBERS CAME TO MEET HIM TO
HELP PROTECT THAT. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS OF THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TECHNET RESPECT PLEASE
TAKE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
ADDITIONAL AB THREE NINETY.
THOUGH WELL INTENTIONED BILL
PLACES A SERIES OF COMPLIANCE
CHALLENGES THAT WILL
UNINTENTIONALLY IMPOSE
SUBSTANTIAL UNNECESSARY COSTS
ON BUSINESS WERE ALREADY DOING
THE RIGHT THING. WE HAVE A FEW
OPTIONS COMPARE FIRST AB NINETY
IN A CONSUMERS WITH THE NOTE.
LEADING TO NOTICE FIFTY. I
CAN'T LANGUAGE OF AB THREE IS
ON REGARDING THE INTO OF ANY
CAN'T. CONSUMERS NOT BE ABLE TO
VIEWS FREE TRIAL OR
SUBSCRIPTION AGREEMENTS THAT
ALLOW THEM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
PREFERENTIAL RATES. TODAY HAVE
A RIGHT TO CANCEL IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SUBSCRIPTION TERM. IT'S
GREAT SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
CONCERNS BOB THIS IS GIVEN THAT
THESE TYPES OF SUBSCRIPTION
DROPPED IN PRICE BASED ON THE
TERMS OF SUBSCRIPTION. FINALLY
THE BILL SAYS COMPANIES MAY
REQUIRE BUSINESS TO
AUTHENTICATE CONSUMER BEFORE
CANCELLATION BUT ALSO CREATES A
LOOP OFF THE CONSUMERS ARE
WILLING. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE SOME
COMPANIES OFFER SUBSCRIPTIONS
TO IDENTITY PROTECTION SERVICES
THE ANTIVIRUS SOFTWARE. FOR
EXAMPLE LET'S NOT BE SURPRISED
IF ALL HARM HE CALLED AGAIN TO
BOTH OF THESE SERVICES WILDLIFE
KNOWLEDGE. IN TURN HE COULD
STEAL HER IDENTITY AND OPEN OR
CLOSE REYES ACCOUNT AND HER
NAME. BEYOND THAT DIMENSION
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH AN EMAIL
SERVICE TO SAY HE CAN'T
REMEMBER THE PASSWORD THERE'S
LESS YOU KNOW IN THAT CASE THE
EMAIL SERVICE WOULD ASK THE
SUBJECT OF RECENT EMAILS. THAT
SENT TO GET THERE I RECEIVED AN
EMAIL CANCELING MY SUBSCRIPTION
TO THE IDENTITY PROTECTION AND
ANTI VIRUS SOFTWARE. IT WOULD
BE A VALID AUTHENTICATION. AND
IT COULD CHANGE HIS LIFE YOU
KNOW PASSWORD. TO BE LOCKED
OUT. HE WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
YOUR EMAIL ACCOUNT. IS ACTUALLY
THE LACK OF AUTHENTICATION CAN
CREATE CASCADING ACCOUNT LONG
ABILITIES WHICH BAD ACTORS CAN
USE TO EXPLOIT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. FOR THESE REASONS
TAKEN AT RESPECTFUL THE- ADDED
TO THIS BILL. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OPERA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SECOND WITNESSES- MISTER
TIMOTHY JOHNSON WITH
ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION. ARE YOU ON THE
LINE WAS JOHNSON. I AM MISTER
SHARE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
AFTER CHURCH MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
WRECKED IN SOFTWARE SO. I AM
TODAY. TO THOSE THAT NEED THREE
ADDS READ. ENTERTAINMENT SO
SERVES AS THE VOICE AND
ADVOCATE THE AUSTIN UNION. YES
A MEMBER COMPANIES ARE
PUBLISHERS OF MANNINGS THAT
MANY OF THE LARGEST TITLES
THEY'RE MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
VIDEO GAME COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA A LOT MAKE MY
REMARKS TO RESPOND YES YES
CONCERNS WITH AB THREE NINETY
BUT WE LIKE TO FOCUS ON ONE
PARTICULAR IN OUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY. REQUIREMENT THAT
WOULD PERMIT A USER TO CANCEL
HIS OR HER SUBSCRIPTION WITHOUT
AUTHENTICATING THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL IF THE ACCOUNT
HOLDER IN THE VIDEO GAME
CONTACT THE SECURE USER ACCOUNT
IS THAT TOUCH POINT THROUGH
WHICH CONSTRUCTION SUMER
INTERACTS OF THE GAME PUBLISHER
OR THE GAME SERVICE OPERATOR
TO. CUSTOMIZE THEIR ACCOUNT
PREFERENCES CONTACT CUSTOMER
SUPPORT COMPLETE FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS SUCH AS PURCHASING
DOWNLOADABLE CONTENT OR
SUBSCRIBING TO AN ONLINE GAME
AND LASTLY CANCEL SERVICES OR
CLOSE THEIR ACCOUNT. BECAUSE
MANY MANY OF THESE INTERACTIONS
MAY INVOLVE THE EXCHANGE OF
PERSONAL DATA INCLUDING IN SOME
CASES THE COLLECTION OF CREDIT
CARD INFORMATION BECOMES CAN
ONLY BE ACCESSED WITH
APPROPRIATE CREDENTIALS. FOR
EXAMPLE A USER NAME AND
PASSWORD. FROM SECURITY THIS
MAY PERFECT YOU KNOW WANT ONE
AUTHORIZED. MAKE ON ALL CHARGE
ON YOUR WILL YOU IN YOUR DAY
AUTHENTICATION ABOUT PROTECTING
THE USER SAFE. AGAINST FRAUD
WHICH CAN HURT NOT ONLY THE
PUBLISHER BUT OTHER USERS AS
WELL. BASED ON OUR REVIEW OF
INDUSTRY PRACTICES YES HE IS
NOT AWARE OF ANY WAY IN WHICH
OUR MEMBERS CAN ENABLE
CANCELLATION OF SERVICES
WITHOUT AUTHENTICATING THE
USER'S IDENTITY. AS AN
AUTHORIZED USER WHICH IS
CRITICAL FOR SECURITY PURPOSES.
DEPARTMENT CANCELLATION WITHOUT
AUTHENTICATION WOULD OPEN THE
DOOR TO SOCIAL ENGINEERING
EXPLOITS THAT COULD LEAD TO
ACCOUNT FRAUD. YES THEY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH A
SPONSOR IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
CRAFT A LAW THAT PROTECTS
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. WILL ALSO
ALLOWING FOR INNOVATION AND
GROWTH IN OUR INDUSTRY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY THANK THANK YOU SIR- WITH
THAT LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL CALLERS.
IN OPPOSITION. TO AB THREE
NINETY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I HAVE TO SHOW THEIR OPPOSITION
AB THREE NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY A GIRL. WILL
BEGIN NOW WITH ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DON HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IF THERE ARE. ANY
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO QUEUE UP
FOR OUR TO SHOW THEIR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO ONE ONE ONE ZERO THREE
PLEASE CALL AT. HELLO GRMAN
PRESIDENT SHRUB ON THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
STRUCTURE. THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER OFF READER LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- AS FAR CAN'T GO AHEAD
PLEASE. I THANK THE AUTHOR. YOU
KNOW THE CONSUMER IN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS IT
JUST REALLY. BOTHERS ME. THESE
AUTO RENEWALS KEEP HAPPENING
WHEN I CHOOSE TO UNSUBSCRIBE IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO DO SO I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS GOOD GOVERNMENT
IT'S BEST FOR PROTECTION
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS. SO I
WOULD ASK TO BE ADDED TO COOPER
THANK YOU MR BERMAN. I'D BE
HONORED THANK YOU. I JUST
MISSED A PANIC AHEAD. I WOULD
ECHO THE SENTIMENTS ABOUT- THE
NEED TO HAVE SOME US SOME OTHER
WAY TO BE ABLE TO CANCEL AND TO
MAKE IT EASIER- AND I HAVE
GREAT RESPECT FOR YOUR ABILITY
TO WORK WITH OF THOSE
ADJOURNMENT ISSUES BROUGHT UP
ABOUT THE SECURITY OF MAKING
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
ABLE TO USE THIS TAX STUFF SO
CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MISSPENT. MISS WICKS PLEASE.
JUST ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM A ORINDA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL.
I THINK IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE
I WOULD LOVE TO BE AT THIS CO
AUTHOR. MUST BE SUPPORTED. I'LL
BE HONEST THIS MUCH. MISTER
DAVID GO AHEAD YEAH I'LL JUST-
I GUESS ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
EVERYONE IF THEY THINK IT'S AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURE. I THINK
THERE'S A FEW THINGS FEWER
THERE ARE NOT VERY MANY THINGS
THAT DRIVE ME NUTS MORE. FROM
THE FROM YOUR BILL TRYING TO
ADDRESS ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK
ABOUT AS A PROBLEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ZERO. SEEING HOW
MUCH OF THIS COMMITTEE HI.
RIGHT IN HERE'S PRETTY FRESH
THE FAILURE ALL WELL I ALSO
IDENTICAL TO COME. MAY I WANNA
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR WORK KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
BILL FOR A LONG TIME AND I
TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR- CONTINUE
WORK. LSU YOU YOU PASSED THE
YOU KNOW WHAT HAS TO YOUR BILL
TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN AND YOU
KNOW YOU CONTINUE EFFORT IS
REALLY A TRULY APPRECIATED THE
BY ALL OF US AND IN FACT SO
WITH THAT THAT WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS I DO I WOULD DO PLEDGE
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE HAD. DOZENS OF
CONVERSATIONS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS-
THAT THEY RAISE THAT I THINK-
YOU KNOW OUR ARE REASONABLE AND-
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED AND RESPECT
AFTER AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE WORLD MISTER CHAIRMAN. I
JUST LIKE TO REQUEST TO BE
ADDED TO BE HONEST. WOULD LOVE
THAT THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT.
WHO ELSE HAS NO. ADDED TO BE
ADDED. GALA HUNTING. WELL DONE
THIS GUY WON'T MUCH. I AM GOING
TO VOTE FOR THE BILL THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
ASSEMBLY INSIDE GREAT WITH
THAT- MISTER DOCTOR SECRETARY
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AT
THIS IS AB THREE NINETY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
FLOOR. CHAPTER I SHALL I KILEY
KILEY I'VE OUR QUE HAN. OKAY
HAND I'VE DONE IT HI BENNETT I
CARILLO. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HI GABRIEL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER
OKAY. GALLAGHER I. IRWIN- WHEN
I LEE. WHICH ONE WHERE ARE YOU
OKAY EXACT. SURE HAS NINE BUT
OKAY NOT NINE VOTES ARE YOUR
BILL AS I THINK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS EVERYBODY. SO THAT
BRINGS US TO- ITEMS SIX MISTER
CHIU. AB. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
NUMBER. SIX WELCOME MISTER CHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR SEEKS TO STRENGTHEN
PATIENT CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
NOT THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER
FOR THE INSURANCE. PEOPLE ON
THEIR SPOUSES PLAN OR YOUNG
ADULTS ON THEIR PARENTS PLAN.
IN THOSE INSTANCES THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER MAY RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT CARE THAT A
PATIENT MAY NOT WANT REVEALED.
IN SOME CASES IT COULD BE EVEN
DANGEROUS FOR THAT PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER TO RECEIVE THIS
INFORMATION. THE WOMAN
ACCESSING REPRODUCTIVE CARE OR
CARE RELATED TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENT MAY NOT WANT
HER PARENTS AND OUR PARTNER TO
KNOW. A TRANSGENDER YOUTH MAY
NOT WANT THEIR PARENTS TO KNOW
THAT THEIR TRANSITIONING OR
ACCESSING GENDER AFFIRMING
HEALTH CARE. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
THE PATIENT TO REQUEST
INFORMATION THAT RELATED TO THE
SERVICES NOT BE SENT TO A
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER THROUGH A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
REQUEST. UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
NO STANDARDIZED CCR PROCESS SO
FOLLOW THROUGH HAS BEEN BURIED
AND HAPHAZARD. IT'S CONFOUNDING
PLANTS WITH THE STATE IF
INSURANCE COMPANIES FAIL TO
ACCOMMODATE THE REQUEST BUT BY
THAT TIME THE DAMAGE IS DONE.
THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE UPON
EXISTING PROTECTIONS IN TWO
MAJOR WAYS FIRST IT WOULD
ESTABLISH AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS FOR
SENSITIVE SERVICES ENSURING
THAT PRIVACY IS NOT VIOLATED.
AND SECOND IT EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF SENSITIVE
SERVICES TO INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE AND TRANSGENDER
HEALTHCARE TO INSURE MORE
PEOPLE CAN HAVE PRIVACY
PROTECTED. MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS ANY
REMAINING CONCERNS. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT ALL OF US AGREE
THAT WE DON'T WANT ANY PATIENT
TO AVOID CRITICAL CARE TO
PREVENT A POLICY HOLDER FROM
FINDING OUT ABOUT THE CARE. AND
WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESS MOLLY ROBSON
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA. I YES
UP FOR- LET'S SOME OF WITHOUT
FIRST WITNESS- MISS ROBSON GO
AHEAD. DESTRUCTION ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. MR OPERATOR CAN YOU
CHECK TO SEE IF- MISS MOLLY
ROBSON IS ON THE LINE. EIGHT
ONE MOMENT. LOOKING. FOLLOW
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- YOU WANT TO
GO AHEAD DESPITE MUTE YOUR
PHONE IT'S YOUR PROBABLY MUTED
ON YOUR AND MOLLY. MISTER CHAIR
SHE IS CONNECTED WITH WINE-
MALI. FOR SOME REASON TODAY
WE'VE BEEN HAVING A LOT OF
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES SEEMS.
SHE'S ON SHE'S ON AND COMPUTER
THIS MISTRUST AND UP TO WHERE.
MISS ROBSON ARE YOU THERE.
MAYBE WE CAN CIRCLE BACK WITH
HER- YEAH SHE IS ON THE WELL.
CAN WE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OTHER SUPPORTERS. AND THEN COME
BACK TO MISS ROBSON. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU ARE PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW YES SIR THE L. A. B. YES I
DO OKAY AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU FOR OUR SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WILL LIE
ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CANYON MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE THANK YOU BYE. NINE
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FRANKLIN JOHN BEHALF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN IS
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. OKAY NOW
MISTER CHAIR MOLLY CHEWED UP-
SHE DID HAVE TO DO THAT SORT OF
SHE WAS ALREADY OPEN AS THIS IS
THE- PERSON SO I'LL JUST GO
AHEAD AND ON MUTE YOUR LINE SO
YOU CAN SPEAK OKAY. WHAT A
SOFTWARE LINE GO AHEAD MOLLY
HERE GO UP IN YOUR LIFE. HI
SORRY ABOUT THAT CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES. OKAY GREAT I'M SO SORRY-
GOOD AFTERNOON BY REDFIN WITH
PLANNED HOW TO PLAY AT THE
CALIFORNIA- WE REPRESENT THAT
SEVEN. ACROSS THE STATE WHO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION- PATIENT-
YEAH- YOU'RE NOT A FUN THING
EIGHTY ELEVEN IN THE- TO
CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT WORK
THAT ADVOCATE THE LAWMAKERS
UNDERTOOK IN THE PAST. SB ONE
THREE EIGHT EIGHT YEARS AGO. I
THANK THAT PASSED. A BILL
CONTINUE TO FIND IT DIFFICULT
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW. AGAIN CONFIDENTIALITY
FOR THEIR HEALTHCARE. FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S HEALTH
CENTERS CONFIDENTIALITY ABOUT
THE CORE OF ITS ROLE AS A
TRUSTED HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
PATIENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS SENSITIVE SERVICES LIKE
REPRODUCTIVE CARE GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES RAFFI I CARE WITHOUT
FEAR OF HAVING A PRIVATE
INFORMATION EXPOSED. WHEN
PATIENTS SEEK CARE THEY MAY NOT
REALIZE THAT THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR CARE THEY RECEIVE
COULD BE THIS CLOSE BY REACHING
NOTED THAT FROM THE HEALTH
INSURER. IT IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
FOR MINOR THAN YOUNG ADULTS ARE
ON THEIR PARENTS PLANS. ANYONE
WHO HAS HAD TO NAVIGATE
COVERAGE ISSUES WITH THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE NOW BUT IT IS
NOT A SIMPLE OR EASY PROCESS.
AND THE CENTRE LINE OTHER
PEOPLE FOR THEIR HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE NOT HAVE TO PLAN IN
ADVANCE AND THEN WITH THE HELP
OF CONSUMER RIGHTS ADVOCATES
AND ATTORNEYS. TO ENSURE. THAT
THEY CAN GET THE MEDICAL CARE
THEY NEED. HEALTH CARE. AND
CONFIDENTIAL IS CRITICAL. TO
ENSURING THAT ALL PACE CAN
CONTINUE TO ASK. NEEDED
SERVICES. YOUR JUDGMENT ABOUT
HOW DECISIONS. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WILL SET THE- POSITION TO
BE ONE. OR PLANS RECOMMEND. TO
THE PATIENT RATHER THAN THE
PRIMARY SUBSCRIBER OF THE PLAN.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
KEPT SAFE FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE PROUD TO FIVE EIGHT ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR ENTERED YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATCHA. AT THIS POINT I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM HERE-
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE TELL US YOUR NAME
AND THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT IF APPLICABLE PLEASE.
THANK YOU AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR TO SHOW YOURS.
WORK ON THIS BILL AND WITH A
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CALIFORNIA PARTY
SEPTEMBER SIX ISLANDS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
I'M SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB. ONE ONE EIGHT
FOUR. AND NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU IT'S
GOOD OPPOSITION STARTING WITH
JET HAMPTON WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
LOCATION OF HEALTH PLANS- ARE
YOU ON THE LINE MISTER MISTER
HAMPTON. YES I AM GOOD
AFTERNOON LESTER SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I JUST CAN'T
STAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS-
BRADLEY WE ARE HERE OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR AND
LASTED AMENDED. I PERSONALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SINCERELY THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE AUTHOR STAFF
IN THE SPONSORS FOR THEIR
TRANSPARENCY AND WORKING WITH
WORKING WITH US- IN GOOD FAITH
TO RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE SPELL I WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD TO DATE. HOWEVER
I AND PRACTICE. WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
SPECIFICALLY YEAH WE ARE-
RESPECTFULLY. I REQUEST
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT. TO THE
BILL. THAT WOULD SPECIFY THAT A
PLAN OR INSURER HAS NOT
RECEIVED A CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION REQUEST. FROM THE
ENROLLEE OR THE INSURED. THAT
THE CLIENT CAN CONTINUE TO
DIRECT THE CONFIRMATION TO THE
CURRENT ADDRESS ON FILE. AS
LONG AS THE COMMUNICATION IS
ADDRESSED DIRECTLY TO THE
INDIVIDUAL AND HOLY OR INSURED
WHO RECEIVED THE SERVICE. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS COMPLICATION
IT'S CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
HELP MANAGERS CONTINUE TO MEET
THEIR STATUTORY. AND LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE. HEALTH
INFORMATION TO THEIR MEMBERS
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT THEY-
ENSURING THE PRIVACY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL OR. THE IN RALEIGH-
IS PROTECTED. ADDITIONALLY ARE
ALSO A THAT THAT DON'T GO
DELAYED. DATE TO HELP THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES. UPDATE
THEIR ALSO SOME- AND
APPROPRIATELY TRAIN THEIR STAFF
TO ENSURE- THAT WE ARE.
FOLLOWING THE LAW AS WRITTEN
AND CONTINUE COOLEY GREAT- SO-
WITH THAT BEING SAID AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE TO DATE BUT AT AS FOR THE
BILL AND DROP WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO IT MUST
TO DEFEND IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ARE SECOND WITNESSES
STEPHANIE WATKINS- AS WALK INS
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YEAH HM
NUMBER STEPHANIE WHAT CAN BUT
THE AT. IN THE CALIFORNIA AND
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES. WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL PRINT
TODAY BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR SPONSORING
COMMITTEE STAFFER THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US IN
THE OPEN DIALOGUE. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND I'D LIKE
TO ECHO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS AND JUST REINFORCED
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO GET THIS
RIGHT. AND ENSURE THAT PLANT
MANAGER CONSOLE PROCESS AND
PROVIDE IMPORTANT HEALTHCARE
<c.red>NFORMATION AND NOTICES TO OUR</c>
MEMBERS BUT ALSO PROTECT THE
INDIVIDUAL PATIENT PRIVACY.
WITHOUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR BONTA CHEAPEST POSSIBLE
CALL- I'M A PART OF THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE
NOBODY HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
LIKE TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION
LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
MISTER OPERATOR FOR COLLEGE IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU TO SHOW
OPPOSITE IN ABIA. EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
TO AB. ONE ONE EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND I NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S BRING
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION- COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. BILL'S BEEN
MOVED. TO HAVE A SECOND. IT
SECOND IT UP. ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SOME
A MEMBER CHIU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND FOR WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND ENSURING THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN KEEP THEIR
MEDICAL INFORMATION PRIVATE IS
A BASIC RIGHT AND BUT NOT
ALWAYS EASY TO CHEAT TO ACHIEVE
I WAS PROUD I WAS PROUD TO
SUPPORT US THE ONE THIRTY FOUR
IN YOU KNOW A FEW YEARS AGO AND
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS THIS
BILL TODAY SO WITH THAT- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. BY WOULD
APPRECIATE NAGO. A MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
THIS IS AB ONE ONE EIGHT FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAPTER FIVE
SHALL I KILEY. KILEY VOTING
POWER QUE HAN RK HANNAH AYE
BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE CARILLO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER NO IRWIN HI- WHEN I
LEE. WICKS FIVE WICKS HI YOU
YOUR BILL IS UP I THINK YOU
HAVE SEVEN BOTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
FREEMAN. AND THANKS TO THE
COURTESY OF MISTER CUNNINGHAM-
PANELISTS FRIEDMAN HAS ITEM
ELEVEN YEAH IT IS I A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX AND I
APOLOGIZE I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
CONFUSION. PROBABLY MEANT AND A
WELCOME TO OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU IN YOUR COMMITTEE FOR
ALL OF YOUR VERY GOODWORK ON
THIS BILL WILL WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING THE MMS LISTEN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON PAGES
FOUR AND FIVE. THIS IS A BILL
THAT'S NOT A SPONSORED BILL
THIS IS A BILL THAT CAME OUT OF
COMPLAINTS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
OUR OFFICES- THAT REALLY
INCREASE DURING COVERT ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO HAD BOUGHT TICKETS
TO PERFORMANCES SOMETIMES VERY
EXPENSIVE PERFORMANCES AND HAD
THOSE POOR PERFORMANCES EITHER
CANCELED OR SUBSTITUTED OUT-
AND- WHEN PEOPLE WOULD TRY TO
GET THEIR MONEY BACK OFF AND
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO GET THERE
BUT THERE ARE GET A REFUND FOR
THOSE TICKETS- THEY WERE
INSTEAD OFFERED SUB TWO
PERFORMANCES AT A TIME WHEN
THEY REALLY JUST WANTED THE
MONEY BACK. SO THEY BUY TICKET
TO AEROSMITH AND SAID THAT THEY
WERE SUBSTITUTING KENNY G.
YOU'RE OUT A LOT- AND THAT WAS
SORT OF YOU KNOW ALLOWABLE- AND
THERE'S BEEN REALLY BECAUSE OF
COVERT THIS MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
UNANTICIPATED CANCELLATIONS OF
TICKETS BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE ON
THE CONSUMERS TO HAVE TO BEAR
THE BRUNT OF THAT COST THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET THEIR
MONEY BACK- NOW DURING KOBE
BECAUSE OF THE STRAIN THAT THAT
WAS PUTTING ON SOME OF OUR
LIVE. VENUES UNFORTUNATELY SOME
OF THEM WENT BACK AND
RETROACTIVELY CHANGE THEIR
CONTRACTS OF WITHOUT A YOU KNOW
A LEARNING CONSUMERS ARE GIVING
THEM ANY VOICE SO THEY WOULD
WERE THEY RE IT RETROACTIVELY
CHANGE THEIR CONTRACTS TO
REMOVE THE REFUND GUARANTEE IN
FAVOR OF A SUBSTITUTE
PERFORMANCES INSTEAD. SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT ENSURES
THAT TICKET BUYERS HAVE TO
RECEIVE THEIR REFUNDS WITHOUT
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE EVENT
CANCELLATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO GO AND BEG FOR THEIR
MONEY BACK THAT MONEY JUST HAS
TO BE GIVEN TO THEM. AND IT
ALSO- US SAYS THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE THE CHOICE OF GETTING A
REFUND IF THE- SHOW TO WHICH
THEY BOUGHT THE TICKET IS
SUBSTITUTED WITH A DIFFERENT
ARTIST OR DIFFERENT CHAU
ALTOGETHER- OFTEN ALSO-
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY BUY A
TICKET THAT. THE OF THE TICKETS
COMING FOR FROM AN- ON A-
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY THE THEATER.
AND THE LIMITS THE ABILITY OF
THE TICKET BUYER TO RESELL THE
TICKET OR TO GIVE IT AWAY. TO
SOMEBODY ELSE IF THEY CAN'T USE
IT YOU KNOW SOMETIMES WILL SAY
WELL I CAN'T USE THIS TICKET
I'M GONNA SELL IT OR I'M GONNA
GIVE IT TO A FRIEND. BUT THEIR
CONTRACT SAYS THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE TO BE THE PERSON THEY HAVE
TO SHOW I TO SAY THAT IT'S
THEM. THIS CLEAR FOR THIS A
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT THAT'S
MAKE CLEAR TO PEOPLE WHEN THEY
BUY IT. SO THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
WHEN THEY PURCHASE IT THAT
THAT'S THE CONTRACT THAT
THEY'RE ENTERING INTO. A WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ANYBODY WHO IS- ANY
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT ANYTHING IN THE BILL
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN AMENDMENTS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PROTECT
SUBSCRIPTION PURCHASES THAT
SORT OF THING- THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IS
SUPPORTING AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX
AND I WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THERE'S NO- PRIMARY
WITNESS FOR THIS BILL BUT I.
DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
EITHER SO LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES- MR OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORTERS. OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
SIX. THE BILL. THANK YOU MR
OPERATOR. ARE THERE ANY CALLERS
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT NOT AT THIS
TIME BUT WELL ARMED AGAIN TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
RESEARCHERS THERE'S STILL
NOBODY QUEUEING UP VERY GOOD
LET'S GOOD OPPOSITION I.
BELIEVE MISTER TIM LYNCH IS ON
THE LINE AND HE'S WITH
AMBASSADOR THEATRE GROUP ARE
YOU ON THE LINE MISTER LYNCH. I
AM YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. TIM
LYNCH ON BEHALF OF THE
AMBASSADOR THEATRE GROUP BASED
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND OWNING
OWNERS OF THE CURRENT THE
GOLDEN GATE NAY ORPHEUM
THEATERS- FIRSTLY LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY DO
RESOLVED- TO CONCERNS WE HAD
WITH THE BILL RELATED TO- OUR
SUBSCRIPTION BASED SERVICES AND
THE REPLACEMENT OF IDENTICAL
SHOWS AND THE ANALYSIS THAT A
NICE JOB WORKING THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES AND DESCRIBING THE
PROBLEMS AND THE AMENDMENTS DO
I RESOLVE THOSE. WE DO HAVE ONE
REMAINING CONCERN IS ALSO NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS REGARDING THE
THIRTY DAY DEADLINE TO RETURN
MONEY- TO THE CONSUMERS- WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND THE COMMITTEE ON
THAT AND WE'RE HOPEFUL WE CAN
FIND SOME RESOLUTION- IN THE
DAYS FORWARD AND- YOU MEAN TIME
WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE POSITION
UNTIL THAT REMAINING ISSUE IS
RESOLVED THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEE NOBODY HERE IN
THE ROOM OR AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION WHO WISH TO SPEAK- IN
OPPOSITION- MISTER OPERATOR.
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SHOW UP. FOR AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO FOR A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY
SIX. MR SURE NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP VERY GOOD- LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FOR THE AUTHOR. CNN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR I'LL WORK ON
THIS THIS IS A GREAT CONSUMER
BILL SO I WANNA THANK YOU AND
WITHOUT THE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THIS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE THEATER GROUPS
OF WHICH I HAVE MANY IN MY
DISTRICT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THIS IS WORKABLE FOR THEM WHILE
WE PROTECT CONSUMERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO WITH THAT THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
TO MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS AB ONE FIVE FIVE
SIX THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAPTER HI CHAO HI KILEY KILEY
AYE BARRICADE HIM POWER QUE HAN
AYE BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE
CARILLO. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GABRIEL GABRIEL
HI GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I IRWIN
HI- WHEN I WE- WICKS WICKS HI
YOU HAVE NINE VOTES THE BILL
WITHOUT YOU MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO BRINGS US TO. MR
CUNNINGHAM IS SNACKS. THAT'S
ITEM NINE AB. TWELVE SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TO THEM HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO OF LIKE TO
THINK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR EXCELLENT WORK
ON THIS BILL AB TWELVE SIXTY
TWO ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
CONSUMER PRIVACY PROTECTION FOR
USERS OF SMART SPEAKER DEVICES
THE INNOVATION AND TWENTY FIRST
CENTURIES TECHNOLOGY HAS
TRANSFORM LIVES SMART SPEAKERS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO EXECUTE A
TASK AT THE COMMAND OF A WAKE
WORD THIS TECHNOLOGY HAS
WIDESPREAD USE AND TREMENDOUS.
POTENTIAL TO BETTER OUR LIVES.
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION SMART
SPEAKERS TODAY HAVE BEEN SOLD
GLOBALLY. IT'S A MASSIVE MARKET.
HOWEVER SOME PEOPLE DO NOT
REALIZE THAT THESE DEVICES ARE
CAPABLE OF VOICE RECORDING AND
CLOUD STORAGE SOMETIMES WITHOUT
A WAKE WORD BEING USED OR
INTENTIONAL ACTIVATION BY. THE
USER. SIMPLY PUT AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO WOULD PROHIBIT A
SMART SPEAKER DEVICE FROM USING
RECORDINGS OR TRANSCRIPTIONS
THE QUALIFY AS PERSONAL
INFORMATION UNDER THE CCPA.
FROM BEING USED FOR AN
ADVERTISING PURPOSE SHARED WITH
A THIRD PARTY OR RETAINED
ELECTRONICALLY UNLESS THE
CONSUMER HAS OPTED IN WITH
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT IF THE
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT. THAN THOSE
PROVISIONS WOULD NOT APPLY TO
THAT DEVICE THERE'S TWO BORTON
THINGS TO NOTE ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL DIFFERS FROM LAST
SESSION'S VERSION WHICH DIED
FROM COVERT OR ENCODED RELATED
REASONS IN THE SENATE- THIS
BILL EXEMPTS ENTIRELY DE
IDENTIFIED DATA. OR DATA THAT
CANNOT BE LINKED TO A
PARTICULAR CONSUMER. SECONDLY
IT. APPLIES ONLY TO RECORDINGS
FROM SMART SPEAKERS AND WE'VE
TIGHTENED UP THE DEFINITION OF
A SMART SPEAKER DEVICE AND
CREATED A BUNCH OF EXEMPTION SO
YOUR CELL PHONE. IT WILL NOT BE
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL. PRIVACY
MY VIEW IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
NOR IS IT AN ISSUE WE CAN
IGNORE AS POLICY MAKERS WELL
THESE TECHNOLOGIES HAVE
IMPROVED OUR LIVES AND WILL
CONTINUE. TO AND WE ARE VERY
GLAD FOR THAT. WE MUST CREATE
BASIC SAFEGUARDS FOR CONSUMERS.
AND WE MUST ASSURE PEOPLE THAT
THE PRIVACY IN THEIR HOME WHERE
THE PRIVACY INTEREST IS AT ITS
ABSOLUTE PEAK. IS PROTECTED FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND I'D
LIKE TO TURN THIS OVER TO.
ARIEL FOX JOHNSON FROM
COMMONSENSE- TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
JOHNSON ARE YOU ON THE LINE. HI
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO SIR
YES YES GO AHEAD PLEASE MISS
JOHNSON. THANK YOU CARACALLA
NUMBERS WITH THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
I'M OUR OUTBOX JOHNSON YOUR
COUNSEL AT COMMON SENSE MEDIA
REPLACES THE PART AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO WHICH WOULD GIVE
FAMILIES MUCH NEEDED
PROTECTIONS OVER SMART SPEAKERS
WHICH SKY ROCKETED POPULARITY
LAST YEAR. BURKE SPEAKERS ARE
INCREASINGLY PLACE AND FAMILY
ROOMS KITCHENS AND EVEN KIDS
BEDROOMS. A PRICE POINT OF
UNDER SIXTY DOLLARS AND PANDA
DESIGNS CAN ENCOURAGE THIS. AND
SPEAKERS PERMANENT PERCH AND
SENSITIVE LOCATIONS AND THEIR
ABILITY TO LISTEN TO ANY SPOKEN
WORD MERIT SPECIAL PROTECTIONS.
FOR CONSUMERS FROM THE GET GO.
MANY OF THE DEVICES KEEP. AND
RECORD AND- INDEED SOME EVEN
KEEP INFORMATION CONSUMERS
THINK THEY HAD DELETED BY
MAINTAINING A TRANSCRIPT OR
DELETING AUDIO. EMPLOYEES CAN
LISTEN TO RECORDINGS AND
RECORDINGS AND TRANSCRIPTS CAN
BE USED COMMERCIALLY PROFILE
AND TARGET FAMILY. FAMILIES
LOVE THE CONVENIENCE OF THESE
DEVICES ESPECIALLY THIS PAST
YEAR BUT THEY WANT MORE CONTROL
ACCORDING TO A COMPETENT
CERVANTES PARTS BICKERED MORE
THAN NINE IN TEN PARENTS THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT MAKING CONTROL
THE INFORMATION COLLECTED ABOUT
THEIR FAMILY. YEP FAMILY FEEL
HELPLESS A THIRD SAID THAT
WHILE THEY'D LIKE TO LIMON
INFORMATION COLLECTION BY SUCH
DEVICES THEY DON'T KNOW HOW.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE FAMILIES
THE CONTROL THEY WANT IT WOULD
PROHIBIT COMPANIES FROM USING
INDIVIDUALS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE START SPEAKER
RECORDINGS. IN TRANSCRIPTIONS
FOR ADVERTISING IT WOULD
REQUIRE OPT IN CONSENT FOR
CONSUMERS. IF A COMPANY IS
THOUGHT OR SHARE THIS
INFORMATION FOR A NEW MOM I
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION FANS
THREE ABOUT HER BABY'S
DEVELOPMENT. IT DOESN'T WANT
THAT SENSITIVE. REQUIRE PAPERS
THIS BILL PROVIDES. FOR
FAMILIES WHO WANT TO KEEP A
CHILD LEARN JUST. PRIVATE BUT
STILL WANT THEIR KIDS TURNED A
DEVICE FOR SCHOOL HELP. THIS
BILL PROVIDES PROTECTION. WE
THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO
PRESS FOR A STRONG AND PRIVACY
PROTECTIVE BELL AN IDEA WHAT
THE COVER ALL SMART SPEAKER
DEVICES. BUT WE THINK THIS IS A
MEASURE TO CORPORATE AND
CRITICALLY NEEDED FIRST STEP
AND ASK THAT YOU VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL TO HELP INSURE
CONSUMERS DON'T HAVE TO
SACRIFICETHEIR PRIVACY AND
WELL BEING. IN ORDER TO MAKE
USE OF INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
ROOM. OR THE REMOTE LOCATION
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY SO
LET'S OPEN UP PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS. PLEASE
JUST TELL US YOUR NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT IF
APPLICABLES AUX MISTRUST
READER- THIS IS ON AB. TWELVE
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU SHOW
SUPPORT ON AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
GENERAL. AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH
LINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD MORNING THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG CALLING FROM OPEN TO
PRIVACY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWO SIX TWO THANK. THANKS
PLEASE. AND I'M SURE THERE IS
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD LET'S GO
TO OPPOSITION BELIEF- MISTER
CAMERON THE DIMITRI WITH
TECHNET IS OUR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS CAME BEACHAMAP
TECHNET TECHNET RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO AS
WE FIND IT IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
SEVERAL REASONS. FIRST LIST ALL
SINGLED OUT ONE TYPE OF VOICE
RECOGNITION FEATURE DEVICE
MARKETERS INTO VARIOUS TO TREAT
THEM DIFFERENTLY DISADVANTAGING
SOME BUSINESS MODELS OVER
OTHERS FROM ALL GOOD POLICY
RATIONALE. SECOND THIS BILL
DISCRIMINATED VOICE TECHNOLOGY
BY OBTAINING HAVE SHOWN FROM A
CUSTOMER'S ACTIONS TAKEN BY A
SMART SPEAKER. THIS WILL HAMPER
INVESTMENT IN INNOVATION OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY. THE CONSUMER
IF A CUSTOMER ORDERS GROCERIES
ONLINE BY TYPING THEY CAN BE
SHOWN ADS AND COUPONS FOR OTHER
PRODUCTS THEY MIGHT WISH TO
PURCHASE. BUT UNDER THIS BILL
IF THE CUSTOMER USES THEIR
VOICE TO ORDER GROCERIES VIA
THEIR SMART SPEAKER THEY
CANNOT. THERE IS NO PRIVACY
BENEFIT FOR THIS DISCRIMINATION
AND IN FACT DISADVANTAGES SOME
COMMUNITIES. CERTAIN THE AUTHOR
BRINGS UP THE CONCERN THAT
SMART SPEAKERS MIGHT BE
LISTENING TO PEOPLE WHEN THEY
SHOULD BE WE CALL THAT A FALSE
WAY. THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN IN FACT IT
COULD MAKE IT WORSE LEARNING
FROM FALSE WEIGHT DATA HELPS TO
PREVENT THEM FROM HAPPENING THE
LAST NAMES ARE NOT INTENDED.
FINALLY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES
CUSTOMERS TO OPT INTO THE
DEVICES FUNCTION PROPERLY. DOES
SO WITH PRESCRIPTIVE
AFFIRMATIVE WRITTEN CONSENT
THAT MAY REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO
STATE THINGS THAT ARE NOT TRUE
FOR THAT BUSINESS. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL REQUIRES CUSTOMERS TO
OPT IN FOR THE DEVICE TO SHARE
THEIR VOICE COMMAND WITH THAT
THIRD PARTY APPS FOR EXAMPLE IF
I ASK MY SPORTS SPEAKER. TO
PLAY A VIDEO OR SONG MY
FAVORITE STREAMING DEVICE DATA
SHARING DATA WITH A THIRD PARTY
ACCESSING THE FUNCTIONALITY. OF
AN APP OR WEBSITE YOUR VOICE IS
THE PURPOSE OF THE SMART
SPEAKER. AND ALSO THIS BILL
REQUIRES CUSTOMERS TO OPT INTO
THE DEVICE RETAINING DATA IF
SOMEONE DOES NOT OFTEN THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO CALL THEIR
CONTACTS PLAY MUSIC GLASS SHOP
PERHAPS SET UP TO TURN ON THEIR
LIGHTS. OKAY ALL OF THIS WILL
CREATE CUSTOMER CONFUSION
FRUSTRATION WITHOUT ADDRESSING
FALSE WICKS AND IT WILL HAMPER
INNOVATION IN THESE LIFE
CHANGING PRODUCTS FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SECOND WITNESSES SOLOMON
THREE PULLED. MY APOLOGIES SO
FOR MR PRONOUNCING YOUR NAME
WHAT. BILLION STRONG. NO MISTER
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS WHAT. FEW AND I'M TESTIFIED
IN OFFICE. TO A BEACH SIX TWO.
I AM THE CEO OF THE U. S. WHICH
IS A ORGAN. DEDICATED TO THE
EMPOWERMENT ANY CLUE OF WITH
THIS. I HAVE SPENT MY GONNA ACT.
AS A RESULT I NEED ASSISTANCE
WITH ALL OF MY ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING SUCH AS EATING
BATHING AND GETTING DRESSED.
AMABLE CON WHEELCHAIR USER. ARE
YOU SMART SPEAKERS CODE BLACK
AND UNLOCK MY DOORS WITH JEFF
ARAFAT. TO TURN ON A LIGHT AND
I USE THEM TO INDEPENDENTLY
MANAGE MY ENVIRONMENT. SMART
SPEAKERS FOR ME GREATER LEVELS
OF INDEPENDENCE AND PRIVACY.
IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND THE
BENEFITS OF THIS BILL
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU BALANCE
THEM AGAINST THE PROPER ACTION.
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES
PEOPLE. TO OPT IN IN ORDER FOR
THE DEVICE TO FUNCTION
PROPERLY. IT'S CONFUSING.
PEOPLE ONE UNDERSTAND THAT IF I
DON'T HAVE BEEN. I WON'T BE
ABLE TO CONTROL. LIFE. MY DOORS.
THE NEW. NONE OF THESE
FUNCTIONS WILL BE A- YOU LOOK
AT THE BILLS FAN A- MOTION AND
AVERAGE AND IT IS BASICALLY THE
TRUMP THE COMMAND IN BY MY
VOICE TO MATCH BECAUSE WILL
COME BEACH FROM. IF I BY
PRIVATE AT FIVE ONE OF ONE
RIGHT I CAN DO SO GOOD PROMOTE
BATES ON THAT. BUT DO THAT IF I
DO ABOUT BOYS. SCHOOLS ME THEM
SAYING WHAT THEY WILL AND
ACCESS THAT SENSE TO ME. WE
NEED ORGANIZED TO CONTINUE TO
IMPACT IN THE ADVANCE OF THESE
KINDS OF TECH. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY HAS ALWAYS
BEEN THE GREAT. EQUALIZER FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
ENCOURAGE AND THAT RIGHT THANK
YOU NOT DISCOURAGED. THESE
RESULTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
TO VOTE NO THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR- SEEN NOBODY HERE
IN THE- OR AT THE RIM LOOK. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN UP LET'S
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE. MR
OPERATOR PLEASE SIR- UP THE
LINE FOR CALLERS IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THEIR LINE NUMBERS. IN
LINE SIXTY EIGHT OR MY COULD
OPEN. I DON HOFFMAN ON BEHALF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
ENTERNEXT COMMENT COMES FROM A
LINE OF ONE SIXTY SIX. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS STEPHANIE MORE WHILE ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. ONE
ONE HUNDRED THREE. MIKE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
THANKS THANK YOU. NEXT PLACE.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD WITH THAT- LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMEDIAN
IS OR WHEN GO AHEAD- THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO- I THINK
THERE IS NOTHING MORE CREEPY
THAN WHEN- I HAVE. A
ADVERTISEMENT ON MY PHONE ABOUT
THE CONVERSATION I'M- HAVING I
HOPE THAT WAS ONLY A-
COINCIDENCE BUT- I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU ARE- WORKING ON BUT I
THINK THIS BILL. NEEDS SOME
FUNDAMENTAL WORK- LAST TIME I
BROUGHT IT UP LIGHT IT UP
STATE. AND- SUBNATIONAL COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT WERE MENTIONED
ALREADY BY THE OPPOSITION- THIS
BILL. ADOPTS A OFTEN RATHER
THAN AN OPT OUT AND THAT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT FROM WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND VOTERS HAVE
DONE WITH CCPA AND CPRE. AND
I'M REALLY CONCERNED THAT YOUR
BILL WILL HAVE- THAT THE IMPACT
YOUR BILL WILL HAVE ON THE
OPERATION OF SMART SPEAKERS.
WILL HAVE MORE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND BENEFITS FOR
CONSUMERS. PEOPLE WHO PURCHASED
SMART SPEAKERS- ARE ACTIVELY
SEEKING TO USE VOICE
RECOGNITION AND PUTTING
BARRIERS BETWEEN THEM AND- THE
PURCHASE FEATURES SEEMS
INTRUSIVE TO ME AND YOU HEARD
THAT FROM THE LAST SPEAKER AND
I CERTAINLY KNOW ALSO WITH MY
PARENTS WHO ARE IN THEIR
EIGHTIES THAT. THEY LOVE THE
EASE THAT THEY HAVE- WITH
THEIR- ALEXA. AND THEN I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT THEIR SPECIFIC.
LANGUAGE THAT- REALLY NEEDS TO
BE CARE IN THE FALL AND THAT'S
THE- BETWEEN BASIC FUNCTIONS
AND ENHANCE US MARKETERS SO.
SAME THING THAT I SAID THE LAST
TIME AND I'M CERTAINLY HOPING
THAT I CAN SUPPORT YOUR BILL ON
THE FLOOR. AND I WILL EXPLAIN.
PRINT OUT THIS WEEK'S GO AHEAD
PLEASE- AT FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
BILL UP- UP AGAIN AND I HAVE A
QUESTION AND A COMMENT- THE
SECOND SPEAKER. WOULD HE BE
ABLE TO USE ALL THESE
FUNCTIONALITIES SIMPLY BY
OPTING IN. YES UNDER UNDER THIS
BILL LANGUAGE IF THE- THE
INFORMED CONSENTS GIVEN AT THE
TIME OF SET UP OF THE DEVICE
AND IF THE- USER CHOOSES TO OPT
INTO THE ENHANCED FEATURES AS
THE FINE THEN THERE WOULD BE NO
LIMITATIONS WHATSOEVER- ON.
ANYTHING RIGHT RIGHT SO I THINK
THAT SOLVES. MAYBE NOT A 100%
OF THAT ISSUE BUT IT CERTAINLY
SOLVES A- LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
IT IN MOST USE CASES OKAY AND I
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW IT. AS
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES WHICH DOES
VERY RAPIDLY- IT IS OUR DUTY TO
TRY TO CATCH UP TO THAT FROM A
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT. FOR IT
FROM MY OPINION WITH AN EYE
TOWARDS PRIVACY- SO I KNOW IT'S
A COMPLICATED SUBJECT MATTER
YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED ON THIS
AND FOR A YEAR OR TWO IN THIS
SPACE- I WANT TO KEEP SEE THIS
BILL KEEP MOVING FORWARD AND I
KNOW THERE ARE STILL THINGS TO
WORK OUT. WHICH I HAVE NO DOUBT
YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM WILL BE
ABLE TO DO AND LOVE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR AND WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. MISTER BENNETT.
CHECK HI YOU HAVE. I APPRECIATE.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO WITH THE
BILL WANT TO. SURE THAT THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD THAT YOU.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON ADDRESS OF THESE
ISSUES. ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES
IS THE FACT THAT PEOPLE OFTEN
HE SAID ITSELF'S. NOT A 100%
BUT CERTAINLY VAST MAJORITY THE
PROBLEMS I HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THAT. SMALL
RESERVE- MY RIGHT TO. WHEN WE
GET WHEN IT GETS TO THE FLOOR
BUT I DO A LOT OF MOVE OUT HERE
SO YOU CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON.
THANK YOU. HE THERE ARE NO
ADDITION. COMMENTS WANT TO
THANK. MISTER CUNNINGHAM FOR.
YOUR CO CONTINUE WORK IN FACT I
THINK YOU STARTED MORE THAN TWO
YEARS AGO AND I TRULY. APPLAUD
YOUR WORK. AND THIS IS THE-
ISSUE THAT YOU CAN TRY TO. OF
TACKLE FOR AWHILE SO I. I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL OUT
ABSOLUTELY- I THINK- YOU KNOW
THE BILL PROBABLY NEEDS A
LITTLE FINE TUNING HEARING
THERE SO. SO I DO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONTINUE WORKING. HI THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE- TO ME
ALSO SO. SO WITH THAT THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES IF
I MAY I'LL TRY TO BE QUICK I
DID WANT TO DRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY TECHNO AND-
SOME OF THE VERY THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS BY. BY THE COMMITTEE-
YES IT'S TRUE THE STREETS A
TYPE OF DEVICE DIFFERENTLY BUT
THAT THAT DEVICE ITSELF IS
DIFFERENT. RIGHT THIS BUILDS ON
AN EXISTING CODE SECTION THAT
SAYS. TELEVISIONS ARE CONNECTED
TELEVISIONS CANNOT RECORD
PEOPLE- THEN THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THE SMART SPEAKERS ARE
STABLE IN THE USED IN THE HOME
THE HOUSTON BEDROOMS IN THE
USED IN KITCHENS JUST LIKE A TV
IS MOUNTED. OR PROPPED UP OR
SITTING. IN YOUR LIVING ROOM OR
IN YOUR KITCHEN SO. I ME
BECAUSE- BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THE DEVICE- I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THE- PRIVACY. PROTECTIONS
THAT THE USER NEEDS. ARE
COMMENSURATELY GREATER- IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN A KEYBOARD AND
TYPING IN THE KEY THE- TECH
THAT INDIVIDUALS TALKING ABOUT
KEYSTROKES AND SO FORTH. BUT
KEYBOARDS CAN'T RECORD YOUR
VOICE RECORDINGS AND SEND THEM
TO THE CLOUD TO BE STORED.
WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE IN AND
DISTRIBUTED. TO GOD KNOWS WHERE
ALL OVER THE EARTH AND THE
KEYBOARDS DON'T HAVE THOSE
FEATURES. SO IT IS DIFFERENT
BILL. THAT'S NECESSARILY SO.
AGAIN IF THE- DATA IS DE
IDENTIFIED THEN THERE'S NO.
LIMITATION WHATSOEVER ON THE
USE OF THAT. ARE A LOT OF SMART
SPEAKER MANUFACTURERS ALTHOUGH
NOT ALL BUT A LOT OF THEM ARE
DOING THAT ALREADY. SO I THINK
THAT'S APPROPRIATE WE'VE GOT
THAT- FINE TUNE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER- IT DOES NEED SOME WORK
AND I WANT TO GET TO A 100% ONE
OF THE COOLEST THINGS ABOUT
SMART. SPEAKERS SPEAKERS I'VE
WATCHED SOME VIDEOS AND
PRESENTATIONS. AND MY PARENTS
ARE GETTING THE AGE WHERE.
THEY'RE GONNA NEED THAT TYPE
OF. HELP AROUND THE HOUSE AS
WELL AND THAT'S- THAT'S REALLY
NEAT AND WE NEED TO PRESERVE
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING THAT.
INHIBITS THE FULL USE OF THAT
FOR PEOPLE THAT- MAYBE HAVE
LIMITATIONS- NO MATTER THE
SOURCE. SO THEY CAN ENJOY THE
FULL. BENEFIT OF IT- I THINK WE
CAN GET THERE AT AND I THINK
I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO KEEP
WORKING ON IT I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY GROUPS. AND ALL
THE DIFFERENT GROUPS ON- YOU
KNOW MODIFICATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS TO THE LANGUAGE.
YEAH MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUING TO DO THAT. I THINK
THE BILL YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT IN THE
LATTER. FIRST ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MUCH. THINK THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED- MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE BILL HAS BEEN IT HAS NOT
BEEN MET THANK YOU GO. THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU MEMBERS UP
WITH THAT MR SECRETARY- THIS IS
AB ONE TWO SIX TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CAPS
HI SHALL I KILEY. KILEY I'VE
OUR QUE. R. K. HAND HI BENNETT.
BENNETT I CARILLO. AREA I'VE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
GABRIEL. WELL I GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I IRWIN. LATE RIGHT
LEE HIGHWAY X. WICKS HI HI CAN
ATTENDANCE YOUR BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. STEP
BRINGS US TO THE NEXT AUTHOR
LET'S MAKE SURE I HAVE IT
CORRECTLY I BELIEVE IT IS MR
GABRIEL. ITEM. TWELVE FIVE FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. I'M SORRY- HOLD
ON JUST A SECOND. THREE OF US
OKAY- SHE'S BEEN WHAT OKAY.
OKAY SCOTT SORRY- I'M SORRY I
MISSED YOU MISTER EVER WHICH
LIKE TO. THIS REVERSED PLEASE
COME ON UP. I NEED THE NEW
GLASSES. SORRY ABOUT THAT. AND
YOU HAVE- ITEM TWENTY AND
THAT'S. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR. ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR IN HIS
COMMITTEE CHIEF CONSULTANT A
CALL FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS. I WILL BE
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TO INCREASE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR IMPLEMENTS
FINDINGS FOR THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION ALTERNATIVE PILOT
PROGRAM BY AUTHORIZING THE DMV
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHP TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND MOVE
FORWARD. WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION CARDS
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES AND
LICENSE PLATE WRAPS. IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN SB EIGHT OH
SIX AUTHORIZED THE DMV TO
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
VEHICLE REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVES AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE RESULTS OF
THE PILOT PROGRAM. THE PILOT
PROGRAM ALLOWED SPECIALTY PLATE
OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION ELECTRONICALLY.
THROUGH DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES
PROVIDERS AND ALLOWED
INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS THE
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE LICENSE PLATES APP
ESTABLISHED BY THE LICENSE
PLATES PROVIDER. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM FOUND THAT THESE
ALTERNATIVE REGISTRATION
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AT THE DMV
BY ALLOWING SPECIALTY PLATE
OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION VIA AT- A MOBILE
APP RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO
INTO THE DMV. IN ADDITION THIS
PROGRAM COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE
THE DMV THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN POSTAGE FOR RENEWAL
FEES BY ALLOWING USERS TO RENEW
THEIR VEHICLE DIGITALLY- TODAY-
TO PROVIDE- SUPPORT TESTIMONY I
HAVE GYM LIGHTS REPRESENTING
REVIVER. WITHOUT TONE MR LIGHT
ARE YOU ON THE LINE PLEASE. I
AM HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF
OF REVIVER- THE MANUFACTURE OF
THE DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE ONE
OF THE THREE ITEMS THE DMV
EVALUATED- I WANTED TO NOTE
THAT THE BILL CONTAINS A FIFTY
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE DMV THAT
FEE ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT. IS TO BE CHARGED
NOT TO CONSUMERS THAT PURCHASE
OR UTILIZE ONE OF THESE THREE
PRODUCTS BUT RATHER TO THE
VENDORS INDIVIDUALLY- TO OFFSET
THE COST OF THE DEPARTMENT TO
IMPLEMENT THE INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM- WITH THAT WE CANNOT
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ENOUGH FOR WORKING WELL OUTSIDE
OF NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS TO
FINALIZE THE AMENDMENTS ON THIS
BILL- WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS IN HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR LIGHTS ARE SEEN NOBODY HERE
IN THE ROOM OR AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION HELLO WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES MISTER OPERATOR FOR
SUPPORTERS- IN SUPPORT. OF AB
NINE EIGHTY FOUR. YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB BE NINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE. SEVEN ZERO I COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND
ALIGNMENT ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER FROM THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE UP FOR. AN
ONLINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
YEAR MIKE IS UP. HE HAS. LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE TO MAKE
IT UP AND. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR-
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION A BELIEF
WE HAVE MISTER JACOB SNOW WITH
THE SELL YOU ON THE LINE- ARE
YOU THERE MR SNELL. YES ARE
YOUR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DAN- THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY- MY NAME'S JACOB
SNOW AND I'M NOT TECHNOLOGY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BOB THE OPPOSITION TODAY
BECAUSE AB NINETY FOUR
THREATENS TO PUT NEW
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY INTO
LICENSE PLATES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. BOTH FOR
INDIVIDUAL DRIVERS AND FOR
EMPLOYEES WHO COULD BE SUBJECT
TO ADDITIONAL MONITORING AND
TRACKING OF THEIR WORKPLACE AS
A RESULT OF THE SPICES. WE DO
APPRECIATE THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD.
SPONSORS BUT THE BILL STILL
LACKS ADEQUATE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. LOCATION
INFORMATION OF THE TIME
GATHERED BY GPS FROM DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATES CAN BE CAREFULLY
REVEALING A UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT RECOGNIZED IN
CARPENTER PERSONS UNITED STATES
LOCATION INFORMATION QUOTE
PROVIDES AN INTIMATE WINDOW
INTO A PERSON'S LIFE REVEALING
NOT ONLY HERE HIS OR HER
PARTICULAR PARTICULAR
MOVEMENTS. BUT THROUGH THEM-
HER POLITICAL POLITICAL
FAMILIAL PROFESSIONAL RELIGIOUS
AND SEXUAL ASSOCIATIONS. PERSON
ASSOCIATIONS WITH OTHER PEOPLE
POLITICAL. HOME WORK ADDRESSES
HEALTH CONDITIONS CAN ALL BE
INFERRED FROM GPS LOCATION
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY
ELECTRONIC DEVICES. AND
CONTACTED DIGITAL LICENSE
PLATES ARE OFTEN USED AS PART
OF PRIVATE SLEEPS IN A
WORKPLACE. INCREASE PROJECT
PROTECTIONS NOT REDUCE THEM
PEOPLE WHO DRIVE FOR THEIR WORK
MAY FIND THEMSELVES FACING THE
CHOICE OF ACCEPTING BEING
TRACKED BY THE LICENSE PLATE ON
THE CAR THEY DRIVE. OR LOSING
THEIR LIVELIHOODS AND THAT'S
NOT A CHOICE TO ANYONE SHOULD
BE FACED WITH TODAY. I NOTICED
THAT THE DRIVER IN THIS CONTEXT
REALLY ISN'T ADEQUATE IT'S
NECESSARY TO EITHER HAVE STRICT
LIMITS ON COLLECTION OR REALLY
ROBUST GUARANTEES THAT THE
DRIVER HAS REAL POWER TO DECIDE
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE. BY THE
RETURN ON LOCATION TRACKING AND
MONITORING- ON THE CAR THEY'RE
DRIVING OR NOT. BASICALLY NO
GOOD REASON FOR A SIMPLE BY
TRYING TO COLLECT HIS PLATE TO
INCLUDE. DETAILED SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY TO TRACK AND RECORD
PEOPLE'S GPS LOCATIONS USE THAT
INFORMATION CAN. EXPOSE PEOPLE
TO INTRUSION INTO HARM. ABOUT
THE AMENDMENTS- ARE YOU KNOW
ABOUT. THANKS FOR MUCH THANK
YOU SIR LOS. NO ONE HERE IN
ROOM- OR THE REMOTE LOCATION
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
MISTRUST READER. FOR CALLERS.
IN OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. IN LINE EIGHTY YEAR
MIKE IS UP. HI MISTER CHAIRMAN
BUT HE CAN'T THE COURT ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION JUST LIKE
TO LIKE IN OUR POSITION ALONG
WITH THE ACLU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY YEAR MIKE IS UP.
YES THANK YOU THIS IS TRACY
REMEMBER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
OPEN PRIVACY WE WERE UNABLE TO
SUBMIT A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
OPPOSITION WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE ACLU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. I MEAN ME AND I'M AGAINST
THIS SOME CREEPY DEL THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S GONNA LIKE VIOLATE
PEOPLE'S BASIC ALL RIGHT BUDDY
I THINK. DELGADO UP MA'AM
PLEASE- IF YOU CAN JUST TELL US
YOUR NAME. AND YOUR POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU WERE
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION I
THINK I YOU'VE CALLED MADE
SEVERAL CALLS TODAY- AND- SO AT
THIS POINT WOULD YOU PLEASE
JUST IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND TELL
US YOUR POSITION. HI I AM
CALLING ALEXANDER HAD FROM I'M
STILL IN OPPOSITION TO THAT
EARLIER BILLS I WAS TALKING
ABOUT AND I NOT ALLOWED TO CALL
ON MORE THAN ONE BECAUSE I'M
AGAINST THIS ONE I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE COOLEY ONE WENT
BECAUSE I'M AGAINST THAT ONE
TOO BUT DOESN'T COME UP. AND
THEN YOUR PHONE THING TO. AND I
CAN'T GET BACK ON AND THEN I
CAN'T GET A LINE. I'D BE MORE
AGAIN. MA'AM I THINK- YOUR
BEHAVIOR SEEMS TO BE DISRUPTING
THIS HEARING. AND I HAVE DHEA
PROVOCATIVE TO DISCONNECT YOUR
LINE IF THAT HAPPENS AGAIN- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL. SO
WITH THAT- HOPE READER ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL COLORS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COLORS AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO OUR COMMITTEE FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION MISSED WEEKS
GO AHEAD PLEASE THANK YOU-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
I JUST WANT TO- SEE IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED SURE BOB WE DID TAKE- A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS- THAT
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
ACLU- THERE WAS ONE AMENDMENT.
THAT I COULDN'T ACCEPT BECAUSE
IT WAS ADDED BY ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WHICH
WAS WHERE THE BILL WAS BEFORE-
IT WAS REFERRED TO THIS
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE SPONSORS ON WAYS THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS.
VERY GOOD- MISC POWER CAN GO
AHEAD PLEASE- THIS SERVICE I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL I THINK- YOU
KNOW THE COST SAVINGS THAT YOU
CITED IN POSTAGE ALONE WAS
FAIRLY SHOCKING WE'RE SPENDING
A LOT OF MONEY WHEN NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE THAT
PEOPLE WOULD BE EXCITED TO USE
AND I THINK YOU'RE PROVIDING US
WITH THAT OPPORTUNITY. AND
CLEAR WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK
TO ADDRESS THE PRIVACY CONCERNS
THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT- YOU KNOW THERE'S THE ONE
REMAINING CONCERNED I TRUST YOU
TO WORK IT OUT I THINK THAT WE-
WE JUST DID A BILL TALKING
ABOUT OPT IN OPT OUT THERE'S A
LOT OF WAYS TO ADDRESS IT
WITHOUT COMPLETELY DISABLING
THE TECHNOLOGY AND- I TRUST YOU
TO. TO GET THERE AND PROVIDE
THIS TECHNOLOGY IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIANS SO THANK YOU ARE.
YOU SUPPORTING ABOUT. THANK
YOU. MR GABRIEL GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YEAH I THINK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. AND I GUESSED MAYBE
LITTLE BIT CAN. HERE BY MY
UNDER. OF THIS IS THAT IT WOULD
BE UP TO THE CONSUMER THAT THEY
COULD TURN OFF THE ABILITY TO
TRANSMIT THE LOCATION DATA IS
THAT CORRECT. YES THAT IS THE
CASE. YES YEAH THE THIS THE
CUSTOMERS HAVE THE OPTION. OF
TURNING. OFF THE LOCATION
SERVICES VIA THE APP. GREAT
THANK YOU YEAH I GUESS TO ME
ABOUT REALLY ADDRESSES SOME OF
THAT PRIVACY CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE WE'RE
PUTTING THE THAT DECISION
MAKING POWER IN THE HANDS OF
THE CONSUMER I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE AS THE STATE COULD BE
TELLING EVERY CONSUMER. OUT
THERE THAT THEY HAVE TO DO X.
OR Y. IF THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT WOULD LIKE THAT
LOCATION DATA ON THAT SEEMS TO
BE THEIR PREROGATIVE. AND
FRANKLY THEIR INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY TO DO THAT SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONVERSATION
WITH THEM AND I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I DON'T SEE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I WILL ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR. BRINGING THE
BILL FORD AND- AS WELL AS A
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH. US THE
COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS THE
OPPOSITION HAND. AND I THINK
THAT THE REASON AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU. TOOK A- OF STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE I THINK YOU KNOW.
IN THAT THERE IS ALSO THE- NON
GPS OPTION ARE IN YOU KNOW THE
PRICE IS NOT GONNA BE ANY
DIFFERENT SO. SO I THINK THAT
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE SO
THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE MORE
WORK AHEAD OF YOU SO BACK TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION- SO
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS DISCUSSION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WAS THERE
MOTION. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
IN AND SECONDED- MISTER-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A NINE EIGHT FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAP HI CHAO I
KILEY. RK RK HAND AYE BENNETT
AYE FINANCE AYE CORREA. I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
IRWIN LATE HI WE I. WICKS YOUR
BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES IT ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. THAT BRING SERVICE TO MR
SANTIAGO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND I WANT TO THANK MR
GABRIEL FOR EXTENDING THE
COURTESY AS WELL- MR SANTIAGO
WE HAVE ITEM TWENTY ONE AND
THAT'S FIFTEEN OH THREE. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AT THE BACK
OF A CHAIR. I THINK IT IS-
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
HELPING US TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL AND I DIDN'T MEAN
IT MEAN THAT I KNOW A LOT OF A
SAY THAT. IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE IT'S EXTREMELY WELL MEANT
ARE YOUR MEMBERS WILL HELP US-
TO PREVENT THE SHARING OF THE
DATA THAT WE WERE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT- IT IT'LL
REQUIRE THE DOES THAT THE DATA
BE DELETED- ONCE THE PROGRAM IS
OVER- AND THEIR SAFEGUARDS OF
THE OF THE INFORMATION WILL BE
ABUSED- DURING ROUTINE STOPS
OR- WHAT HAVE YOU SO WE'RE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL BUT I THINK
IT MAKES US THE BILL A MUCH
STRONGER- AND BETTER BILL BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO A PILOT PROGRAM-
WHERE THE WHERE THE DMV WOULD
REPORT BACK TO STATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY SIX I TO HAVE DIGITAL'S
ID'S I MEAN WE KEEP EVERYTHING
IN ALLOPHONES TODAY- FROM OUR I
WILL GETTING FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS WE KEEP INSURANCE
CARS WE GET EVERYTHING WE NEED
EXCEPT THE ONE THING WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED THE MOST WHICH
IS I. AND- I THINK DELIVERIES
IN THE ONE ELSE HERE TO EXPLAIN
LYFT YEAH WE DON'T LIKE CAME TO
CONCLUSION BESIDES THE FACT
THAT I'M A VERY PERSISTENT
CHIEF OF STAFF. WHO IS POINTING
OUT THE NEED TO DO THIS- AND I
WAS ASSISTED EXCEPT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR- I.
FORGOT MY EIGHTY. APPEAR I FELT
MYSELF. I'M NOBODY GETTING BACK
UP HERE- EVEN THE- TO A CAR IN
THE BELIEVE THE- ON AIR- IN THE
ONE THING I NEED THE MOST MY
ID. HI COULD NOT. GET IT BEYOND
ITS SIGNATURE. I COULD HAVE HAD
A AND DIGITAL ID. AND SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT THIS. WILL
ESTABLISH- AND I DID A LADY
DOWN THE LINE KNOWING THAT.
PEOPLE CAN GET ON AND DO. MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSACTIONS ON
THE PHONE YOU DON'T HAVE A
BASIC IDEA. TO IDENTIFY WHO YOU
ARE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
FEEL EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR.
YOUR PARTICIPATION. AND HELP
AND- TO MAKE THIS A STRONG BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT VERY
GOOD- THERE'S NO REGISTER
SUPPORT THE WITNESS- SO ARE
MISTER OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE UP. I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
AIR IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY- SELECT CIRCLE TO
THE- THE PHONE LINES TO. FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BURKE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO REGISTER
WITNESS FOR OPPOSITION EITHER
SO- PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES. YOUR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHT BE FIFTEEN
OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND LINE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. I'M
AGAINST THIS BILL AND I'M
DEFINITELY AGAINST YOU
CENSORING ME WHEN I'M TRYING TO
SPEAK ON MULTIPLE BILLS MY NAME
IS ANDREA HAD FROM AND I'M
INTERESTED IN SPEAKING ABOUT
SEVERAL OF THESE BILLS AND I
DON'T APPRECIATE BEING CUT OFF.
THANK YOU MUCHA ADAM OF FOR
YOUR CALL- WE HAVE RULES
REGARDING TESTIMONIES IN
GENERAL WE HAVE USUALLY TO NOT
ALLOWED TO SPEAK ON WALL YES
AND AFTER THE TWO MINUTE MARK-
MA'AM WE ASK THE CALL IS TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES. AND STATE
THE POSITION AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT AND BECAUSE OF THE UP
BECAUSE OF A TIME LIMITATION WE
CAN ONLY DO THAT AND THAT WE DO
THAT FOR EVERY SINGLE BILL SO
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL AND I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AND WE HAVE YOUR NAME
DOWN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL. SO I. CAN BETTER GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
SU DISAPPOINTMENTS BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR. SEEING NONE LET ME ALSO
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO OF A
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALSO MY TEAM.
AND I THINK WE HELD A BILL
THAT- THAT'S I FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH. AND AS WE
KNOW DIGITAL ID ARMS AND A
DRIVER'S LICENSE HOW OF THE
POTENTIAL TO PRESENT SERIOUS
PRIVACY CONCERNS. IF NOT
PROPERLY IMPLEMENTED- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- YOU AGREED TO
TAKE AYE AYE LIKE I SAID YOU
KNOW I FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE
HELLO SUPPORTING ITSELF SO WITH
THAT- MY RECOMMENDATION IS AN
ALL RIGHT- SO AT THIS POINT
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH JUST
THE OTHER THE STATE ON NEXT
EXTREMELY EXCITED WE TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT I WAS DONE YES
IT'S ACTUALLY A LOT SAFER
BECAUSE- YOU CAN CHOOSE ONE OF
DIFFERENT MENUS TO DISPLAY THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU WANT.
RELATED TO EXACTLY THE ACTION
ONE TAKE SO IF YOU'RE GOING OUT
FOR A QUICK DRINK YOU COULD
PRESS THE LOGIN BUTTON AND ALL
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED FOR
THAT PARTICULAR- BUT THAT
PARTICULAR ACTION CAN BE
PRINTED IN THE END YOU COULD
SORT IT OUT. SO IT'S I'M REALLY
EXCITED NOW ONCE I TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING
PARTICULARLY IOWA INVITED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IF I DON'T DO IT- I'M
HOPEFUL THAT CALIFORNIA'S OFF.
JR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU WITH
THAT- THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED I
UNDERSTAND- HAS BEEN. AND
WITHOUT PERMISSION- IT HASN'T
BEEN MOVED. IT'S BEEN HELD IN
SECOND NOW. SO MR SECRETARY. OF
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A- ONE FIVE ZERO. THE
MOTION AS PASS AMENDED TO
APPROACH. CHECK OUT HI CHAO I
KILEY KILEY I'VE OUR K. HAN RK
I'VE DONE IT. CORREA CUNNINGHAM.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
IRWIN WAIT HI LEE I WICKS. I
COUNTED SIX CORPSES I WANT TO
GET FIVE OF FIVE AFFECTED
LIPITOR WILL OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. UP THAT IS THAT LAID
OUT ON SO WE GOT SIX VOTES YEAH
YOUR BILL IS OUT SO BAD HI. SO
LET'S SEE SO AT THIS POINT I
SEE MISTER LOLE WHICH WAS THE
LAW HERE PLEASE COME ON UP
HELLO. AND AGAIN EIGHT ONE
EXTEND MY CODE IS THE COURTESY
TO MISS MR GABRIEL ONE WHAT'S
THAT SO MR LOW YOU HOW- ITEM
EIGHTEEN. AND THAT IS- FOUR AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE SO
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESEARCHER AND COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I
LIKE THE- SO- THAT'S TO OUR
WITNESS SO. LET'S SEE WE HAVE
WITH US IS FREE BILL. SIX YES
DOCTOR SIR I GUESS IN FROM THE
WRECKERS UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ALL VERY GOOD
AND ARE YOU ON THE LINE ON THIS.
MAYBE I SHOULD GET THE NAME
RIGHT. THIRTY ZERO LIKE I SAID
THAT WAS A- SIX. THERE ARE
DOCTORS SIERRA LAKES AND-
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR FROM THE
RUCKUS SCHOOL OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS THE OPERATOR I DO NOT
SHOW THAT DOCTOR LIKE IT'S AN
HAS CONNECTED. R. EIGHT MAYBE-
MAYBE SHE SHE HAS A THE MUTE
BUTTON ON. I GUESS WE COULD
CIRCLE BACK GO WITH HER- I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK GO IN SUPPORT
SO WHY DON'T WE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR THE- PUBLIC COMMENT.
LOOK FOR CALLERS SO TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. AND IT WILL CIRCLE
BACK WITH THE OF THE WITNESS.
BOB FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE TEN ZERO.
ANALYTE A ONE HUNDRED NINETY
SIX I COULD UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. Q. OUR NEXT
PLEASE. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION EITHER AND THERE'S
NO REGISTER WITNESS- FOR
OPPOSITION SO LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR OPPOSITION
CALLERS PLEASE. FOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. SEEING
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU MR LOW AFFORD
ON BRING FOR THIS BILL- UP
PERSONALLY THE BILL LISTEN
SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT FOR ME I
THINK IT. IF YOU HAVE READ THE-
ANALYSIS IT POINTS OUT- SOME
SOME ISSUES THAT THAT I AM
PERSONALLY HAD WITH BUT I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND- ALSO THAT YOU HAVE A
LITTLE MORE TIME TO WORK ON IT
CO GOING FORWARD. AND I'M
HOPING THAT BY THE TIME IT
REACHES TO THE FLOOR I'LL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT AGAIN SO WITH
THAT- I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU DON'T EVEN
AS OF REFLECT ANALYSIS AS YOU
KNOW THE BILL HAS IMPRINTED
DOES ENJOY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND THAT IS THE IMPETUS AND
VISIT THE DIRECTION THAT WE
HOPE TO HAD TO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD AND- I
APPRECIATE THE ACCOMMODATIONS
IN YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT MR
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON AB- L. CIRCLE WITH THE
WITNESS TO SEE OF- SHE'S BACK-
MISTER OPERATOR- CAN YOU DOUBLE
CHECK TO. IF- MISTER. PROFESSOR
OF SERRA LEGACY IN THIS- BACK
ON THE LINE. JUST TO GIVE HER
THE OPPORTUNITY. WE DO NOT SHOW
HER ON THE LINE IF BECAUSE
THERE ARE LIKE I SAID IT'S ON
THE LINE PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO
TO WE CAN IDENTIFY YOUR LIFE. I
GUESS WE TRY TO. SO WITH THAT-
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE AT THIS IS AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR CHAPTER HI
CHARLES HI KYLIE. KYLIE I'VE K.
HOW ARE QUE HAND AYE BENNETT
AYE BENNETT AYE CARILLO.
CUNNINGHAM GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GALLAGHER. IRWIN LATE HI LEE I
WICKS YOU HAVE SIX WHAT THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WITH THAT MR GABRIEL OOPS.
GREAT MR GABRIEL YOU HEALTH-
ITEM TWELVE AND THAT'S AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED SO WE GOT TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR TEAM FOR
THE THOUGHTFUL FEEDBACK AND
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. IN RECENT
YEARS CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY ALARMED ABOUT THE
ROLE OF SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
IN MODERATING OUR POLITICAL
DISCOURSE. FOR MANY
PARTICULARLY FOLLOWING THE
HORRIFIC ASSAULT ON OUR
DEMOCRACY AT THE US CAPITOL
EARLIER THIS YEAR. THESE
CONCERNS CENTER AROUND THE ROLE
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
PLAY. IN PROMOTING HATE SPEECH.
DISINFORMATION CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
FOR OTHERS IT IS THE MYSTERY
BEHIND WHY CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS
IN CONTENT AND NOT OTHERS ARE
SUBJECT TO DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
THERE'S GROWING CONCERN ABOUT
SEVERE POLITICAL POLARIZATION.
AND THE ABILITY OF A HANDFUL OF
COMPANIES TO PROFOUNDLY SHAPE
THE PUBLIC DISCOURSE THAT IS
CENTRAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY. AB
FIVE EIGHT SEVEN ADDRESSES
THESE CONCERNS BY REQUIRING
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO SHARE
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
CONTENT MODERATION PRACTICES
WITH CONSUMERS. PARTICULAR THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE LARGEST
AND MOST SOPHISTICATED
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE THEIR
CONTENT MODERATION POLICIES.
HOW DOES POLICIES ARE ENFORCED
AND THE KEY METRICS AND DATA
AROUND ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE
POLICIES. TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE THESE
COMPANIES TO HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
POLICIES. NOR DOES IT REQUIRE
THEM TO UNDERTAKE ANY TYPE OF
ENFORCEMENT. IT SIMPLY REQUIRES
THEM TO BE OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
WITH POLICYMAKERS AND THE
PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT. IF ANYTHING
THEY ARE DOING TO MODERATE
SPEECH ON THEIR PLATFORMS. THIS
NARAL APPROACH RESPECTS THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND FEDERAL
PREEMPTION WHAT THE SAME TIME
PROVIDING MEANINGFUL
TRANSPARENCY AND MUCH NEEDED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY. IN SHORT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO COME CLEAN
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE MODERATING
CONTENT. SO THAT WE ALL CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THEY ARE
AMPLIFYING CERTAIN VOICES AND
SILENCING OTHERS. THE PUBLIC
AND POLICY MAKERS DESERVE NO
LESS. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO KNOW
THAT WE APPRECIATE SEVERAL THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION. THE AMENDMENTS WE
ARE TAKING TODAY ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL. NEEDLESS
TO TIME WOULD LIKE TO MOVE TO
MY WITNESS LARA CRAP FROM THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. THE
REPORT ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS
AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND THOUGHTFUL
SYSTEMS. THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
GO TO OUR FIRST WITNESS.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M LARA
CROFT COUNCIL FOR TECHNOLOGY
POLICY AND ADVOCACY AT THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANKS NINETEEN THIRTEEN
ADL'S MISSION HAS BEEN TO STOP
THE DEFAMATION OF THE JEWISH
PEOPLE AND TO SECURE JUSTICE
AND FAIR TREATMENT FOR ALL
DEDICATED TO COMBATING
ANTISEMITISM PREJUDICE AND
BIGOTRY OF ALL KINDS AS WELL AS
THE FUNDING DEMOCRATIC IDEALS
AND PROMOTING CIVIL RIGHT. ADL
IS A LEADING VOICE IN FIGHTING
HATE IN ALL FORMS INCLUDING
ONLINE WE ARE COMING OUT OF ONE
OF THE MOST DIVISIVE ELECTIONS
IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY AGAINST
THE BACKDROP OF CODE NINETEEN
AND A HORRIFYING MURDERS OF
GEORGE FLOYD BRIANNA TAYLOR AND
RECENTLY THE TRAGIC KILLINGS OF
DANTE WRIGHT. ADAMS LAID OUT
AND THAT HIGHER BRYANT THE WAY
NEWS AND CURRENT EVENTS
REVERBERATE ONLINE MATTERS AND
THE CONCERN AROUND SOCIAL
MEDIA'S ROLE IN HOSTING AND
EVEN PROMOTING HATE RACISM
EXTREMISM HARASSMENT AND
DISINFORMATION IS WELL FOUNDED.
FALSE ALLEGATIONS OF VOTER
FRAUD SPREAD ONLINE LED TO THE
VIOLENT INSURRECTION AT OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL THE MOST
PREDICTABLE TERROR ATTACK IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WHAT LITERALLY
PLANNED AND PROMOTED OUT IN THE
OPEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA. ONLINE
HARASSMENT IS ALSO RAMPANT
ACCORDING TO ADL'S LATEST DATA
41% OF AMERICANS HAVE
EXPERIENCED ONLINE HARASSMENT
AND ONE IN THREE OF THOSE
HARASSED ATTRIBUTE AT LEAST
SOME OF IT TO A PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTIC. AND IF HE IS
THE ONLY TAKING PLACE ON FRENCH
MESSAGEBOARDS 75% OF THOSE
TRAPPED SAID AT LEAST SOME HER
A HOT ROTHMAN HAPPENED ON
FACEBOOK. 24% ON TWITTER 21% ON
YOUTUBE 15% OFF THAT CHAT WELL
RESOURCE HIGHLY PROFITABLE
PLATFORM DESPITE THESE ALARMING
CONCERNS EFFORT BY SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO MODERATE CONTENT
HAVE BEEN INADEQUATE AT BEST
BUT ALSO OPAQUE ARBITRARY
BIASED. IN IT AND IN THE GLOBAL.
MOST MADE PLOT PUBLISHED
TRANSIT EUROPE. BUT IN REALITY
SHARE LIMIT AND- THE REPORT
LIKE THE DATA AND MET NEED TO.
UNDERSTAND HOW CONSUMERS ARE OR
ARE NOT PROTECTED. TODAY IT IS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW THE
FULL SCOPE AND NATURE OF
EXTREMISM AND HATE ONLINE THE
LACK OF REAL TRANSPARENCY
AROUND THE ENFORCEMENT OF
POPCORN POLICIES AS AN URGENT
PROBLEM. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS THAT BY
REQUIRING SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
COMMUNITY GUIDELINES AND REPORT
DATA AROUND THE ENFORCEMENT OF
THEIR POLICIES. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
THE REMOTE LOCATION WHO WISH TO
SPEAK- IN SUPPORT SO MISTER
OFFERED- PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. OUR ON A. B. FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE
NUMBERS. AN ONLINE A ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YEAR MY
COULD OPEN THE LOCK. THERE ARE
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATTHEW
FRIEDMAN. POLICE SELECTOR COULD
NO LONGER ALSO KNOWN AS THE
ANTI DEFAMATION. IN RECENT.
THERE'S A GROWING AND AROUND
WALL MEETING GOOD MORNING HEY
SPEECH THIS AND CONSUMER THEORY
I I'M AND HARASSMENT THEREFORE
WE SUPPORT AB FIVE A SEVEN
WHICH WOULD THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY BY SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES ON HOW THEY HANDLE
PEOPLE CONTENT ON THEIR
PLATFORMS. WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER SUPPORT WHICH INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF OTHER SIGNATORIES
WHICH ARE ALSO SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL OTHER SUPPORTERS INCLUDE
ACCOUNTABLE TAX MONEY ON
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA
ASIAN AMERICANS IN ACTION.
ESPERANZA IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
PROJECT JAPANESE AMERICAN
CITIZENS LEAGUE BERKELEY
CHAPTER KOREAN AMERICAN
COALITION LOS ANGELES LEAGUE OF
UNITED LATIN AMERICAN CITIZENS
NAILING IT FOR AMERICA NATIONAL
HISPANIC MEDIA COALITION ORANGE
COUNTY RACIAL JUSTICE
NOW ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
WESTERN REGION AND PACIFICA
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU AGAIN TO
THE BILL'S AUTHORS AND
SUPPORTERS AND TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
YEAH NEXT PLACE SO. IF YOU CAN
JUST TELL US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. THIS FRANCE FOR STILL
REPRESENTING COMMONSENSE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME
WITH THAT LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE THE FIRST
WITNESSES DYLAN HOFFMAN WITH
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION. MR
HOFFMAN ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I
AM THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- DON'T HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN ONCE
AMENDED. WELL WISHERS OF THE
AUTHOR AND SUPPORTERS GOAL
NAMELY YEAH INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY IN OUR CONTENT
MODERATION EFFORTS- WE HAVE
SOME SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO
IMPROVE THE BILL- CURRENTLY THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS COULD
FRUSTRATE THIS GOAL IN PLACE
ONE WORKABLE BURDEN ON OUR
COMPANIES- THE CREATION OF A
NEW QUARTERLY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR TERMS OF
SERVICE AND DATA ABOUT HOW CAN
MODERATION. IS LIKELY ENOUGH TO
START OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ALREADY MAKE THEIR
TERMS OF SERVICE HE HOOKED. UP
ON THEIR WEBSITE. THE ISSUE IS
REPORT RETURNS SERVICE TO THE
AG AND THE- OF THIS REPORT.
MAYBE FIVE IN. PRESIDENT REPORT
A QUARTERLY. THE CARE CONTENT
MOTHER FACT. BUT I THE DETAILS
ABOUT HOW CONTENT THAT'S WHY
NEVER HAVE BUT I THINK COME
BACK TO SCHOOL THE EARLY PART.
ESPECIALLY CRATER WHICH YOU
PLAY AFFIX TO TECHNICAL I HAVE
BEEN FOUND WE ARE TRYING TO
ISOLATE THAT LINE RIGHT NOW
OKAY THANK YOU I'M- OUR- I WE
BELIEVE FOUND THE SERVER THAT
THEY UNITS. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU
MISTER- HELLO THANK YOU FIVE IN
SEVEN OR BUSINESS FOR ON A
COURT BASIS NOT ONLY ACCURATE
SCALE. NOT PRACTICES BUT
DETAILS ABOUT CONTENT FLAG AND
ACT AGAINST NEARLY I'M FOR THE
CENTER COURT DUE TO NATURE.
ANALYZE AND YOUR ACTS CONTRE.
FURTHER THIS YEAR BY OF CONTENT
ARE COMPANIES REVIEWED ON
REASONABLE TO REPORT DATA ON
INDIVIDUAL PIECES OF CONTENT.
ARE COMPLETE ACTION BILLIONS OF
PIECES OF CONTENT ACROSS THE
PLATFORM EVERY QUARTER. THE
REQUIREMENTS COLLECT RETAIN
REPORT INFORMATION ON
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DATA IS
UNWORKABLE. WE CAN JUST
CONSOLIDATING THIS INFORMATION
THE ONE ANNUAL REPORT TO BE
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE THE
PLATFORMS AND THE START TO
DISCLOSE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DATA.
AGAIN WHILE WE AGREE WITH THE
GOAL OF THE BILL WE BELIEVE
THESE CHANGES ARE NECESSARY TO
MAKE THE BILL MORE WORKABLE FOR
THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE ONGOING CONVERSATION-
CALTRAIN QUESTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I NEXT WE HAVE
SCHLOSSMAN WILL HAVE IT- WOOD
COUNTY IF. YOU CAN KEEP IT
BRIEFLY SO. YES COURSE THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN FROM CAL. WITH
OPPOSE IF I EIGHT THOUSAND WE
WOULD APPRECIATE BILLS GOLD
INCREASE. AROUND CONTRA
MODERATION MODERATION. BUT THE
BILL BY AT THE AMENDED OUT ARE
THERE TO FAR WILL IMPACT
ABILITY TO. ON BOTH. ONLINE
IMAGINE ABOUT ACTORS AND ENDING
DESPITE HOW CON AND I TO COME
DEEP DESCRIPTIONS ABOUT
AUTOMATED CONTENT MODERATION
SYSTEMS WORK THE RULES BY WHICH
THE SYSTEMS IDENTIFY CONTENT
FOR HUMAN REVIEW. FOURTEEN VERY
TRAINING MANUALS INSURANCE
POLICIES ON HOW EXACTLY CONTENT
MODERATION IS IMPORTANT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
REQUIRES BUSINESSES TO
DISCLOSE. ON A QUARTERLY BASIS-
WE BELIEVE THE DETAILED LEVEL
OF LOCAL FORTY APARTMENT CAN'T
THREATEN THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF USERS WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING BAD ACTORS WITH-
TECHNICALLY ROAD MAPS ON HOW
BEST TO EXPLOIT THE SYSTEMS-
MODERATES MODERATORS AND
PRACTICES- THESE ARE AT SOME OF
THE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN THAT. I THANK YOU OR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD TODAY.
THANK YOU SEEING NO NO ONE HERE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE- MR ROBERT- PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR.
CALLERS IN OFFICE. TO AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. FOR COMMON THEN
UP DO YOU AB FIVE EIGHT THAT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE TEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE A FEW
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS. AND
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
HEREBY COULD OPEN. HI THIS IS
PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN DIRECTOR
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE
AND EXTREMISM I APOLOGIZE I WAS
BOUNCED OUT OF THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT I JUST WANT TO MAINTAIN
THAT ARE CENTER OFFERS VIGOROUS
SUPPORT FOR THIS LEGISLATION WE
HAVE FOUND. THAT THERE IS AN
INCREASE IN INTEREST.
DISTRIBUTORSHIP TWO WITNESSES
OR IS ONE OF THE NIGHT BUT NOW
OKAY YES SIR- YEAH AT THIS
POINT WHICH THE ALLOWING. THE
CALLS TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES
AND ALSO STATE THEIR POSITION
BUT WE DO WE DO HAVE YOU YOU
REGISTER AS A SUPPORTER. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL. SO OPERATOR LET'S GO TO
THE NEXT TO COLLEGE. NINE TWO
HUNDRED TEN YEAR MIKE IS UP.
LINE TWO HUNDRED TEN. LIKE IT'S
OPEN PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE. IT
IS. LINE TWO HUNDRED NINE YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN HELLO MY NAME IS
PATRICIA STRONG AND REPRESENTED
MOUNT SALEM- CHURCH AND I'M IN
THE OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM- NEXT PLEASE. I AM
TWO HUNDRED SEVEN YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ASSISTING HEALTH
PERMISSIBLE CHARGES EXHORTATION
A CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
NEXT PLEASE. LINE FIFTY NINE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF TECH THAT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME TO
WITH THAT LET'S UP BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A
FURTHER DISCUSSION BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENT MISTER LEE GO
AHEAD. I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS BILL AND
I'M ALSO PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL AS MUCH AS WE WOULD
LIKE OF YOU SEE THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO REGULATE
THEMSELVES AS THEY ARE NOW
BECOMING PUBLIC FORUMS IN THE
INTERNET SPACE- I THINK IT
SHOULD BE A TIME THAT THEY ARE
NOT ABLE TO THE ALWAYS THE MOST
EFFECTIVELY SO THEY NEED TO BE
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND I THINK
THIS BILLS. AS A AS A STRONG
BALANCE BETWEEN THAT MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE SO GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUT ALSO HOLDING
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT PUBLIC
INTEREST OF MAKING SURE THEY'RE
NOT JUST- CESSPOOLS OF
CONSPIRACIES SO IT'S IMPORTANT
AND OBVIOUS FOR THIS BILL TODAY
OF COURSE. THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
INTENTION AND EFFORTS OF THIS
BILL AND I THINK THERE ARE MANY
IMPORTANT THINGS TO COME OUT OF
THIS I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOU
HAVE ALREADY ACKNOWLEDGED A-
THAT THERE ARE THINGS THAT YOU
WANT TO IMPROVE IN THIS BILL
AND THAT YOU'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE- PEOPLE WHO ARE
OFFERING SUGGESTIONS TO IMPROVE
THE BILL SO. I'VE CERTAINLY
LOOK FOR THAT ALSO WHAT THAT
COULD LOOK AT THEM YES
SUPPORTING THIS MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU HAS. BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
COMMITTED TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I. WANT TO YOU FOR.
TACKLING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
THAT THERE'S A NUMBER OF BILLS-
SIMILAR BILLS GOING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM. I'M BACK FOR THE- PAST
TWO TWO YEARS AGO AND I HAVE A
BILL GOING GOING THROUGH.
JUDICIARY AND MR. GALLAGHER IN
MISTER KILEY ALSO HAD- HAS ONE.
I THINK DEALING WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS IN GENERAL
IT'S- SO CUT THAT TELLS ME
THAT. YOU KNOW I THINK- THESE
PLATFORMS ARE REALLY- IMPACTING
OUR- DAILY LIVES AND YOU KNOW
TO THE EXTENT THAT- YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE SO MANY. OF MEMBERS TO
TRY TO REALLY ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES. SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU I MEAN I THINK THE WAY THAT
YOU YOU APPROACHING THE ISSUE
IS A VERY CREATIVE ONE. AND I
TRULY APPRECIATE IT- AND- YOU
KNOW I THE BILL THAT I'M
CARRYING SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH
IS. WHICH- DEALS WITH
MISINFORMATION. WHICH IS A KIND
OF A PIECEMEAL APPROACH AND-
COMPARED TO THE WITH THE WAY
YOU HAVE IT- WITH THE CONTENT
MONTH MODERATION. WHICH IS A
LOT MORE COMPREHENSIVE WAITED
TO ADDRESSING IT. AND YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY AVOIDING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT CHALLENGES AND ALL.
SO YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT MY
BUILDING MISSED COLLEGE BECAUSE
BILL. WENT TO JUDICIARY WAS
BECAUSE OF THE- FIRST AMENDMENT
COMPONENT. AND ALSO THE SECTION
TWO THIRTY OF THAT YOU KNOW
THE- COMMISSION DECENCY ACT. SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE HURDLES
THAT WE HAVE TO KIND OF GO
THROUGH. SO THAT'S WHY I'D LIKE
TO THE APPROACH THAT YOU'RE
TAKING WITH THIS. SO AT SOME
POINT YOU KNOW IT IT. YOU KNOW
I YOU LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
ALSO MAYBE. GOING FORWARD. BUT
THAT WOULD THAT- I WANT ASK YOU
TO CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU YOUR-
THANK YOU MISTER TEPPER PRE. OR
NOT YOU'RE A YOUR YOUR YOU'RE
TALKING. AND WE BE DELAYED AND
pHONORED ADD YOU AS A- AS A- AS
A CALL AUTHOR- JUST FOR A
MINUTE JUST TO RE. A LITTLE OF
WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITE.
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THEM I DO. TO SOME-
SKEPTICISM. THE BURDEN ARGUMENT
HERE. YOU KNOW THESE THESE
THESE COMPANIES ARE LOOKING AT
ALL OF THIS DATA CONSTANTLY IT
IS PART OF HOW THEY OPTIMIZE
THEIR SERVICES. AND JUST TO ADD
AN ELEMENT OF REALITY I MEAN IF
YOU LOOK AT ONE OF THE
COMPANY'S FACEBOOK. THEY HAD
ANNUAL REVENUE LAST YEAR EIGHTY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS. I HAVE
OVER FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. THEY HAVE THE BEST
TECHNOLOGISTS AND DATA
SCIENTISTS AND- PROGRAMMERS IN
THE WORLD AND SO I THINK I'M
VERY CONFIDENT IN THEIR ABILITY
TO. BEAR THE BURDEN THE VERY
MODEST BURDEN THAT THIS BILL
IDEA. WHEN IT WOULD IMPOSE ON
THEM. AND TO YOUR POINT BEFORE
WE ARE TRYING TO STRIKE A
BALANCE HERE OF RESPECTING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT I THINK THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT AND
CERTAINLY WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
TO NAVIGATE AND- THREAD THE
NEEDLE ON THE FINAL PENSION
ISSUES. BUT WE THINK THIS IS
THIS BASIC NOTION OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
DOES THAT. MAN WITH I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE. HAS THE BILL BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED IT HAS BEEN
SO WITHOUT DOUBT- MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
AB FIVE EIGHT SEVEN THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED THE JUDICIARY
WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
JUDICIARY. CHAP I. CHAO I KILEY.
PARQUET ARE QUE HAND I'VE DONE
IT. HI BEN AYE. CUNNINGHAM
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I GALLAGHER
IRWIN LEE HI WE ARE I WICKS. I
HAVE FIVE OH SO FAR WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I SEE MISSILE GONZALEZ
OUT WITH S. SO WELCOMES
GONZALEZ I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
ITEM THIRTEEN THAT'S AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AS WELL. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THE
MAKING UP THEIR- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
HELPING WORK WITH US ON THIS I
WANT TO REITERATE THAT I MAKING
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE
PROVISIONS PERTAIN TO THE CAP
ON FEES AS DESCRIBED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX ONE NOW JUST PROVIDE
PRICE TRANSPARENCY THAT WILL
ENSURE BOTH RESTAURANT OWNERS
AND CUSTOMERS HAVE A FULL
UNDERSTANDING THE. IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT WORKERS RECEIVE-
THEIR FULL AMOUNT OF TIPS ADD
THAT A CUSTOMER GRANTS THEM-
COMMISSIONS ARE STILL GOING TO
BE A PROBLEM AND I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A HUGE
PROBLEM AFTER THE PANDEMIC AND
THAT. ONCE A LOT OF OUR LOCAL
ORDINANCES START TO EXPIRE BUT
FOR TODAY THIS BILL JUST
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY SO WE CAN
HAVE AN HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT
THOSE COMMISSIONS WHATEVER THAT
SHOULD BE IN THE FUTURE. IT IS-
SHOULD BE A RESTAURANTS ABILITY
TO FIND OUT WHO ELSE IS PAYING
FEES AND IT SHOULD BE CUSTOMERS
OF RESPONSIBLY FIND OUT TO HOW
MUCH THE RESTAURANT IS PAIN IT
HELPS MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION
AND QUITE FRANKLY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK. FOR PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT DELIVERY IS
NOT FREE SOMEBODY IS BEARING
THE COST OF THE DELIVERED
US AS CUSTOMERS OFTEN AS FREE
DELIVERY AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FEATURE
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO SUPPORT
YOUR LOCAL RESTAURANTS TO
UNDERSTAND JUST HOW MUCH
THEY'RE PAID. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
FIRST WITNESSES CHASSIS GROW
ALONG WITH THE- ARE YOU ON THE
YARD OF FOOD WORKER AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS SORRY WHAT
THE WESTERN STATE COUNCIL. MR
ROWELL ARE YOU AVAILABLE ON THE
LINE. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WONDERFUL GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JACKIE GRAY WALL LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE AT THE W.
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL. IF YOU
HAVE THE REPRESENTS OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND THAT THE PHARMACEUTICAL AND
RETAIL SECTORS A CALIFORNIA I
AM TESTIFYING HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TO
EIGHTY FACT. BUT IF YOU WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL HER
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND HER
CONTINUED PERSEVERANCE TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS HAVE THE STRONGEST
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE BY
UTILIZING THE GIG ECONOMY
APPLICATION. TRANSPARENCY ON
FEES CHARGED BY THIRD PARTY
FOOD DELIVERY COMPANY FOR
CUSTOMERS AND BUSINESS OWNERS
ARE ESSENTIAL. DELIVERY
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN EMPLOYING
DESIGN PRACTICES SET UP I'LL
KEEP REPLACE ME THAT ULTIMATELY
IMPACT THE FACILITIES PROCESS
AND WORKER PAY. TRANSPARENCY IS
HELPFUL TO EMPOWER USERS TO
MAKE THEIR DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
THEIR MONEY IS GOING TOWARD AND
HOW IT'S IMPACTING THEIR LOCAL
ECONOMY AND THE CONTACT THE
LIBERTY PEOPLE WHO LACK FULL
TIME WORKER PROTECTIONS AND
BENEFITS. IT IS ONE OF MANY
MECHANISM AN ECOSYSTEM OF
CHANGE WE NEED TO FURTHER HOLD
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MANY STAKEHOLDER TO RELY ON THE
SERVICE THAT. I DO MINIMUM
CONSUMERS THERE'S THERE CAN NOW
WHAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR. A
SERVICE SEE A TAB OR EMAIL AND
WHO THEY ARE PAYING FOR IT SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES ABOUT WHETHER AND HOW
TO UTILIZE THE SERVICE AT. WHAT
ADVOCATING OF HOW THESE
SERVICES CAN AFFECT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY. CAN BE AMENDED THEIR
MARCH AND PARENT INTO HOW THESE
BUSINESSES OPERATE TO HOLD
THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE THAT. SO
WHAT THE COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR PRACTICES AND TO HOLD
REPRESENTATIVES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THEIR
POLICIES. CHICAGO AND
WASHINGTON DC HAVE IMPLEMENTED
SIMILAR MEASURES TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS OF
PRICING FOR THIRD PARTY FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICE AT. CALIFORNIA
CAN AND SHOULD BE THE WAY THAT
IF I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE THAT TODAY ON EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SEEN NO ONE
IN THE ROOM. OR AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION WHO WISH TO SPEAK LET
US OPEN. UP THE PHONE LINES-
MISTER OPERATOR. FOR THOSE IN
SOME. OF AB TWO EIGHTIES. THANK
YOU MISTER FOR COMMENT IN THE
OF AB TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND ALLOW TO HER FIFTY BIKE IS
UP. HELLO THIS IS RENEE WOULD
S. C. I U. L. STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
MICROSCOPE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE TALK
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN YOUR MICROSCOPIC. LINE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN. WE LOST
THAT TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN LINE
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE YOU'RE
MY COULD HELP. HI MY NAME IS
RYAN ALTHOUGH A LOT OF MY
CLIENTS CALL ME GORD ASH FOR
SOME REASON MUCH TO THE CHAGRIN
OF MY EMPLOYER I'M SURE- I WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
UNAMENDED BURKE. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT PLEASE FOR
AUTHORS GOOD NIGHT. WE GOT WE
GOT IT WE GOT TO THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE LINE ONE HUNDRED.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
ELLEN MARSHALL- THE A RETIRED
STATE WORKER NOW DOORDASH
DRIVER AND I OPPOSE AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MA'AM ARE
WE STILL ON SUPPORTER BUT
THAT'S FINE WILL TAKE YOUR
POSITION. NEXT PLEASE. HEY
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THAT'S NOT GOOD OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE THE FIRST WITNESSES
SLOWLY WROTE CHAU WITH THE
LATINO RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION
MISS ROACH ARE YOU ONLINE. YES
I AM THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LILY ROACH ON THE
SEA OF THE LATINO RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION- ALSO KNOWN AS THE
L. R. A. B. L. L. R. A. SUPPORT
RESTAURATEURS SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THE ENTIRE LATINO
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY IN LA. AND
THROUGHOUT. THE U. S. ON BEHALF
OF OUR EIGHT HUNDRED MEMBERS.
I'M OPPOSED TO AB TWO EIGHTY
SIX. THE LATINO REFLECTION IN
THE HAS BEEN HELPING COUNTLESS
FAMILY RESTAURANT CLOSED THEIR
DOORS DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS TURNED. TO
DELIVERY PLATFORMS IF THEY
OPEN. FOR BACK BRADY REASONS
WHY WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
OTHER HAD INDICATED THAT SHE
HAD PLANNED DOWN TO AMENDMENTS.
ON AB TWO EIGHTY SIX ANALYSIS
AT THIS SOMETHING. IT UP I'M
SORRY THE ANNOUNCES INCLUDED SO
I WANTED TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
THAT ISSUE. IF THE LEGISLATURE
WERE TO ENACT A PRICE CONTROL
WE'LL LIKELY SEE HIGHER
CUSTOMER FEES LONGER WAIT TIMES
LOWER SERVICE AND REDUCE
DELIVERY DOWN COVERAGE AT A
TIME WHEN TRUCKERS STRUGGLING
ESPECIALLY ARE LOOKING A
RESTAURANT. IT COULD MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN STAYING OPEN
AND STAY CLOSE AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT THE DEFAMATION OF NOT
ONLY. WATCH WHAT THE NATIONAL
BLACK LATINO RESTAURANTS
BECAUSE OF INCREDIBLY ALL SORTS
OF THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED TO
US- AND THIS DOES NOT HELP WE
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
DELIVERY COMPANIES PUBLICLY
DISCLOSED TO CUSTOMERS THE FEES
PAID BY RESTAURANT. IN A
RESTAURANT DAY PURCHASED
DIFFERENT THINGS WITH
RESTAURANTS USED TO WORK WITH
DELIVERY COMPANIES SOME UP TO
PAY FOR SERVICES LIKE
ADVERTISING MARKETING WHILE THE
OTHERS DO NOT SO. DISCLOSURE OF
THESE FEES IS A NECESSARY
CREATES COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGES SIMPLY PUT AB
TWENTY SIX IS NOT THE ANSWER WE
ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ARE SECOND WITNESSES
IKE BRANNON WITH. THE JACK KEMP
FOUNDATION. MISTER BRANDON I
YOU ON THE LINE. THANK I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAMP PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHORS
REMOVED THE COMMISSION CAP
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. BUT
ADVOCATE IN ALFA STILL
DISCUSSES THE COMMISSION CAP OF
LIKE TO SHARE MY OPPOSITION TO
THAT AS WELL THE TRANSPARENCY
DIVISION BEING DISCUSSED. THE
LEGISLATION HAD JUSTIFIED THE
CAPITAL A TO HELP STRUGGLING
RESTAURANT THE- ENDEMIC.
SEVERAL STUDIES CONCLUDED THAT
CAPPING THE DELIVERY COMPANY
FEES WILL BOOST PROFITS.
HOWEVER SUCH OVERARCHING
REGULATIONS ARE USUALLY
DEFEATED. PRINCETON'S MOST
DELIVERY COMPANY SPACE WITH A
CAP AT A DEFLECTED THE
DELIVERY. ADDED FEES BECAUSE
RESTAURANTS BILLS DEFAULT
HURTING RESTAURANTS AS WELL
INCOME FROM DELIVERY DRIVERS.
EITHER CONCERN RELATES TO THE
TRANSPARENCY PROVISIONS.
RESTAURANTS HAVE A CHOICE WHEN
THEY PARTNER WITH DELIVERY
SERVICE PROVIDERS. MANDATING
TRANSPARENCY AND DISCLOSURE
PROVISIONS COULD CREATE A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE IN THE
MARKETPLACE AND ALSO DETERRED
DELIVERIES. RESEARCH BY SAID
WHY. AT THE UNIVERSITY MISC
SYSTEMS CANCER ARE PRETTY
AFFECTED NOT JUST BY THE CALL
OF GOOD OR SERVICE ALSO BY THE
STRUCTURE OF THE COSTUME THEY
ARE MADE EXPLICIT. REFERENCE
ONE OF THE DRIVERS ARE PAID
ENOUGH THAT RESTAURANTS NOT
CHARGED MUCH SERVICES NOT
CONSUMERS TEND TO FREQUENT
ESTABLISHMENTS DURING THE-
THESE ARE ALL COMPETING FORCES
EVENT OCCUR CONCOMITANT CAN'T
COMMITMENT LAKE. PARK CONSUMERS
WE WILLING TO PAY SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE FOR THEIR FOOD AND THAT'S
WHERE THIS. CALCULUS BREAKS
DOWN. THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
US. NO ONE IN THE ROOM OR THE
REMOTE LOCATION WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. MR OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR. OF
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO EIGHTY SIX. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO. WHY NOT ONE HUNDRED
NINETY ONE YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN.
YEAH DR RUBEN GALA CHAIRMAN OF
THE LATIN BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE IT'S
OPEN. AFTER TAMPA CHELATE
CRYSTAL COLEMAN SMART OF CHRIST
LIBERATION MINISTRIES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHT THREE
TWO EIGHT SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU MATCH NEXT PLEASE. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
WILLIAM CRABS I WORK AS A
DRIVER WITH DOORDASH I OPPOSE.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS UP.
ONE TWO HUNDRED EIGHT. MATTHEW
WILLIAMS MARC BERMAN CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE UNDER
PRESIDENT HE- WE UPHOLD THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE
IS UP. YET ANOTHER A
LEGISLATIVE DISASTER BY
LORRAINE NOT DAHLE WHACKING
BALLS GONZALEZ AB FIVE WASN'T
IT PLEASE. OKAY MA'AM IT IS
PLAN WE'RE NOT TAKING TESTIMONY
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY TELL S
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
THAT'S ALL AT THIS POINT TELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL. THANKS
PLEASE ONE ONE HUNDRED SET
WHITE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
YOU MIGHT GET UP. HI MY NAME IS
NOT SO IT'S VERY HARD DRIVE
ABOUT THAT AND I HOPE LOS
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I NEXT PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED THREE YEAR
MIKE IS UP. AFTERNOON SURE MOM
WOULD TELL CHAMBER AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN YEAR MIKE
IT'S UP. HI HERE ON BEHALF OF
GRUBHUB WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE
SIXTY EIGHT- MIKE IS OPEN.
DONNA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET US ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. BLIND OF FORTY
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. KYLE
GRIFFITH ON BEHALF OF THE
PROTECT APP BASED DRIVERS AND
SERVICES COALITION WE SUBMITTED
A LETTER SIGNED BY TWENTY EIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS IN OPPOSITION TO
TWO EIGHT SIX INCLUDING ALL
THREE ETHNIC CHAMBERS AND LULAC
COUNCIL THIRTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
THANKS THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MIKE AT
THE. LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. WHITE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. HELLO YEAH I'LL OSAKI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE CONSUMER
CHOICE CENTER AND WE FERVENTLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE.
ONE TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN YEAR
MIKE IS UP. MICHAEL SHOW DOWN
WITH CENTRICITY EXHORTATIONS
LOS ANGELES WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR YEAR MIKE IT'S UP. YEAH I
THINK IT WAS BY TEXT ANALYTICS
THE CONSUMER CHOICE CENTER AND
I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ITSELF
THANK YOU THANK YOU OUR NEXT
PLEASE. BLIND TWO HUNDRED ONE
NEAR MY COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MICHAEL BAILEY JOHN BERSHARD
ORNISH AND I OPPOSE AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU HONESTLY.
TEN FIFTY NINE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. LINE. FIFTY NINE. I ONE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ANDREW SAUL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE GREATER RIVERSIDE
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS PAST DECADE W. TO LOSE
PRESIDENT OF THE BAPTIST
MINISTERS CONFERENCE OF LOS
ANGELES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU THANKS PLEASE. FIND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. JERRY BROWN DRIVER FOR
DOOR DASH AND I OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANKS. THANK TWO HUNDRED
TEN YEAR MIKE IS UP IN. YES MY
NAME IS REVEREND JONATHAN
MOSELEY WESTERN REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANKS. LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO YOUR MIKE IS
UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATCHY COOLEY AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
DIVERSITY COALITION AND THE
NATIONAL ASIAN AMERICAN
COALITION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWO EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE OF MY
COULD OPEN. HI THIS IS KAYLA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION BICA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE. NINE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD NOT. HOLE BROWN
LOOKS. DELIVER PUT OFF WORK BUT
THE ONE HUNDRED OTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE- AB T. EIGHT.
WHAT THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE.
LINE TO HER FOR YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. WORKING ONLY WITH GREEN
OLIVES STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. WHITE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE YOUR MIKE
IT'S OPEN. WELL YES I BONTA
BURKE JONES ON THE DASHER- FOR
DOORDASH AND- I OPPOSE TWO
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS PLEASE. AND SIXTY TWO
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. LINE. SIXTY
TWO. AN ONLINE AT NINETY TWO
YOUR MY KIDS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOESN'T WANT TO BE THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AB TWO EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH THANKS
PLEASE. LINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE YOU MIGHT GET UP AND. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS THIS IS
JEANNIE HOW COULD A CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS PLEASE. AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER COMMENT COMING UP LINE
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THREE OF MY-
THANK YOU I'M NOT SURE IF IT
GOT THROUGH BEFORE THIS IS
PETER LAWWELL MORNING ALSO OF
GROUP WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
TWO EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
NINE- MIKE IS UP AND. HI WE ANY
CRACKDOWN BEHALF OF CHECKS THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NECKS PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT OR
MY COULD OPEN. YOU MIGHT WANT
TO TRY VOTING THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF THE
NUMBER OF CALLS COMING IN. AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. JUST ONE MORE MOMENT
PLEASE SURE. AN ONLINE SIXTY
SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS UP. MISTER
SIMICMAN IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WAS THAT THE LAST
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR SORRY
WE ACTUALLY HAD TO MORE PEOPLE
QUEUE UP OKAY. BY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAKE IT UP. HI
MY NAME IS FASTER PATRICIA
BARGAIN. I'M IN OPPOSITION UP
TO EIGHTY SIX AND BY OUR
NOTATION IS NOW SALEM BAPTIST
CHURCH. THANK YOU. IN LINE
FIFTY TWO I COULD OPEN. LINE
SIXTY TWO. PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE. HI MY NAME IS DAVID LEWIS
AND I'VE BEEN A DASHER SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND I
OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MISTER OPERATOR LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MR LEE
HAS A COMMON. YEAH I JUST WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORD AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS I'M ALSO PROUDLY I JOIN
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AS WELL.
AND WHILE IT IS DISAPPOINTING
WE DON'T HAVE THE FEE CAP IN
THE BILL ANYMORE I UNDERSTAND.
AS PART LET IS A PROCESS YOU
KNOW SOME THINGS HAVE TO BE
COMPROMISED. BUT I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT FOR A WHILE HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE FEE CAP
BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
MAIN ATTRACTION OF THE SHOW. IS
THAT OPEN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- WELL EVEN I BEGAN TO SAY
CITIES AND COUNTIES INCLUDING
BOTH MY COUNTIES I DISTRICTS.
HAVE ENACTED 15% FEE CAPS FOR
THE DRAINER OF THE PANDEMIC.
BECAUSE THEY HEARD THE VOICES
OF TONS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT SAID THEY WERE BEING
EXPLOITED. WITH HIGH FEES. AND
THIS IS WHY CIT COUNCILS. AND
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND EVERYONE
RALLIED TO GET THIS TICKET
STARTS WHITE SAID SO HOW
WIDESPREAD. AND TO HAVE THAT
UNIFORMITY. AND THAT
RECOGNITION THE STATE LEVELS
CAN BE WOULD BE SO IMPORTANT-
BECAUSE ALREADY OUR BUSINESSES
ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT AS MANY OF
THE CALLERS OF RECOGNIZE THAT
MANY OF THE PLOT. MANY OF THE
BUSINESSES HAVE CLOSED THEIR
DOORS. AND WORKING ON A RAZOR
THIN MARGIN. RIGHT NOW IT'S
EVEN WORSE WHEN YOU HAVE THOSE
THIS IS WHAT IT FEES. I WISH
WELL THIS ALL PART OF MY SPINE
AND I WISH YOUR DASH WE'RE HERE
OF THEMSELVES DESPITE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I WAS GOING
TO ASK THEM. ONCE THE
EMERGENCY. ORDINANCE IS EXPIRED
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH. WHAT DAY BOB
UP THERE CAN BE. AT WHAT BULK
OF THEIR FEES AGAIN BECAUSE
THEY IS NO GOOD. THAT THEY CAN
START AGAIN. GO BEYOND 15% AND
CHARGE RESTAURANTS REPORTERS.
AND STILL CHARGE CUSTOMERS
EXTRA PRICE THEY CAN MAKE A
DOUBLE PROFIT OFF THIS AND I
WAS THERE HERE TO ANSWER THAT.
IS MY BET IS THEY'RE GOING TO
DO BOTH OF THEM AND RE DOUBLE
PROFIT- BUT YOU KNOW THE BILL
STILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT IT
HAS A GREAT TRANSPARENCY FOR
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES TO
UNDERSTAND WHO THEY'RE DOING
BUSINESS WITH. WHAT THOSE FEES
GO TO. BUT ULTIMATELY STILL
THIS. YOU KNOW OF COURSE THE
ONLY PLATFORMS ARE IMPORTED IN
CONGRESS NOW THE DIGITAL AGE IN
THE MODERN AGE. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT BUSINESSES
SHOULD COUPLE WE SUBMIT TO THE
WILL. OF THESE BIG PLATFORMS.
SO THE BILL SO REALLY IMPORTANT
STEP AND I URGE I WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT BUT- I REALLY
WANT TO THANK. SOMEONE.
GONZALEZ FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER BENNETT GO AHEAD. THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT THAT STILL
REMAIN IN THIS BILL I THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND ONE IS THE
PROTECTION OF THE TIPS- AND THE
MANIPULATION THAT CAN HAPPEN
WITH THAT AND THAT'S JUST JUST
ESSENTIAL. AND THEN THE
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IS. AT
LEAST A MOVES THE NEEDLE OF
FURTHER ALONG FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT MAYBE IS GOING
ON. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE BILL. SO ARE
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALSO- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH OUR- A TEAM AND-
AND TAKING THE AMENDMENTS IS
ALSO. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT
REALLY- YOU KNOW GETTING A LOT
OF- IMPORTANT SO GOING FORWARD
SO. SO I URGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
HELP WITH THE PLEASE LET US
KNOW. SO WE GOT TO FEEL FREE TO
CLOSE AN OR TRY SOME OF THE
ISSUES. IF YOU SEE THANK YOUNG-
YOU KNOW IT. SOMETIMES WE SIT
HERE AND HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
INDIVIDUALS AND SUDDENLY
THEY'RE IN OPPOSITION WITHOUT A
LOT OF EXPLANATION WHY SO. I
WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED TO HEAR
THE LATINO RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION TO SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN LATINO
COMMUNITY. AND HAS A TON OF
LATINO OWNED RESTAURANTS IN MY
DISTRICT I THOUGHT HOW STRANGE
I HAVEN'T HEARD OF THEM. SO
WHEN ON THE WEBSITE WHILE THEY
WERE TALKING. AND I FIND THAT
IN FACT THEY THEY CLAIM THAT
THEIR PARTNERS ARE WALMART
DOORDASH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS TEMPERATE. UTILITIES.
VALERO OIL. SO IN FOR. I'M NOT
SURE IF WE'RE TALKING TO
RESTAURANTS AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- THAT IS WHAT
I'VE SPENT MY TIMEDOING DURING
THIS PANDEMIC IS. ACTUALLY
TALKING TO THE SMALL MOM AND
POP RESTAURANTS IN MY
COMMUNITY. AND OVERWHELMINGLY
THEY KNOW THESE ARE PROBLEMS.
OVERWHELMINGLY THEY YES SUPPORT
A CAP. AND IF NOT A CAP AT
LEAST A TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING DIFFERENT
STORIES FROM THE DELIVERY
COMPANIES. AND THEIR CUSTOMERS
AND THE DRIVERS ON WHAT EXACTLY
IS HAPPENING. ANOTHER FEATURE
OF THIS- AT THIS BILL THE KIND
OF GUY IT WAS HARD TO SEE BUT
IT ALSO PREVENTS THE CUT THE-
THE COMPANIES FROM PROVIDING.
ADDING THEIR OWN COST TO THE
MENU ITEMS BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD
THAT AS WELL YOU KNOW AS- AS
THE SMALL VIETNAMESE
RESTAURANT- THAT I ENJOY GOING
TO SAYS YOU KNOW YOU CAN
PURCHASE SPRING ROLLS FOR SEVEN
NINETY NINE YET IF YOU DO IT
THROUGH DOORDASH SOMEHOW THAT.
BECAME NINE NINETY NINE AND
THAT'S NOT THE RESTAURANT
DOESN'T EVEN NECESSARILY KNOW
THAT'S HAPPENING SO THERE ARE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES IN THIS
TYPE OF THING. AND I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED FOR OUR
SMALL COMMUNITIES THERE'S ONE
OTHER THING I CANNOT AS A
FORMER. ADVOCATE I CANNOT LEAVE
WITHOUT SAYING. IT IS BEYOND ME
THE DOOR DASH THEMSELVES CAN'T
COME HERE AND TALK ABOUT THEIR
HISTORY BY THE WAY LAST
NOVEMBER OF BEING CAUGHT RED
HANDED IN STEALING TIPS FROM
THEIR BAY AREA WORKERS AND
BEING FORCED TO PAY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BUT
INSTEAD STRONG ARMS OR
MANIPULATES OR THREATENS THEIR
OWN DRIVERS TO COME AND SAY
THEY DON'T WANT A BILL THAT
SAYS THEY GET THEIR TIPS. GIVE
ME A BREAK IN OF DOORDASH HAD
ANY CREDIBILITY THEY THEMSELVES
WOULD COME AND ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
IMPETUS FOR THE TIP PORTION OF%
THIS BILL. AND SO LIKE YOU
MISTER LEE THANK YOU FOR SAYING
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION. FOR THE OTHER
ANCILLARY GROUPS THAT SOMEHOW
OUR POSES AND I CAN'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND WHY I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO COME TO MY OFFICE AND TALK
TO ME. YOU KNOW THERE WERE
THERE WERE GROUPS THAT. THE
SIGHT SEEING THEM OPPOSE. OR
SUPPORT PROP TWENTY TWO I
HAVEN'T SEEN AT ALL ON THIS
ISSUE SO I'D LOVE TO TALK TO
THEM. DEEPER YOU KNOW WHETHER
THEY BE CHURCHES- OR CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS BUT- IT
JUST SEEMS VERY SUSPECT. THAT
WE HAVE GROUPS THAT
TRADITIONALLY HAVE BEEN FOR.
WORKING CLASS. PEOPLE OF COLOR
THAT'S TO THESE DRIVERS ARE IN
ARE POSING A BILL THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT THEY GET THE TIPS
AT THE CUSTOMER. ACTUALLY MEANT
TO GO TO THEM. SO I'M A LITTLE
DISTURBED BY THE OPPOSITION TO
HIM SORRY BUT YOU KNOW LET'S
HAVE HONEST DISCUSSIONS LET'S
LET'S KNOW WHO WERE TALKING TO
AND IT'S A LITTLE HARDER WHEN
THEY'RE NOT EVEN HERE IN
PERSON. BUT IF YOU KNOW DOOR
DASH OPPOSES BILL OBVIOUSLY
THEY DO THEY'RE DOING IT
THROUGH EIGHT OTHER DIFFERENT
SOURCES. THEN COME DOWN AND
LET'S HAVE A DISCUSSION. BUT
SENDING OTHER PEOPLE PRETENDING
THAT IT'S SOMEHOW GRASSROOTS
OPPOSITION IS JUST
DISINGENUOUS. I HOPE WE CAN.
GET SOME. HONEST CONVERSATIONS
GOING WITH THESE COMPANIES AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CLOSING AND WITH THAT-
MR SECRETARY THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS AB TWO EIGHT
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR. CHAP HI
CHECK OUT HI KILEY. BAUER K.
HAND. POWER QUE HAN AYE BENNETT
AYE BENNETT AYE CARILLO.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER IRWIN. LEE
LEE HIGHWAY X. YOU HAVE FIVE
VOTE SO WILL BE DEVELOPING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. ALL
RIGHT SO THAT BRINGS US TO THE
NEXT AUTHOR AND I BELIEVE THIS
MISTER LEAD EUROPE BY. AND WE
HAVE- A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR- ITEMS SEVENTEEN. THE
THEY'RE RELEVANT TO HAVE BACK
TO BACK DISCUSSIONS SURE. OKAY
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY OKAY MAYBE
GET THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
VERY HARD WITH MY TEAM ON OUR
LANGUAGE AMENDMENTS AND I'M
HAPPY TO SEND EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR FOR A FEW
REASONS FIRST TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND ENSURE THEY ARE
EQUIPPED WITH ALL THE KNOWLEDGE
THEY NEED WHEN THEY MAKE
FINANCIAL CHOICES ON WHO
THEY'RE DOING BUSINESS WITH.
SECOND IS TO PROTECT OUR LOCAL
RESTAURANTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DEVASTATED BY THIS
PANDEMIC. MANY BUSINESSES HAVE
HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO BECOME
MORE RELIANT ON THIRD PARTY
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM TO
SURVIVE DURING THE PANDEMIC.
ECONOMY AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH IS AN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS. SINCE RESTAURANTS ARE
EXISTENTIALLY RELY ON THESE
SERVICES THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITY IN BARGAINING POWER
BETWEEN THE PLATFORMS AND
RESTAURANTS WHEN THE AVERAGE
PROFIT MARGIN OF OPERATING A
RESTAURANT IS ONLY THREE TO
FIVE PERCENT. SMALL RESTAURANTS
BEING CHARGE UPWARDS OF 30% ON
FOOD DELIVERY ORDERS CHIPS AWAY
AT THEIR ALREADY DWINDLING
MARGINS DESPITE GROWING
COMPETITION THE SPACE. THE FOOD
DELIVERY INDUSTRIES PRIMARILY
CONTROLLED BY FOUR COMPANIES.
OVER EATS POSTMATES DOORDASH
AND GRUBHUB AND AS OF LAST
MONTH THESE FOUR COMPANIES WITH
BILLIONS IN VENTURE CAPITAL
BACKING CONTROL 99% OF SALES IN
THE FOOD DELIVERY MARKET. THIS
DOMINANCE IS ACTUALLY RESULTED
IN THE FILING OF A CLASS ACTION
ANTITRUST LAWSUIT THE STATE OF
NEW YORK. THIS LAWSUIT AMONG
OTHER THINGS CLAIMS THESE FOUR
COMPANIES BARELYCOMPETED ALL
CONSPIRE TO KEEP COMMISSIONS
HIGH AND KOREA WAGES LOW.
DURING THE PANDEMIC IT IS CLEAR
THAT THE BIG TECH MONOPOLIES
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CAPITALIZE ON
THIS NEW REALITY WHILE I
RESTAURANTS OF STRUGGLE TO
SURVIVE. AND DO THAT IS IN A
PUBLIC AND MISINFORMED
NARRATIVES SURROUNDING COVER
NINETEEN THESE IMPACTS HAVE
BEEN FELT EVEN HARDER BY ASIAN
AND ASIAN OWNED RESTAURANTS.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC OVER FORTY THOUSAND
RESTAURANTSHAVE CLOSED THEIR
DOORS IN CALIFORNIA. ASIAN
RESTAURANTS HAVE HAD A FAR
HIGHER RATE CLOSURE THE NON
ASIAN RESTAURANTS AND IT'S EVEN
REPORT THAT ROUGHLY HALF OF ALL
CHINESE RESTAURANTS. IN THE
UNITED STATES HAVE CLOSE SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF PANDEMIC. IT
IS IMPERATIVE WE PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY TOOLS IN PROTECTIONS
TO OUR SMALL BUSINESSES SO THEY
ARE ABLE TO SURVIVE RECOVER AND
THRIVE WE MUST ENSURE THEY'RE
NOT BE EXPLOITED BY BIG
TECHNOPOLIS. AND THIS IS WHY WE
ARE HAPPY TO HAVE THE SILICON
VALLEY CHAMBER COALITION ALONG
WITH THE MOUNTAIN VIEW CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND HISPANIC
SILICON VALLEY CHAMBER
SUPPORTING. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR THIS BILL.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTER MY WITNESS IN SUPPORT. OF
FREMONT COUNCILMEMBER TERESA
CHANG AND SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SMALL RESTAURANT OWNER OF THE
VERY TASTY MILK AND HONEY CAFE
IN THE CITY OF FREMONT. THANK
GREAT NECK. THE BILL SIMMONS
MOVED AND SECONDED- MISS KING
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT ASPEN GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS TERRY TALKING AND I'M THE
OWNER OF A TAIWANESE RESTAURANT
NO CAN YOU COMPLAIN FREMONT
CALIFORNIA I'M OAKLAND
COUNCILMEMBER CONTAINING
DISTRICT ONE IN CITY OF. I
THINK MY NOW RESTAURANT ACROSS
CAL AND THE COUNTRY AMONG THE
HARDEST HIT TECHNICAL DURING
THE EXAM EIGHT. THERE'S AN
ESTIMATE CLOSE 250% OFF
RESTAURANTS BEING PERMANENTLY
CLOSE. WHILE THE ONES THAT ARE
PROVIDING ALL WORKING VERY HARD
TO KEEP AFLOAT. AND IT IS
ALREADY PAYING UPWARDS OF
25230% TO. DELIVERY PLATFORMS
AND HALF OF THAT ANOTHER 10220%
IN MARKETING FEES IF YOU WANT
TO SPEND TO PROMOTE YOUR
RESTAURANT AND WALDRON. WE
CANNOT PUT YOU AND NEED TO BE
PROTECTED BY OUR LEGISLATION A
CALL COMING IN. FROM CUSTOMERS
DIRECTLY RESULT IN. REFERRAL
PLEASE WITHOUT A TWO PARTY
THING AND FAR. LONG BEFORE YELP
AND GRUBHUB AND THEIR
PARTNERSHIP. CUPPED CUSTOMERS
HAVE BEEN USING YELP TO SEARCH
FOR RESTAURANTS. AND NOW THAT
THEY WANT TO CALL RESTAURANTS
DIRECTLY AND PICK UP ORDERS.
FROM THE RESTAURANT SO THEY CAN
GET OUT OF THE RESTAURANT AND
THAT GET PAID MORE YELP AND
GRUBHUB DECIDED THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CHARGE THE REFERRAL
FEE. WITHOUT ADDING MORE
SERVICES. IT'S ACTUALLY A TRACK
BY THE BIG CORPORATIONS AND THE
SMALL BUSINESSES SHOULD BE
PROTECTED COMING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS BILL
WE APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS AND
ALL THE WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEEN NO ONE IN THE ROOM OR
AT THE REMOTE LOCATION WHO WISH
TO SPEAK OUT LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR. ADDITIONAL.
PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM SUPPORTERS.
OF THIS. AND THAT IS SET UP FOR
FORTY FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OR COMMENT IN THE OF AB
FORTY FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN. ZERO AND WE
HAVE A COMMENT COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH- LINE NUMBER.
JUST BE ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE.
I AM NOT LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY KIDS UP.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME VERY WELL- HI THERE
IS NO REGISTER OPPOSITION
EITHER SO I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
HERE IN THE ROOM SO LET'S OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR CALLERS.
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO IT
EIGHTY B. FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HANNAH
SMITH ON BEHALF OF GRUBHUB
GRUBHUB FIRMLY BELIEVES IN A
FUTURE WHERE THERE IS A VIBRANT
AND GROWING RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY THAT IS ABLE TO
BALANCE IN PERSON AND OVER THE
OPTIONS FOR DINERS AND WE SEE
OURSELVES AS PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY NGUYEN AND ALONGSIDE
A RESTAURANT PARTNERS. HOWEVER
OPPOSED IT EIGHT. MEN AT THIS
POINT WE JUST. WE'RE NOT TAKING
TESTIMONY SO. WE JUST ASKING
FOR NAME. AND ALSO THE
ORGANIZATION. ALL HE DID OKAY
SO ALREADY SO I APOLOGIZE
SALUTE PLEASE CONTINUE THEN IF
THERE'S A REGISTER BECAUSE I
WASN'T TOO. I GOT YOU OKAY
POLICE TO CONTINUE THAT I'M
SORRY MY APOLOGIES. THANK YOU
OKAY- PROBABLY HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR AND DRAFTED
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
WEBSITES FROM LISTING PHONE
NUMBERS FOR DINERS TO ORDER
THROUGH GRUBHUB WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT SERVICE THAT OUR
RESTAURANT PARTNERS CHOOSE TO
CONTRACT WITH UP TO PROVIDE.
PHONE ORDER YOUR CRITICAL
SERVICE MAKING OUR PLATFORM
MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR THE
VISUALLY IMPAIRED AND FOR THOSE
WHO ARE MORE COMFORTABLE USING
A PHONE AND A COMPUTER. WHAT IF
THE NATION IF ANYTHING IF THE
TECHNOLOGY DOESN'TALWAYS WORK
AND PHONE NUMBERS ARE NECESSARY
BACK UP. IT CURRENTLY AT EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR IS
UNTENABLE AND IN WHAT CAN ONLY
BE INTERPRETED AS A SINGULAR
FOCUS TO REMOVE GRANDPA'S
ABILITY TO CONDUCT PHONE
ORDERS. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT HE INTENDED TO SELL WHAT
TO GUARANTEE THAT RESTAURANTS
ARE ONLY CHARGE FOR PHONE
ORDERS THAT RESULT IN AN ACTUAL
ORDER. IMPLEMENTED A SERIES OF
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE THE SAME
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOWARDS A
SOLUTION WITH THE BALLPARK
THERE. IT ENABLE THE CONTINUED
DINER AND RESTAURANT CONNECTION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
OTHER. ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT. MISTER CAREY HAVE
NO FOR COMMENT THAT THAT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND THAT'S
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE MISBAH
CAN. I HAD FOR LEE I DID NOT
KNOW ABOUT THIS PRACTICE UNTIL
I WAS READING THIS LAST NIGHT
SHORTLY AFTER ORDERING FOOD
YELP AND FELT. INCREDIBLY
GUILTY AND I'M A CONSUMER WHO
ESPECIALLY WHEN I'M FREQUENTING
MY LOCAL- SMALL RESTAURANTS
GOES OUT OF MY WAY TO PICK IT
UP TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESTAURANT IS GALLIC GETTING
THE FULL VALUE OF. MY BUSINESS
AND TO KNOW THAT I HAD.
BASICALLY BEEN DUPED INTO
TAKING SOME OF THAT PROFIT AWAY
FROM MY LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS
WAS PRETTY UPSETTING TO ME- AND
SO I THINK THIS IS A PRACTICE I
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT.
THERE'S TRANSPARENCY AND
CONSUMERS CAN MAKE THE CHOICE
IT'S JUST AS EASY FOR ME TO GO
ON THE WEBSITE AND CALL THEM
DIRECTLY BUT I DIDN'T KNOW
THERE WAS A DIFFERENCE. AND SO
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
MOVE THIS FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT. HURTING OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES IN A WAY THAT
IS UNNECESSARY. THANK YOU. YES
WE GET- MISCONDUCT. THIS THE
PRACTICE THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET OUT WAS WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ABOUT HAD JUST DESCRIBED
TO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN
YOU'RE SORT OF ARE EXPECTING
THIS TO BE THE DIRECT NUMBER-
FOR THE RESTAURANT IT'S
INSTEAD- IT IS ROUTED THROUGH
SAY GRUBHUB AND SOTHEY GET TO
TAKE A KIND OF ANY RESULTING
PROCIDA COMMISSION JUST WHETHER
OR NOT YOUR THAT'S THE IDEA
RENDON AND SO. SO WHAT IS A
DILIGENT USE OF ROBOT MAYBE A
QUESTION FOR GRUBHUB OUT THERE
HERE. WHAT WHAT IS THAT THE- OF
WHAT IS I MEAN YEAH I S. THAT
YOU HAVE A BROADER- YOU KNOW
FUNCTIONALITY. ARE YOU STILL ON
THE LINE MOST. OF YOU GET THE
NAME OF THE PERSON. WEBER. THE
OPERATOR CAN YOU CHECK TO SEE
IF- THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
GRUBHUB IS STILL ON THE LINE.
AT ALL. CAN ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHAT WHILE WE'RE WAITING FIFTY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM FROM
GRUBHUB IS STILL ON THE LINE HE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO WE
CAN IDENTIFY YOUR LINE. YOU
KNOW WE TRIED. I WOULD LIKE AN
ANSWER I'D BUY IT- QUESTION I
GUESS I'VE USUALLY IS SO UNDER
YOUR BILL THEY WOULD STILL GET
A COMMISSION IF AN ORDER IS
PLACED RIGHT BUT THAT DOESN'T
SORT OF. SEEM TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM AS FAR AS I CAN SEE IT
IN THAT THAT ORDER MIGHT STILL
HAVE ULTIMATELY BEEN PLACE
BECAUSE IT WAS ROUTED THROUGH
THIS YOU KNOW A YELP OR WHAT
HAVE YOU- NUMBER AND SO. WHY IS
THAT KIND OF WHAT DETERMINES
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN TAKE A
CONDITION JUST KIND OF THE
ARBITRARY FACT OF THE CUSTOMER
PLACES AN ORDER AS OPPOSED TO
SORT OF- YOU KNOW JUST TRYING
TO STOP THIS PRACTICE ON THE
FRONT END OF THE RE ROUTING.
RIGHT IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION A CELERY KILEY SO MY
BILL DOESN'T PREVENT THEM FROM
STILL HAVING A CHARGE RIGHT-
ESSENTIALLY AND TO MAYBE ANSWER
YOUR FIRST QUESTION YEP IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT IS KIND OF A
DEAL BECAUSE I GREW UP UP ACTS
AND OTHER AS ANOTHER
INTERMEDIARY WITH AN EMBEDDED
WITHIN YELP I'VE BEEN WITH
DANIEL. SO WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE USING THE CALL SO WHEN
YOU CALL FOR AN ORDER IS ONE
NUMBER THAT MIGHT SAY POWER
BANKRUPT YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THAT MEANS SO THEY COULD BE
TRACKING THAT ORDER AND USING
THAT TRACKING THE ADJUSTER
CHARGER RESTAURANT CORRECT BUT
I'M THINKING AS AS A SELLER
BARKING HANNAH NOTED IF MORE
CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND THAT
DIFFERENCE AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
POWER BY GRUBHUB MEANS OR THIS
TRACKING. J. MIGHT ALTER THEIR
BEHAVIOR MORE SO IN CONTACT THE
BUSINESS MORE DIRECTLY BECAUSE
I THINK CONSUMERS HAVE A FAIR
EXPECTATION THAT YELP IS ACTING
LIKE A YELP PAGE IS ACTUALLY
JUST FINDING THE CONTACT
INFORMATION AND YOU ONE DOLLAR
ORDER YOU HAD PROBABLY NO
INTENTION THAT YOUR BILLING THE
ACT THE RESTAURANT EXTRA ON TOP
OF THAT SO THAT'S WHY I THINK
IS IMPORTANT SO I GET THAT I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WHY SHOULD
THE ABILITY OF GRUBHUB TO
CHARGE DEPEND UPON KIND OF THE
ARBITRARY FACT OF WHETHER THAT.
THE CUSTOMERS ENDS. UP PLACING
THE ORDER NOT. I THINK THAT'S
ACCESS QUESTION. WILL BILLS NOT
TO EXTERRAN THEIR BUSINESS BUT
CERTAINLY TO MAKE IT MORE
TRANSPARENT AND CONSUMER
FRIENDLY. BUT IT IS A VALID
CONCERN. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. YEAH MR PRATER WOULD
YOU PLEASE. A DOUBLE CHECK TO
SEE IF- THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
GRUBHUB IS STILL AROUND. I
THINK WE HAVE AND WE HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM. WE HAVE
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM GRUBHUB
AN ONLINE AT ASPEN WHICH I DID
I WOULD LIKE TO RE ASK THE
QUESTION OR DID THAT YOU HAVE
THAT QUESTION. YEAH YOU DO YOU
HAVE THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HAVE YOU BE APT GET SURE THANK
YOU RIGHT. WHAT DID YOU SORT OF
PROGRESS- YOU KNOW YOUR TAKE ON
THE PRACTICE. RIGHT HERE AND-
WHETHER THAT'S- SORT OF THE
MAIN THING YOU DO AND HOW WHAT
IS THAT SORT OF THAT. AFTER
LABOR- CUSTOMER TO TAKE OF YOUR.
ONE OF MANY SERVICES THAT
GRUBHUB PROVIDES AND ALSO I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS IS THAT
THIS IS A SERVICE THAT OUR
RESTAURANT PARTNERS CONTRACTING
WITH US TO PROVIDE CARE IF
THEY'RE FULLY AWARE OF THE
PRACTICE- AND ESSENTIALLY ADDED
CORD REFUGEES ITSELF AND THAT A
MARKETING AND ADVERTISING
ENGINE FOR RESTAURANTS AND FOR
RESTAURANT PARTNERS. AND SO IT
JUST GOES INTO THE ENTIRE TEAM
OF ME WE WILL CHARGE COMMISSION
ON NEEDS AND ON ORDERS THAT
GRAB HAD GENERATED A PLATFORM-
BUT WE WILL NOT CHARGE ORDERED
YOU KNOW WE WON'T CHARGE
RESTAURANT ORDER COMMISSION
FOR- BURKE COLDER ORDERS THAT
DON'T RESULT IN ORDER OR IN THE
LEAD UP YOURSELF COULD NOT
GENERATE. AND SO WHEN IT COMES
TO PHONE ORDERS IN PARTICULAR
THERE HAVE TO BE A SEPARATE
PHONE NUMBER BECAUSE OTHERWISE
HOW WOULD GRAB A BE ABLE TO
PROVE THAT CRAP PUBLIC THE ONE
THAT GENERATED A LEAD- AND SO
IT'S A VERY BASIC OLD SCHOOL
PRACTICE HONESTLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE OTHER
MARKETING FIRMS IN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN USING PHONE BATES
ORDERING. SERVICES FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS HAVE USED-
AND THIS IS SIMPLY A
CONTINUATION ABOUT FOR OUR
RESTAURANT PARTNERS AND AGAIN I
WANT TO BE CLEAR IF THE
PRACTICE IS DISCONTINUED OR ON
ALLOWED WHICH IS THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED IT IS
RESTAURANTS WOULD LOSE THOSE
ORDERS. THOSE ORDERS WERE NO
LONGER BE COMING TO THE
RESTAURANT AND SO YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
BILL PAPADAKIS AND ENGAGING%
THEM AND WE'RE VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR OUR PARTNERSHIP ON
THAT THANK YOU THINK THERE'S A
SOLUTION THAT WE CAN GET YOU.
THAT AS PRESENTLY DRAFTED ALL.
IT DOES OF **** RESTAURANT
BUSINESS. IN THIS CHAPTER I
FEEL. ME JUST. YOUR GOING
EASILY AT KILEY IDEX. YOU KNOW
YELP IS THE ALL PAGES OF
PLATFORM GRUBHUB IS A BETTER
WITHIN IT. SO USER GO ON THE
APP YELP THEY FOR RESTAURANTS
THEY GO DON'T GO ON APP OF GRUB
TO FIND RESTAURANTS SO. WHILE
IT IS PART OF THE CONTRACT AND
IT IS SOMETHING THAT
RESTAURANTS ENTRANCE TO WHEN
THEY TRY TO YOU KNOW COMPETE
THEM. THE ONLINE MARKET PLACE
IT'S NOT IMMEDIATELY CLEAR TO
THEM BY THE SAME TIME. IT'S A
CALLED A MARKETING. THREE ARE
MARKING SERVICES QUITE A
STRETCH BECAUSE YELP IS THE
PLATFORM THAT DOES THE LISTING
IN THE MARKETING. GRUBHUB IS
JUST KINDA INTERMEDIARY
SERVICE. SO WHY DOES GOPIS
THEIR NUMBER AS OPPOSED TO THE
REST OF SOMEBODY'S IT DESCRIBED
LIKE MAKE IT EASIER. FOR THEM
TO ABROGATE ALL THESE NUMBERS.
THAT WOULD BE A VERY YELP. HAVE
LIGHTED HE'S FOR. BUT I MEAN
ALSO YOU KNOW I HAVE IT I IT
I'VE A SUSPECT KNOW IT'S IT
COMES DOWN TO HOW YOU CAN. MAKE
MONEY IN THE SYSTEM RIGHT I
MEAN THE MORE INTERMEDIARIES
AND HIS TAX SYSTEM THEN YOU CAN
MAKE MORE MONEY BUT- IF IT IS A
GOOD QUESTION FORGET WHY THEY
HAVE TO HAVE AN INTERMEDIARY.
AND YOU HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH
YELP. IF THAT MAKES IT EASIER
TO UNDERSTAND OR NOT IT IS IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WORK ON
TOGETHER. OKAY I'M JUST TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PROHIBITING A PRACTICE THAT
ACTUALLY ADDS VALUE FOR
CONSUMERS LIKE IF. YOU KNOW
THAT. YOU HAVE THESE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ACTUALLY
PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH EASIER
ACCESS TO THE PHONE NUMBERS
THAN THEY MIGHT OTHERWISE HAVE-
AND I'M- A LITTLE WORRIED THAT
ANYTIME YOU INTERFERE WITH
VOLUNTARY. ARRANGEMENTS LIKE
THIS MAYBE WILL BE. UNDERMINING
CONSUMER WELFARE AND THAT WAY.
MR CUNNINGHAM FOLLOWED BY
MISTER BENNETT YEAH THIS THIS
MIGHT BE KIND OF A DUMB
QUESTION BUT THAT DOES THIS
BILL CHANGE ANYTHING. I'M KINDA
NEW TO THE ORDERING FOOD THING
THAT'S I MEAN ON ON AN APPLE.
UNCERTAIN THAT TOP OF IT NOW I
SEEM TO DO ALL TIME BUT AS MANY
PEOPLE I JUST GO ON GRUBHUB'S
APP. AND THEN PICK MY
RESTAURANT FROM THERE WITH THIS
BILL CHANGE ANYTHING NO YOU
WOULD GO ON THE YELP APP WHICH
IS THE MOST COMMON LISTING
SERVICE SO AS WE DEFINE THE
BILL WE TALK ABOUT THE LISTING
SERVICES- GRUBHUB IS JUST KIND
OF THE INTIMATE PARTNER THAT
DOES A LOT OF- ORDER
FULFILLMENT- AND IT'S HARD TO
EXPLAIN BECAUSE THEY DON'T
TECHNICALLY DELIVER THE FOOD
EITHER THEY'RE JUST KINDA. IN
THERE IN THE MIDDLE AND THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY TO CLARIFY THAT
THERE SHOULDN'T BE. A
MISLEADING PHONE NUMBER BECAUSE
IN THE PAST THIS IS A RECENT
DEVELOPMENT GROWTH GRUB GRUB
HUB SLASH YELL BECAUSE THEY
WORKED IT LIKE THIS- DID LIST
NUMBERS THAT WERE NOT
REFLECTIVE SAY IF YOU WANT TO
THE ACTUAL BUSINESSES WEBSITE
OR LOOK AT THEIR MENU. THERE
WITH DIFFERENT NUMBER BECAUSE
ARE USING THAT TO TRACK AND NOW
IT SEEMS THEY ARE USING THE
SAME NUMBER BUT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO DISCERN WHAT IS
HAPPENING STILL SO THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENED BUT YEAH YOU
WOULD GO ON YELP AND YOU'D
STILL BE ABLE TO FIND THE
RESTAURANT BUT STILL BE THERE.
THROUGH YOUR ISSUE IS IF I GO
THROUGH HEALTH AND THEN I BET
ON ON YELP THERE'S GRUBHUB'S
SOMETHING YES IF YOU PRESS THE
POWER BUTTON ALL YEAH AND THEN
THE ORDER COUNTING. FOR AND
THEY'RE STILL CHARGING THE
RESTAURANT. SO WHAT HAPPENED
THE PAST SAY YOU ON THE YOU
PRESS THE CALL BUTTON KALRA.
BUTTON AND CALLED ME LIKE- I'M-
THIS A GLASS KNOWN AS RAJENDRA.
HISTORICALLY THE- CALL BECAUSE
IT GOT ROUTE AND AFTER. BIG
STILL. THE RESTAURANT EVEN IF
IT DID NOT RESULT IN ORDER
BECAUSE THEY'RE CLAIMING. THAT
THEY'RE GIVING GENERATING LEADS
FOR THEM. WHEN IN FACT YOU GO
ON. THE YELP WEBSITE TO FIND
IT'S NOT LIKE GRUBHUB PROVIDED
LEAVE INTEREST WAS THE SERVICE.
OKAY I THINK I THINK THAT
CLARIFIES IT YEAH THANK.
CERTAINLY NOT SUPER INTUITIVE
AS AS I HAVE COME TO LEARN TO
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
INTERESTING PRACTICES THAT WERE
NEGATIVE MISTER BENNETT. YEAH I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT- TO A LARGE
EXTENT THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
COMPETITION. AND THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT COMPETITION IN THE
MARKETPLACE AND SO THE SMALL
RESTAURANT. IS DOESN'T HAVE THE
OPTION OF HAVING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PLACES THEY COULD GO
AND- HAVE THAT COMPETITION AND
DRIVE DOWN THE PRICE- MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE BEING TREATED
FAIRLY X. CENTER. AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE CONSTANTLY CHANGING
THE FACT THAT THERE'S
INSUFFICIENT COMPETITION
BECAUSE- THE ANTI TRUST LAWS IN
THE APPLICATION OF ALL THOSE IS
VERY SLOW AND CUMBERSOME. AND
THIS TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING SO
FAST I MEAN. MOST OF US AS AS
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTED
OUT TO A LAST NIGHT SHE WASN'T
EVEN AWARE OF THIS RIGHT SO-
THIS IS OFF THE RADAR SCREEN
AND SO THIS IS AN ATTEMPT. TO
TRY TO ADDRESS ONE. RELATIVELY
SMALL PART OF INADEQUATE
COMPETITION AND WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IN THE TECHNOLOGY FIELD
AS- THE THERE'S A CONSTANT
ATTEMPT TO BUY OUT YOUR
COMPETITORS. WERE PARTNER UP
WITH YOUR COMPETITORS SO THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE THIS COMPETITION
EVER INVOLVED AND SO I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ALWAYS
BE SENSITIVE TO THAT. AND
REALLY HAVE THE TO HAVE THESE
KIND OF BILLS AND ACTIONS TO
BE. A WAY OF TO BE ON NOTICE
THAT YOU CAN'T. ABUSE YOUR
MONOPOLISTIC POSITION IN THE
MARKET PLACE YOU HAVE YOU
SHOULD BE PROACTIVELY. FAIR
WITH THE SMALL RESTAURANT AND
SAY OKAY IF YOU DIDN'T GET AN
ORDER WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
THIS OR- OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
SO THAT'S- THAT'S HOW I VIEW IT
MORE FROM US. YOU KNOW TRYING
TO COUNTER COUNTER BALANCE OF A
GREAT IMBALANCE THAT IS OUT
THERE THAT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ALL OF US TO TRY
TO ADJUST IT IN THIS. FAST
MOVING WORLD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WE GET OF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT IT IS
JUST THE FASTENER HOW MANY MANY
WAYS YOU COULD STAY TRANSACTION
AND- IT'S JUST A VERY EYE
OPENING I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING OF THE BILL FOR IT AND
ALONG WITH THE PREVIOUS BILL I
THINK UP YOU KNOW I'VE LEARNED
SO MUCH ABOUT THIS A BUSINESS
AS A WHOLE IN CANADA WELL THANK
WITH DOING THAT TOO SO- AND
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU KNOW PRACTICES OUT
THERE SO THAT THE I THINK THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED SO- FEEL FREE
TO CLOSE. YEAH I'LL JUST SAY
VERY BRIEFLY YOU KNOW IN MY
SHORT TIME HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THE COUPLE MONTHS I'VE COME TO
REALIZE SOMETHING VERY- CLEARLY
ONE OF THEM IS A
DISPROPORTIONATE LOBBYING POWER
OF BIG TECH CORPORATIONS
IMMERSES OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT WE RELY ON EVERY DAY IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT MAKE IT SO
UNIQUE AND VIBRANT AND MY BILL
SIMPLY SIX TO REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF SMALL BUSINESS
AGAINST ALL THE ODDS AND AS
WE'VE COME TO LEARN PERSONALLY
ANALYZE AND SOLVE BUSINESSES
INDEPENDENT MAKE CHANGE A LOT
OF OUR DINING HABITS RIGHT MANY
OF US WOULD NEVER HAVE ORDAINED
TO THINK ABOUT GOING ON AN APP.
AND ORDERING THAT WAY WHEN YOUR
BUSINESS IS NEVER STRUCTURE THE
BUSINESS AROUND THAT EITHER AND
TO STAY COMPETITIVE AND TO STAY
ALIVE DURING THESE VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES DAVE THEY LOOK
TO THESE APPS AND SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW THAT'S NOT AS TRANSPARENT
OR ST FORT IS A THOUGHT I CAN
TELL YOU THIS BILL CAME BECAUSE
ONE DAY I ORDERED. A MEAL VIA
YELP GRUBHUB AND HE ALMOST
CUSSED ME OUT BECAUSE HE WANTED
HEALTHY IS HEADED EVEN THOUGH
HE'S LIKE THOUGHTS ALL HORRIBLE
OF ALL THESE THINGS AND
EVERYBODY KNOW THAT AND OF
COURSE YOU KNOW IT'S ONE OF THE
MANY GREAT ASIAN SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
ALREADY SO- I WANT TO THANK
THAT CONSTITUENT FOR BRING THIS
TO MY ATTENTION VERY VIVIDLY
AND I WANNA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JIM. MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AT THIS. AB ONE FOR.
FOUR THE MOST. IS DUE. AS A- TO
FLOOR. CHECK OUT HI CHAO I
KILEY. KILEY NOT VOTING
BARRICADE HAND ARE QUE HAND AYE
BENNETT. BENNETT I CARILLO.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GABRIEL GALLAGHER IRWIN HI-
WHEN I LEVY HI LEE I WICKS. YOU
HAVE SIX WHAT'S YOUR BILL IS UP
TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS SO THAT BRINGS
US TO- I BELIEVE MISS IRWIN-
ITEM FIFTEEN YOU HAVE A B. TWO
SIX EIGHT. HE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED. ALL RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT THE AB TWO SIX H. EIGHT
WHICH WILL PROTECT THE PRIVACY
OF MY MURDERED CONSTITUENTS WHO
DID IN THE BORDERLINE MASS
SHOOTING AB TWO SIX EIGHT IS
BASED ON EXISTING LAW THAT
ALLOWS FAMILIES TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF THEIR MURDERED LOVED
ONES AND IS BALANCED AND THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF RECORDS
WILL REMAIN PRIVATE PUBLIC.
AFTER THE EVENTS OF THE
BORDERLINE MASS SHOOTING THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION
THE PUBLISHED REPORTS BY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND THE
SHERIFF AND MULTIPLE NEWSPAPER
STORIES THESE FAMILIES CONTINUE
TO BE TORMENTED BY CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS REQUESTING AUTOPSY
RECORDS. THEY ARE INTENT ON
DISTORTING THE MEMORY OF THESE
VICTIMS THROUGH HURTFUL AND
OUTRAGEOUS CLAIMS ON MESSAGE
BOARDS CLAIM THAT THE VICTIMS
OF MASS SHOOTINGS ARE CRISIS
pLIVING OVERSEAS AB TWO SIX
EIGHT AMENDS AN EXISTING LAW
THAT ALREADY ALLOWS FAMILIES OF
MURDERED CHILDREN TO PETITION A
COURT TO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN'S
AUTOPSY SEALED. I WANT TO
APPLIES TO A DEATH THAT IS THE
RESULT OF A CRIMINAL ACT AND
NOT OF NATURAL CAUSES AN
ACCIDENT OR ONE THAT IS SELF
INFLICTED. EIGHTY TWO SIX EIGHT
SIMPLY EXTENDS THE AUCTION
ALREADY OFFERED TO FAMILIES OF
THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE CHILD
VICTIMS WHO DIED FROM A
CRIMINAL ACT TO VICTIMS OF ALL
AGES IT IS A CRUCIAL SAFEGUARD
FROM AGAIN FROM- THE L. A.
RETAINS A CRUCIAL SAFEGUARD
FROM THE EXISTING LAW THAT IS
SEALED CANNOT BE REQUESTED
UNTIL AFTER A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION IS SECURED HOWEVER
IT ADDS THE IMPORTANT
ALTERNATIVE THAT A SEAL CAN BE
SOUGHT AFTER A CASES CLOSED BY
PROSECUTORS DUE TO ALL SUSPECTS
BEING DECEASED. AFTER ALL NO
CONVICTION WILL EVER BE SECURED
AGAINST A MASS SHOOTER WHO
TAKES HIS OWN LIFE AS WAS THE
CASE OF BORDERLINE TWENTY OTHER
STATES PROVIDE FAMILY SOME
DEGREE OF PRIVACY BY KEEPING
ALL AUTOPSY RECORDS.
CONFIDENTIAL OR SEVERELY A
LIMITED. REGARD OF- THE VIEW OF
THE STATUS. I'M HONORED TO BE A
JOIN TODAY AND SUPPORT BY PHONE-
WITH THE ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
REPRESENTING VENTURA COUNTY.
AND MARCO FARFAN IS THE FATHER
OF TELEMARKETER FULLNESS WHO
WAS KILLED IN THE BORDERLINE
MASS SHOOTING IN THOUSAND OAKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS IS
BEEN KNOWS ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
IN HERE YES HANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND YET VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED MEASURE.
CAPITALIST LEGISLATIVE BASED ON
THE EXPERIENCES OF THE COUNTY
WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENT RIGHT TO
PROTECTION. IT OTHER STATE ACT
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
FOR HERE SHE YOUR PROUDEST OF
THE BOY FAMILIES AND IN HONOR
THOSE WHO BY LAW IN SIX BOX.
BOB I WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
COMMENTS. IT SAYS- LOOKS WE
LOST THERE ARE LITTLE BIT TELL
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU YOUR
TEST AND BUT I'VE THIS ONE IS
SO MARC ALL FINALS SO. FAMILIES
THE BORDER. MASS SHOOTING
VICTIMS- ARE YOU ARE YOU
AVAILABLE MR OR FINALS. FINALS
SAM HI PLEASE GO AHEAD CAN HEAR
YOU FINE YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MANY MY NAME'S
MARK OR FILES FROM THOUSAND
OAKS AND I'M SPEAKING. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIXTY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN HAS
CLEARLY THAT THE SPECIFICS OF
THIS BILL BUT I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE PURPOSE IS TO
AFFORD SOME PRIVACY TO VICTIMS
OF VIOLENT CRIMES MY SON
TELEMACHUS OR FARMS. ALONG WITH
ELEVEN OTHERS WAS KILLED IN A
MASS SHOOTING AT YOU KNOW ON
NOVEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND BECAUSE THE VERY
PUBLIC NATURE OF HIS DEATH HE
AND WE HIS FAMILY HAVE OFTEN
BEEN SUBJECTED TO VERY
INTRUSIVE SCRUTINY FROM PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
AND THIS IS A VITAL REASON TO
PROTECT CERTAIN AUTOPSY RECORDS
ONCE INFORMATION BECOMES PUBLIC
ANYONE INCLUDING TROLLS CAN GET
TO IT AND USE IT. NOW THE DAY
BEFORE YESTERDAY. WAS MY SON'S.
THIRTIETH BIRTHDAY BUT WE ARE
WHO WE COULDN'T CELEBRATE IT
WITH THEM WE INSTEAD MARKED THE
OCCASION. AND SUFFER THROUGH IS
ABSENT AS WE HAVE DONE FOR THE
LAST EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
DAYS. THE LAST TIME WE SAW OUR
SON. HIS BODY. LAY UNDER A
QUILT AT A FUNERAL HOME. AND
THE TRAUMA OF THAT IMAGE IN MY
MIND IS CRUSHING AND IT DOESN'T
GO AWAY SO. IMAGINE THE IMPACT
OF HAVING DETAIL AUTOPSY
RECORDS CONSTANTLY FLOATING
ABOUT IN PUBLIC. AS OUR PRIVACY
IS VIOLATED AND WHAT IS LEFT OF
OUR SENSE DIGNITY IS STRIPPED
AWAY. JUST IMAGINE THE IMPACT
SO PLEASE ALLOW US AND ALL
OTHER. ALL THESE WORKERS SOME
SEMBLANCE OF PRIVACY. AND PEACE
AND PLEASE IN DOORS AB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR FOR YOUR TESTIMONIES- I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT THE REMOTE LOCATION
WHO WISH TO SPEAK SO LET'S OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES- OPERATOR.
OF THE FOR THOSE WHO LIKE TO
CALL IN- TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
THIS IS A B. TWO SIX EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TO FIX
STATE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. COMMANDER CAN ONE THEN.
ZERO I'M NOT LINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
CORONERS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT AT OF
EIGHTY TWO SIX EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
I ONE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS REBEKAH MARKETS
ON BEHALF OF BRADY CAMPAIGN AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME. A VERY GOOD- AT THIS
POINT IT'S GOOD OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE THE FIRST WITNESSES
BRITNEY PARCEL TOLD.
ASSOCIATION. MISS UP BY SAUDI
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FOR
IMPARTIALITY AND I'M GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. AND WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OF CODE
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN I WENT- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME- YOU KNOW OUR
CONCERNS ARE OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER OF OPPOSITION BUT
ULTIMATELY- WE FEEL THEIR
EXISTING SAFEGUARDS- IN PLACE
TO ADDRESS PRIVACY RIGHT POINT
COME TO- REDACTIONS AND ALSO.
THEN I'LL DEMOCRATS FOR RECORDS
OF THE STATE- AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE NOW
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO YOU-
SPEAKING AT THE CENTER COUNTY
STARK. AND I WILL STAY ON THE
LINE IF YOU HAVE ANY TECHNICAL.
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER C. CAROLINE KALLANG.
WITH THE VENTURA COUNTY STAR
YEAH. PLEASE GO YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STACY
GOING ON THE NEW DIRECTOR OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY STAR. I CAN
APPRECIATE WHAT THE AUTHOR AND
THE FAMILIES HAVE TO SAY ON
THIS ISSUE I KNOW THIS ONE IS
PERSONAL- NOT GOING TO TRY TO
CONVINCE YOU OF ANYTHING TO TRY
TO BETTER EXPLAIN WHERE WE'RE
COMING. FROM AS JOURNALISTS TO
SPEAK THE TRUTH. AND THAT'S
OFTEN. RARELY PRETTY. WE HAVE
READ THE AFTER ACTION REPORT
INVENTOR COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE. BEING INVESTIGATED
REPORTS OF INTER COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE
AUTOPSY REPORTS. FOR SERGEANT
RON HE WITH THE SHOOTER. WE
STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED ON
NOVEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THE DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RELEASED SO FAR WHICH
URETER PRODUCED BY THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. OR MORE BASED
ON THE MATERIALS- THIS IS A
PERSONAL THE SEEKING A PUBLIC
RECORDS. IT'S. PROFESSIONAL
IT'S OUR JOB. ONE OF OUR
MANDATE THIS REPORT AND EDITORS
OF TO HOLD. ACCOUNTABLE AND
IT'S NOT JUST IN THIS INSTANCE
WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR POLICE
MISCONDUCT RECORDS FROM THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. AND EVERY OTHER AGENCY
LAKE COUNTY HAS HANDED OVER AT
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE- I CAN'T
LOOK INTO THE HEARTS OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE AND- IF THEY'RE TRYING
TO KEEP IT FROM US BECAUSE OF
SOME SUPPOSED. TO INCLUDE.
ASSEMBLY LINE OR NOT BUT I HOPE
WE CAN AGREE THAT WE AS A
SOCIETY ARE BETTER WITH GREATER
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY. NOT
LESS. THE OF THE TERM CRIMINAL
IN THE BILL. IN MY MIND IS TOO
BROAD. TOO MANY PEOPLE DIE AS A
RESULT OF CRIMES TO HEAD-
AUTOPSY REPORTS HELP US DO OUR
JOB. THEY SHOW A DIFFERENT VIEW
OF THE EVENTS. THAT WE GET THE
DOCUMENTS AND THERE'S NOTHING
THERE DO NOT WHAT WE WILL TELL
YOU TELL THE TRUTH. I HOPE
THAT'S WHAT WE LEARNED. BUT
WHAT IF WE LEARN MORE. WHAT IF
WE WANT SOMETHING TO HELP OTHER
AGENCIES PREVENT MORE MASS
SHOOTINGS AND EVENTS- AND
BETTER UNDERSTAND TO RESPOND TO
SOMETHING AS PREVIOUSLY
UNSTOPPABLE LIKE THIS. I'M
TROUBLED BY THE TIME IT TOOK
FOR THE SECOND ENTRY INTO THE
BORDERLINE. I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYTHING WOULD BE CHANGED IF WE
HAD THOSE RECORDS. BUT I CAN'T
BE SURE WITHOUT THEM. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SCENE NO ONE IN THE ROOM- TO
TESTIFY LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO LIKE TO
CALL IN TO OPPOSED. TO AB TWO
SIX EIGHT. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO SIX STATE
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN
ZERO. IN LINE ONE HUNDRED YEAR
MIKE IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING MEMBERS TICKETS CAME
WHEN DEAN WITH THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION- WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWO
SIX EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MR
GABRIEL AT. YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
FIGURE SOMETHING WOMAN FOR THIS
BILL- AND INTEREST FOR THE
EXTERNALLY COMPASSIONATE AND
THOUGHTFUL WAY THAT YOU HAVE.
SUPPORTED THE BORDERLINE
FAMILIES THIS IS YOU KNOW I
SPENT SOME TIME THERE IS A- AS
A KID AND THIS IS ONE THAT HIT
HOME FOR ME AS WELL AND- JUST
MY- EXTERNALLY CONDOLENCES TO
THE FAMILY AND THE WITNESS I'M-
NOT PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY- WE DID
WE DID HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS LAST NIGHT I JUST
WANTED TO. RAISE THE POINT ON
THE RECORD. I THINK IN MOST
INSTANCES YOUR BILL MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE AND IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO- BUT WE ARE
BALANCING A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
INTERESTS HERE THERE'S A VERY
STRONG EVERYTHING MOST CASES
OVERRIDING INTEREST IN PRIVACY
FOR THE FAMILY. BUT THERE MAY
BE AN ONE OUT OF A THOUSAND OR
ONE OUT OF TEN THOUSAND CASES-
REALLY STRONG INTEREST IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION RIGHT FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST FOR FIRMWARE
ANDERSON SO I WOULD JUST OFFER
TO YOU- IF YOU WANT TO THINK
ABOUT AND ENTERTAIN THE
POSSIBILITY. OF MAYBE TRYING TO
CARVE OUT AN EXCEPTION WHERE.
AFTER AFTER THIS HAPPENS IF
SOMEONE COULD GO TO COURT A
PETITION THE JUDGE YOU COULD
SET A VERY VERY HIGH THRESHOLD
IN THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE
INSIDE. IF THERE'S OVERRIDING
PUBLIC INTEREST AND PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE OF THIS INFORMATION
JUST TO CREATE A LITTLE BIT OF
A RELEASE VALVE FOR THAT ONE IN
TEN THOUSAND SITUATION WHERE.
IT REALLY DOES MAKE SENSE FOR
THE PUBLIC TO KNOW SO I WILL
LEAVE THAT TO YOUR DISCRETION
AND JUDGMENT I HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN YOU AS AN AUTHOR-
AND BUT JUST WANTED TO RAISE
THAT ON THE RECORD AND- WE'LL
BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT ABOUT THE
FACT. RIGHT THANK YOU. AS
MEMBER- GABER. AND I WAS
LOOKING AT AFTER YOU RAISE
ISSUE WE- WE CERTAINLY ARE OPEN
TO. ANY LANGUAGE THAT IN THAT.
AGAIN THIS IS VERY NARROWLY
CRAFTED SO IN THAT INSTANCE
WHERE THERE MIGHT BE. A PUBLIC
NEED TO KNOW- BUT I JUST WANT
TO GO THROUGH WHAT THE BILL
SAYS RIGHT NOW THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE IS ALWAYS AVAILABLE
THAT'S THE NAME AGE CAUSE AND
MANNER OF DEATH. AND THERE ARE
NUMBER OF ENTITIES ALSO THAT'S
A MIGHT HAVE A NEED TO KNOW.
THAT ARE ALLOWED TO VIEW THE
AUTOPSY RESULTS ARE READY SO
THAT'S- LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROSECUTORS SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES. HOSPITALS THAT
TREATED THE VICTIMS DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS. CIVIL ATTORNEYS AND
INSURANCE COMPANIES. AND
LASTLY. ANY FAMILY MEMBER. CAN
ACTUALLY I REQUEST TO HAVE THE
RECORD UNSEALED SO. ONE FAMILY
MEMBER CAN REQUEST HAVE IT
SEALED IF ANOTHER ONE REQUEST
TO HAVE IT UNSEALED. THEN YOU
DO GO TO COURT FOR THAT SO- WE
WILL TO CONTINUE TO LOOK IF
THERE'S- IF THERE'S- SOME WAY
TO. TO HAVE THAT ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARD AND THAT VERY RARE
INSTANCE. BUT AGAIN THIS WAS
EXTREMELY NARROWLY- TAILORED.
TO ACTIVE SITUATED IT'S NOT WE
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
OFTEN VIEWS. MUCH BEYOND
SITUATIONS LIKE A BORDERLINE.
YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT AND MY
COMPLIMENTS YOU HAVE CRAFTED
THIS VERY NARROWLY AS IT. AS IT
EXISTS SO I APPRECIATE HAT
AND- AGAIN THIS IS REALLY
JUSTICE AS WE DISCUSSED LAST
NIGHT THAT ONE IN TEN THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CASE FOR
THE JUSTICE SOME VERY. OVERRIDE
STRONG OVERRIDING PUBLIC
INTEREST THAT THE JUDGE WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO. TO
ENGAGE IN ABOUT THE PAST AND
FIGURE OUT WHICH IS WHICH IS
THE PRIVATE INTERESTS OF. SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. YEAH C. NO
OTHER CA. THE SUPPORT. MISTER
MISTER. AND IF ALL MR BEEN.
YEAH COUNTY GANG UP ON THE SOME
MEMBER. COME I DO THINK THAT
MIGHT BE A WORTHY. ADDITION I
MEAN I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
THOUGH UNDER THE BILL AS
DRAFTED NOW- THE RECORDS CAN
STILL BE USED IN A CRIMINAL
CASE BY PROSECUTION AND
DEFENCE. IN A CIVIL THE CIVIL
LITIGANTS CAN STILL GET ACCESS
RIGHT. AND SO I MEAN IT ANYBODY
THAT. NEEDS TO USE IT FOR
PURPOSES OF COURT IS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET THESE RECORDS-
FAMILY MEMBER HAS TO REQUEST IT
RIGHT. SO I MEAN UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE- THIS THE
CEILING ISN'T REQUESTED IT
DOESN'T APPLY IS THAT CORRECT.
OKAY YEAH I MEAN I CAN'T I'M
TRYING TO. THINK HYPOTHETICALLY
OF THAT ONE IN TEN THOUSAND
SITUATION IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
EVEN. THINK OF THE HYPOTHETICAL
BUT I THINK IT MIGHT EXISTS OUT
THERE SOMEWHERE. WHERE IT WHERE
SOMEBODY FROM THE MEDIA FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD WANT- YOU KNOW
SOME NEW EVIDENCE COMES OUT
ABOUT THE OJ CASE OR SOMETHING
I DON'T KNOW. AND SOMEBODY FROM
THE MEDIA WOULD WANT. TO
PETITION A COURT FOR ACCESS IF
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT DOING
THAT I WOULD AGREE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FROM SAN
GABRIEL OR WHATEVER FROM- THAT
THAT- IS GABRIEL AND I THINK. I
MIGHT. OTHERS SAY ALLAH.
THOUSAND OAKS THING- THAT'S YOU
THE I AGREE THAT I THINK THE
THRESHOLD SHOULD BE REALLY
REALLY HIDE IT SHOULD- AND IT
SHOULD REQUIRE A JUDICIAL
BALANCING TEST AND GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- THE
PETITIONER THAT THE VICTIM
FAMILY MEMBER THE PETITION TO
HAVE IT SEALED TO ALSO HAVE A
CHANCE TO COME IN AND EXPLAIN
TO A JUDGE WHY IT SHOULD BE
RELEASED. SO JUST SOME THOUGHTS
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
BILL BUT AND WE'RE CERTAINLY TO
IT YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE BOTH
ATTORNEYS WE HAVE ASKED THE
OPPONENTS FOR LANGUAGE THAT
THAT MIGHT BE- THAT WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO USE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK FOR LANGUAGE LIKE THAT
YEAH I THINK THEY SHOULD WORK
WITH YOU AND OFFER THEM. THANK
YOU. MISTER SEVEN MEMBER COME.
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM.
CHAIRMAN I WAS A VENTURA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR ONE BORDERLINE THE
ATTACK TOOK PLACE I WAS ONE OF
THE SUPERVISORS IN THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE TO ASK- MISTER
WOULD CARRY THIS BILL WHILE I
WAS ON THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS- AND AT THAT AS
SHE STARTED CARRIED ABILITY AS
WE WERE MAKING THE REQUEST WE
CERTAINLY HEARD- FROM THE
NEWSPAPERS ASSOCIATIONS AND
OTHERS THAT- IT'S- AN
OPPOSITION TO THE TO THE
REQUEST. AND I THINK IN A GOOD
GOVERNMENT IS IT IS ALWAYS THE
HARDEST WHEN YOU HAVE GOOD READ
PRINCIPLES ON BOTH SIDES OF
PRIVACY OF THESE FAMILIES WE
WERE ALL TRYING TO SAY THESE
FAMILIES NEED SOME PRIVACY IN
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION. AT
THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW THE
NEWSPAPERS ARE SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT IF IT'S A FOSTER CHILDREN
AND THERE'S A YEAH THE
GOVERNMENT IS COVERING UP- YOU
KNOW SOME SOME BEST A AND SO I
JUST REALLY WANT TO COMPLIMENT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THOUSAND
OAKS- FOR NARROWLY I FEEL
REALLY NARROWLY CRAFTING
MISSING TO PROTECT THOSE
FAMILIES. IS IN FOR IT THE
BORDERLINE FAMILIES IN
PARTICULAR BUT OTHER FAMILIES
AND IN A SIMILAR SITUATION IN A
WAY THAT AT LEAST THE
PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
AS SHE'S BENDING OVER BACKWARDS
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ABUSED- SO HAVE A
FAMILY ONCE THE AUTOPSY
INFORMATION OUT THEY CAN'T SO
IF YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
THEY SUSPECTED THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS DONE SOMETHING
WRONG. THERE'S BEEN A SHOOTING-
OF ONE OF THEIR VICTIMS BY- THE
POLICE OR SOMEBODY ELSE- SO
JUST THERE'S A THERE'S A GREAT
EMPHASIS ON THE FAMILY IS
PROTECTED IN TERMS OF GETTING
THE INFORMATION OUT IN THE
PLANT FAMILY ONLY NARROWLY CAN
CAN PROTECT THIS INFORMATION IN
IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS AND SO MY
COMPLIMENTS- AND- THERE IS THE
YOU KNOW THE DEMAND FOR THE
PERFECT WILL ALWAYS BE THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD AND- AND NOT
THAT I THINK THAT THERE'S
ANYTHING. WRONG WITH THE
SUGGESTION YOU HAVE HERE BUT I
THANK YOU IS IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL
CHECK- EFFORT ON YOUR- TO. THIS
DOWN SO I CERTAINLY BE
STRONGLY. SUPPORTING THE EFFORT
TO MIKE BUT MOSTLY MY PERSONAL
I MEAN MY PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL COMPLIMENTS TO YOU
FOR. COMING UP WITH A NOT JUST
GIVING UP LAST YEAR WHEN YOU
COULD GET IT. WITH THE BROADER
VERSION OF IT BUT COMING UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT GIVES HOPE
STILL FOR THOSE FAMILIES- THE
ABUSE THAT. HAS TAKEN PLACE HAS
TO BE BALANCED AND THEY'VE
THEY'RE SUBSUMED TERRIFIC
ABUSES OF THIS AUTOPSY.
INFORMATION HAS TO BE BALANCED
WITH- WITH THE- WITH WITH THE
PUBLIC- DESIRE FOR THE
INFORMATION OR THE PUBLIC YOU
NEED TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION
OUT THERE AND I THINK YOU
SHOULD BE STRUCK OF A VERY GOOD
BALLOTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF
MY CHAIR KILEY. THANK YOU AND-
I REALLY- ECHO WHAT OTHERS HAVE
SAID IN TERMS OF. APPOINTING
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN FOR
WORKING WITH THESE FAMILIES WHO
HAVE HAD TO GO THROUGH SO MUCH
AND I'VE HAD TO. YOU KNOW GO
THROUGH THIS ABUSE OF. OF THE
RECORDS IN THE PROCESS IT'S
REALLY- JUST AWFUL AND- I THINK
IT'S A DIFFICULT ISSUE I THINK
I WOULD HAVE TO COME DOWN. A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY THOUGH THAN
SOME OF THE OTHER MEMBERS-
YOU'RE LISTENING TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
GROUPS IN THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION- I THINK THERE WERE
VERY COMPELLING AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S YOU KNOW JUST SORT
OF A ONE OF THOUSAND CASE WHERE
THERE'S A MATTER OF WHERE THESE
ARE A MATTER OF PUBLIC INTEREST
I THINK THAT. ANYTIME YOU HAVE
A HOMICIDE THE MATTER OF
TREMENDOUS PUBLIC INTEREST AND-
I DON'T THINK THAT THE DEFAULT
SHOULD BE- YOU KNOW ONE OF
LIMITING ACCESS ON THE PART OF
THE PRESS OR ANY OTHER GROUP-
THAT SEEKS TO. YOU KNOW- SHINE
A LIGHT ON. VARIOUS ASPECTS OF
THE EVENT THAT MADE- YOU KNOW
HAVE A RAMIFICATIONS FOR POLICY
OR FOR- YOU KNOW- PROSECUTION
OR FOR STEPS GOING FORWARD SO.
I MEAN I'M- I JUST DON'T THINK
I CAN SUPPORT THE BILL IN THE
CURRENT FORM ONE SORT OF- YOU
KNOW EVEN. ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT FOLKS ARE SUGGESTING OR
MAYBE YOU CAN GO AND TRY TO-
YOU KNOW MAKE A SHOWING THE YOU
NEED TO GET ACCESS WHAT ABOUT
SORT OF DOING IT THE OTHER WAY
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THE A
CASES WHERE YOU HAVE SORT OF.
ROLES ARE YOU HAVE THIS PROCESS
BEING ABUSES PROBABLY. THE RARE
SCENARIO MAYBE I'M WRONG ABOUT
THAT BUT COULD YOU SORT OF. LET
THE DEFAULT SO THAT YOU COULD
MAKE USE OF THAT YOU KNOW THE
REDACTION- PROCEDURES THAT ARE
ALREADY ARE THERE ANY EXISTING
LAW AND MAYBE IF YOU HAVE A- A
RARE CASE WE'RE NOT THE LAST
PRIVACY INTERESTS ARE STILL-
BEING VIOLATED A FURTHER STEP
TO BE TAKEN. WELL THERE IS YEAH
THERE THERE IS OBVIOUSLY A- AN
OPTION FOR REDACTION AND THE
FAMILIES HAD NO- THEY HAD NO
CONFIDENCE THAT THAT WOULD. BE
USED TO PROTECT THAT AUTO C.
RECORD. THAT THE- THAT THAT
THAT THE ALL TALKED TALK RECORD
AS A WHOLE NEW. TO BE. TO
REALLY PROTECT THEIR THEIR
INFORMATION. THEY LOOKED AT-
THEY LOOK AT THE REACTION. AND
IT HAD TO GO THROUGH THE COURT
SYSTEM IT'S NOT THAT WELL
DEFINED WHEN YOU CAN USE IT
AND- AND AGAIN. REALLY FOR
PRIVACY YOU NEED TO- IF YOU
NEED TO REALLY. I'M STILL THE
ENTIRE RECORD AND AGAIN THIS
THERE ARE ONLY CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THIS. THE PERSON THE
MURDERER WOULD HAVE TO BE- I'M
KILLED HIMSELF. AND IF YOU LOOK
AT BORDERLINE IN VENTURA COUNTY
WE HAVE HAD LITERALLY HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF
REPORTS IN THIS. COMMITTEE WE
TALK ABOUT FOR INSTANCE THE
HIPPA. MEDICAL INFORMATION IT
WHICH IS THE MOST PRIVATE TYPE
OF INFORMATION AND NOW YOU HAVE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO IF THEY
WERE A COUPLE OF YEARS YOUNGER.
THIS WOULDN'T EVEN BE AN ISSUE
BECAUSE THE LAW IS ALREADY
THERE BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE
TWENTY AND NOT EIGHTEEN. THEIR
HIP A RIGHTS AS SOON AS THEY
WERE MURDERED. ARE VIOLATED AND
THAT IS ARE THEY TAKING SOME
SORT OF. DRUGS ARE THEY I MEAN.
WHY SHOULD ALL YOUR PERSONAL
INFORMATION WHEN SO MUCH OTHER
INFORMATION HAS ALREADY BEEN
DISCLOSED THE LAST LITTLE BIT
OF DIGNITY THAT YOUR FAMILY HAS
BE DISCLOSED. WHAT IS THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT WHEN THERE'S A
LIST OF TEN DIFFERENT AGENCIES
I CAN ALREADY GET THE
INFORMATION. WHAT IS THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT WHAT WE SAW IN VENTURA
COUNTY THERE WAS NO PUBLIC
BENEFIT IT IS THE TROLLS I'VE
HAD LETTERS OF MY HOUSE. PEOPLE
IN THAT YOU KNOW THREATENING
THE VICTIM'S FAMILY IT JUST AT
A CERTAIN POINT WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THERE WERE VICTIMS AND
ALL THIS. SURE MISTER MIRACLE
AND- HELLO THIS IS A MEMBER OF
AUDIENCES THIS THIS IS RELATED
TO. YOU CAN GET AFTER A GOOD
ARGUMENT IS THAT YOU KNOW YOU
SAID YEAH HOMICIDES REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THEY ARE. THAT'S
WHY MESSAGE IN ERROR THAT'S
RIGHT JUST LIKE TO ASK YOU ALL.
TO MORE TIME. BOTH THERE WE GO
HI ALL THOSE ELEGANT WAY YES WE
PURSUE LOS IN THE DOES AIR YEAH.
BUT- I JUST LIKE THE ALL TO
REPEAT- ALL OF THIS THAT ARE
REAL THAT ALREADY RESTRICTED IN
OTHER WORDS THE THIS IS ONLY
RESTRICTED IN COULD YOU PLEASE
REPEAT THE BASED ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW THE PERSON
HAS TO BE DEAD YOU KNOW THE
THAT THE SHOOTER HAS TO BE
DEALT COULD COULD YOU DO THAT
OKAY. EVERYTHING THAT THE
SHOOTER HAS TO BE DEAD AND ALL
THE OTHER INFORMATION IS
RELEASED AND THAT THAT AND
THERE ARE VICTIMS AND THERE ARE
VICTIMS THAT ARE OVER EIGHTEEN
SO WE'RE JUST EXTENDING THE
SAME PROTECTION THAT WE DO FOR
UNDER EIGHTEEN- GIRLS AND AGAIN
THERE'S A WHOLE LIST OF-
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT COULD.
FOUR FOUR IF THEY HAVE A REASON
TO KNOW ARE ABLE TO SEE THOSE
AUTOPSY REPORTS AND AGAIN IN
TWENTY DIFFERENT STATES THEY
COMPLETELY HIDE THIS WITHOUT IT
BEING A MURDER VICTIM BECAUSE
THESE RECORDS ARE SO INCREDIBLY
PERSONAL. SO I'M SORRY I GET A
LITTLE WOUND UP IN FOR. FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND FOR
ME WE LIVED THROUGH THIS WE
HAVE BEEN WITH THE FAMILIES FOR
THE YOU KNOW THE LAST FEW YEARS
THAT ALL THE MEMORIAL SERVICES.
AND THIS IS KIND OF THE FINAL
INDIGNITY THAT THEY HAVE TO.
THAT THAT THAT THE PERSONAL
DETAILS OF THE BODIES OF THEIR
CHILDREN- ARE TO BE REVEALED.
SO BUT I CERTAINLY I BY
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ALL IT'S A
BALANCING ACT I KNOW APPRECIATE
THE OTHER SIDE'S ARGUMENT CALL
I JUST I JUST WANTED TO WANTED
TO GO ON RECORD IT IF IT. IF
YOU HAVE. A CAREFUL READING OF
THE BILL WILL SHOW. THAT IN THE
VAST VAST MAJORITY THIS BILL
WILL JUST DOES THIS BILL WILL
NOT OF NOT APPLY. SO OFTEN IT'S
NOT MURDERS ARE IMPORTANT. AND
NEARLY ALL THE MURDERS WILL
STILL HAVE THE RELEASE OF THIS
INFORMATION EXCEPT WHEN THE
SHOOTER HAS. ALREADY ALREADY
KILLED THEMSELVES FOR EXAMPLE
AND IT IN THAT SITUATION AND
THE FAMILY REQUEST YOU KNOW
ONCE THE PRIVACY TO CONTINUE-
SO. WHAT I THINK WE JUST NEED
TO AIR THAT WE FINALLY REACHED
A REASONABLY- YOU KNOW GOOD-
ADJUSTMENT TO IT BALLOTS HERE
WITH S. AND AGAIN MY
COMPLIMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND I WAS TOLD ME SAY
THAT- MY HEART GOES OUT TO THE
FAMILIES. WHO HAVE LOST LOVED
THEIR LOVED ONES IT IS A TOUGH
IT'S A TOUGH CALL FOR ME ALSO I
THINK IT'S BEEN MENTIONED BY
SEVERAL COLLEAGUES OF OURS AND
IS THE BALANCING ACT A HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE START THAT RIGHT
BALANCE AND YOU KNOW BETWEEN
TRANSPARENCY IT BETWEEN
TRANSPARENCY AND M. AND PRIVACY
AND WE TALK ANYTHING ANYTIME
TALK ABOUT THAT YOU KNOW PR A
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT AND
THINK. YEAH YOU YOU KNOW YOU
TALK ABOUT THE BALANCING ACTS
OF SO- SO FOR NOW I THINK I'M
GONNA STICK TO STAY OFF AND- AS
YOU KNOW GO FORWARD I'LL SEE IF
I CAN CAN SUPPORTED- SO SELL
WITHOUT THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. NO I WILL- TAKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENEFITS THE STATEMENT
SAYS MY CLOTHES AND- WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I THINK
WE STILL NEED- MOTION. HELPED
SECTOR IT WAS- YEAH I KNOW WE
ARE INCLUDED SECOND. I THE MOVE
TO GET MR SACK MY SIDE- THIS IS
A B. TWO SIX EIGHT THE MOTION
AS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAPTER. CHAU NOT VOTING KILEY
KILEY NOPE OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
YES SENATE I'D SORIA.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GABRIEL APRIL I GALLAGHER. ONE
FIVE- WHEN I LEVY. WICKS WICKS
HI FIVE VOTES WE WANT SHORT
TERM WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANKS MUCH THAT BRINGS US TO
THE NEXT BILLS AND THAT WOULD
BE. THE TANGO DON'T KNOW IF MR-
OKAY AND IS. SHE'S DOING AT THE
TANGO CORRECT- YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW- SHE'S PRESENTING. ALL I
COULD DO MIND IF I THINK. ALL
AROUND WE COULD DO THAT TOO
EITHER EITHER WAY I MEAN I'M
GOING. OKAY WHAT WHAT ONE WE
WANT TO DO IT OKAY WE DO ALL
THAT WE DO MY BUILD. YEAH. YEAH
YEAH I KNOW THAT AND THEN
THINGS FELL. THIS IS- AB TWELVE
FIFTY TWO CORRECT MISTER CHOW
THANK YOU YES CORRECT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY-MUCH I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT FREE
BUT THIS IS. A LOT OF AB FOR
TWELVE FIFTY TWO WOULD BRING
HEALTH INFORMATION COLLECTED BY
DIGITAL HEALTH PRODUCTS TO BE
UNDER THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL PRIVACY
LAW. OUR DIGITAL HEALTH
PRODUCTS ARE GETTING HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS NEW WAYS TO GET
USEFUL AND ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT. THEIR PATIENTS FOR
EXAMPLE A DIGITAL AND MOBILE
CONNECTED INHALER CAN DETECT
WHEN THE DEVICE IS USED.
MEASURE THE STRENGTH. OF THE
USERS INHALATION AND ALSO
TRANSMIT THIS INFORMATION TO
THE USERS DR. ALSO SEVERAL
FORMS OF DIGITAL PILLS ARE
ALREADY IN USE. THESE PILLS
COMBINED INGESTIBLE MICROCHIPS
SENSORS WITH PHARMACEUTICALS.
AND COMMUNICATE WITH THE PATCH
THAT COLLECTS INFORMATION AND
SENDS IT OVER TO A MOBILE
APPLICATION. HOW THESE PRODUCTS
CAN RECORD THE TIME AND
QUANTITY A DRUG IS TAKEN ONCE
TEMPERATURE ACTIVITY LEVEL AND
HEART RATE. ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION CAN BE HIGHLY
SENSITIVE AND WOOD UNDER OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES BE PROTECTED
UNDER THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
MEDICAL AND INFORMATION ACT.
AND THAT'S CALL C. M. I. A. AND
ALSO HIT BUT WHICH HAS BEEN
ALSO MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY. NOW
IN ORDER FOR THIS KIND OF DATA
TO BE CONSIDERED MEDICAL
INFORMATION IT NORMALLY NEEDS
TO BE GENERATED BY A HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER. PROVIDER HOWEVER
INFORMATION GENERATED OR
COLLECTED BY A DIGITAL HEALTH
APPS MEETING AT THE PATIENT
LEVEL AND ALSO OUTSIDE OF A
MEDICAL FACILITY WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE CAPTURE. UNDER
THE EXISTING DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION THIS BILL
TWELVE FIFTY TWO WILL BRING
THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND THE
INFORMATION THEY COLLECT UNDER
THE CMI EIGHT BY CONSIDERING
ANY BUSINESS THAT OFFERS SUCH
AN APPLICATION OR DEVICE TO
CONSUMER. TO BE A PROVIDER OF
HEALTH CARE WITH RESPECT TO THE
APPLE OF THE DEVICE. NOW THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT SENSITIVE
HEALTH DATA IS TREATED WITH THE
SAME CARE AND AS DATA THAT IS
GENERATED IN A TRADITIONAL
MEDICAL SETTING. AND PROHIBIT
THAT INFORMATION FROM BEING
SHARED WITHOUT THE PATIENT'S
WRITTEN CONSENT- I HEALTH-
MAUREEN MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS AND ALSO
REBEKAH GONZALEZ- ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. I FIRST WITNESS IN
SOME A PERSON. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS MAUREEN
MAHONEY ADMITTING YOUR POLICY
ANALYST THE CONSUMER REPORTS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO BECAUSE IT
WOULD EXTEND. EXISTING STRONG
HEALTH PRIVACY LAW THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT THE SENSE OF
HEALTH INFORMATION GENERATED BY
NEW FORMS OF HEALTH TECHNOLOGY
SOME PROTECTIONS OVER THE STATE
IS ESSENTIAL NOT ONLY GOOD
SENSE OF DATA FROM MENTAL
HEALTH APPS FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
BE USED TO TARGET ADS TO BE
DOWN THE ROAD COULD BE OBTAINED
BY OTHER THIRD PARTIES. I NEED
TO MAKE IMPORTANT DECISIONS
ABOUT YOU CONSUMERS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT FOR HELP
WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT HOW THAT
DATA MIGHT BE SHARED MISUSED
CALIFORNIA PATIENT PRIVACY IS
PROTECTED BY THE CIA AND HIPAA
HOWEVER THESE TWO LAWS ONLY
PROTECT SENSITIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION IS GENERATED BY
CERTAIN ENTITIES NOT THE
INFORMATION CREATED BY MANY NEW
HEALTH TECHNOLOGIES. THE CCPA
WOULD APPLY TO THE STATE OF THE
LAW IS NOT A STRONG FOR EXAMPLE
THE FIFTY P. ALLOWS CONSUMERS
TO STOP STILL THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION IF YOU MAY HAVE- BY
THE FALL PROHIBIT MOST CASES O
SHARING AT ALL. AB TWELVE FIFTY
TWO WOULD ADDRESS SERVICE GAPS
IN PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OVER
CONSUMER SENSE OF HEALTH DATA
AND WE URGE. YOU TO ADVANCE THE
BILL THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU
THE SECOND ONE DOESN'T
APARTMENT FOR. HELLO MY NAME IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ AND I
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA DEGREES FROM
ACCREDITED SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO ONE
WANT TO THANK THE OFFICE FOR
INTRODUCING A SPELL WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT PERSONAL HEALTH
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY
SPECIFIED DIGITAL PROJECT IS
SUBJECT TO THE CONFIDENTIALITY
OF MEDICAL INFORMATION ACT.
PERRANCE BEAR BY ENSURING
PATIENT PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
WHILE STILL ALLOWING FOR THE
SHARING OF HEALTH INFORMATION
FOR THE DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
OF PATIENTS. MANY OF OUR
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
ST SENSITIVE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY IS ESSENTIAL
FOR OPEN AND HONEST
COMMUNICATION AND CLIENTS MIGHT
BE CONFIDENT THAT THEIR
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED.
PROTECTING PERSONAL HEALTH
INFORMATION IS NECESSARY AS
THIS INFORMATION IS UNIQUE AND
PRIVATE EACH INDIVIDUAL ALL
THIS INFORMATION INCLUDES
INTIMATE DETAILS OF SOCIAL
BEHAVIOR PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS
AND FINANCIAL INFORMATION THAT
WE MAY NOT I NOT WANT TO SHARE
WITH OTHERS. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION
IS PRIVATE IN ORDER TO PREVENT
POTENTIAL HARM EMBARRASSMENT
AND DISCRIMINATION FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE OUR AYE. VOTE
AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR PLEASE A THE LINE
FROM OF THE PUBLIC- WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. IN LINE
ONE HUNDRED YEAR MIKE IS UP.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
THE FIRST WITNESS. ALL WITNESS
LINES ARE OPEN. THE FIRST ONE
THIS IS ASHA MOHAMMED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THANK YOU SURE MEMBERS SLASH
ONE HUNDRED CATS GENERALLY
RESPECTFULLY- OPPOSED AB TWELVE
FIFTY TWO. AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO
MAY TURN VIRTUALLY ALL
BUSINESSES OFFERING DIGITAL
HEALTH SERVICES YOUR DEVICES
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE FITNESS
WEARABLES AND DIGITAL SCALES
EVEN WEBSITES AND APPS THAT
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
INTO PROVIDERS OF HEALTHCARE
SUBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONFIDENTIAL
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT. BECAUSE THE
MONEY WAS NOT DESIGNED FOR THE
BILL PUT TO DEAL WITH THESE
DEVICES AND SERVICES THE
APPLICATION MAKES IT NEARLY
LIMIT THE FEATURES AND
USEFULNESS OF EXISTING DEVICES
THAT MANY OF US USE AND RELY
UPON EVERY DAY- PARTICULARLY
DURING THE LAST YEAR THE NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
PERSONAL HEALTH DEVICES AND
SERVICES LIKE MENTAL HEALTH
APPS. HAS BEEN DEMONSTRABLE
SUBJECT WILL BE BUSINESSES TO
SEE ON MY WAY A WILL LIKELY
INCREASE THE COSTS OF
DEVELOPING PRODUCING IN
MAINTAINING COMPLIANT PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES WHICH IS AN
UNNECESSARY DETERRENT TO
DEVELOPING THESE TOLLS
ADDITIONALLY UNDERSTOOD TO BE
ABLE ATTORNEY GENERAL PRIVACY
REGULATION PASSAGE OF PROP
TWENTY FOUR AND THE APPOINTMENT
OF OUR FIRST CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
PROTECTION AGENCY. CUSTOMERS DO
ENJOY ROBUST PROTECTIONS FOR
ALL THE STATE UNDER EXISTING
AND UPCOMING LAW SUBJECTING
BUSINESSES OFTEN THESE DEVICES
AND SERVICES TO REQUIREMENTS
CFIA IS UNNECESSARY- THESE SOME
OF THE THINGS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWELVE PETITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HER TODAY. THANK
YOU THE SECOND ONE AN OPPOSITE
IS. FEEL IT GRIEVES WE THAT. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON FIELD RECENT
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT TODAY I WANT TO
STAKE THE AUTHOR FOR ENGINE
GAUGES MEANT AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY WITH US OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS ON THIS ISSUE AND
STAFF AS WELL- WE'RE ESPECIALLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL TODAY WERE
BECAUSE- OPPOSED BECAUSE THE
BILL. IS REALLY PREMATURE GIVEN
THE OVERLAPPING A COMPREHENSIVE
SET OF PRIVACY LAWS IN PLACE
TODAY FROM THE ONGOING
AMENDMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT TO THE
RECENTLY ADOPTED CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY RIGHTS ACT. WHICH
RAISES THE LEVEL OF REGULATION
IN THIS AREA FOR SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND- AND
TRYING TO LANDSCAPING IN THIS
AREA UNDERGONE SWEEPING CHANGES
LAST YEAR WE RESPECTFULLY
SUGGEST THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES REALLY OUGHT TO
ADDRESS AND ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS COMPREHENSIVELY. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- KNOW
ABOUT TODAY BUT AGAIN THANK YOU
TO THE- AUTHOR. AFTER ALL OF
HIS ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WISH TO COME ENOUGH. FOUR
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. ONE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY YEAR MIKE IS UP.
HI DON HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY POST THANK YOU.
ONE TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. AND LINE. TWO
HUNDRED FORTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CAME
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE ATTACK
THAT IN RESPECT OPPOSITION. AND
LINE TWO HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
YOUR MY KIDS UP. GOOD ACTORS
ANY ERA CALIFORNIA NINE FIVE
THREE POSTSEASON IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER KAREN I
APOLOGIZE AFTER RUN IN ONE
SECOND PRESENTED ON ANOTHER
COMMITTEE I WANT TO SAY I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY I POINT YOU I THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT EFFORT HERE-
DONE TODAY I WAS PERSUADED BY.
SOME OF THE POINTS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION- I CAN I
DISAGREE THAT THIS BILLS ARE
NOT UNNECESSARY THINK IT'S VERY
NECESSARY IN THAT THE THRUST OF
THE BILL'S IMPORTANT. BUT I DO
WORRY OF IF IT'S A BIT
OVERBROAD AND WHETHER WE MIGHT
BE IMPOSING SOME IS
INCONSISTENT- REQUIREMENTS ON.
ON BUSINESSES I THINK FOR
EXAMPLE ABOUT. YOU KNOW I'VE OF
MEDITATION APP ON MY PHONE
RIGHT DOES THAT COUNT. I
HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T USED IT IS.
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS SO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT INFORMATION
ANYBODY WOULD GET BUT- YOU KNOW
JUST TRYING TO THINK ABOUT WE
WANT TO CREATE ROOM FOR
INNOVATION. THESE ARE PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE IN SOUTH. I
TRUST YOU I KNOW YOU'RE VERY
FAR FROM THIS AREA BUT WE JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND MAYBE AS
YOU SAID WITH WITH A DIFFERENT
BILL FINE TUNING. I'M JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
THOSE NEEDS. YOU CAN'T WHICH IS
SO IMPORTANT PROTECTING
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY RIGHTS TO. TO
REALLY IMPORTANT AND SENSITIVE
MEDICAL INFORMATION BUT ALSO.
WHERE THERE IS ROOM FOR
FLEXIBILITY AND INNOVATION TO
ME BECAUSE I FOUND A LITTLE BIT
SO. THANK YOU FOR THE BILL AND
I WILL VOTE FOR WHEN I COME
BACK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. SEEING NO
OTHER A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHED COMMENT-
MISTER CHALLENGE IT BECAUSE-
ALL YES I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A AYE VOTE- ALL RIGHT- MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CHAPTER I
CHAO HI KILEY. KILEY NO POWER
QUE HAN ARE QUE HAND AYE
BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE CARILLO.
CUNNINGHAM GABRIEL. GALLAGHER
IRWIN HI- WHEN I LEAVE. WICKS
WICKS HI. THAT HAS. FIVE VOTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. A LOT.
OKAY SIR. NUMBER SACRAMENTO.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
VICE CHAIR I BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE LAST BILL AND THAT'S- THE
TANGLED AND REPRESENTING- MR
TANG IS MISBAH K. HAND CAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MISBACH IN. AND
THAT'S- THE LAST BILL ON THE
AGENDA WHICH IS- AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN ANYTIME YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME PRESENT AB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG- I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS MENTION IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON BEHALF OF
MR TANG. AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
SIX TO PROTECT GUN VIOLENCE
RESEARCHERS ACCESS TO DATA THEY
NEED TO STUDY THE EFFECTIVE
NATURE OF OUR GUN LAWS. DESPITE
A THIRTY YEAR HISTORY OF
PROVIDING THIS CRUCIAL
INFORMATION AN EXISTING LAW
REQUIRING IT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
RECENTLY DECIDED TO LIMIT
ACCESS TO KNEECAP OR GUN
VIOLENCE RESEARCHERS. AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN RETAIN THE STATE
ACCESS BY REQUIRING DOJ TO
SHARE THE INFORMATION WITH THE
STATE FUNDED YOU SEE FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER.
CLARIFYING EXISTING LAW THE DOJ
BELIEVES PROHIBITS THE SHARING
OF DATA WITH RESEARCHERS
ALLOWING A DISCRETIONARY
PROCESS FOR OTHER RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS TO ACCESS THE DATA
EXTENDING RECORDKEEPING FROM
TEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
ENSURING RESEARCHERS PROTECT
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY. THIS DATA
LEADS TO EVIDENCE BASED
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
DEATHS AND INJURIES FROM GUNS
CALIFORNIA MUST CONTINUE TO
SHARE THIS DATA SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE OUR
FIREARMS POLICIES AND REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES HERE TODAY GAREN
WINTEMUTE WITH YOU SEE WHICH
FIRE RESEARCH CENTER. AND
REBEKAH MARKETS WITH THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S GO TO OUR FIRST WITNESS-
IS SO. AGAIN THE ONE TEAM THE
TEAM IS FROM YOU SEE. A DEMO
ROOM. GO AHEAD SIR GO AHEAD.
PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU I NINE
HI DOCTOR WINTEMUTE. CORRECTOR
THAT FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
CALIFORNIA RESEARCHERS HAVE
WORKED WITH DOJ FOR THREE
DECADES. TO GENERATE THE
EVIDENCE NECESSARY FOR SOUND
POLICY MAKING ON FIREARM
VIOLENCE AND ITS PREVENTION.
THE WORKER LIES ON IDENTIFIED
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DATA. STUDIES
AND SIMPLY CAN'T BE CONDUCTED
OTHERWISE. THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN STRICKEN HEARINGS TO
PRIVACY PROTOCOLS ESTABLISHED
BY PARTICIPATING UNIVERSITIES.
AND FUNDING AGENCIES AND THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN A PRIVACY
BREACH. EXPECTING THAT SUCH
RESEARCH WOULD CONTINUE. TO
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
NATION'S FIRST PUBLICLY FUNDED
CENTER FOR RESEARCH ON FIREARM.
VIOLENCE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. ORIGINALLY AND THAT OF
OPPOSITION TO THE INDEPENDENT
SCIENTIFIC STUDY OF VIOLENCE
TOOK ROOT AT D. O. J. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE BILL
BEFORE YOU SEEKS TO RESET THE
BALANCE IT WOULD ALLOW
RESEARCHERS AT THE CENTER AND
AT OTHER CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES TO DO THEIR WORK
AND HELP PREVENT DEATHS AND
INJURIES FROM VIOLENCE IN OUR
STATE THANK YOU AN OLD NEWTON
STAY AVAILABLE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU SIR AND
NEXT WE HAVE REBEKAH MARCUS
WITH THE BRADY CAMPAIGN- AS
MARKETS ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I AM GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS REBEKAH MARQUESS
REPRESENTING THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA
COLLECTS AND ARCHIVES THE
UNIQUELY RICH BODY OF DATA ON
POTENTIAL RISK FACTORS
CHARACTERISTICS AND
CONSEQUENCES OF GUN VIOLENCE.
RESULTS FROM THIS RESEARCH HAD
INFORMED FIREARM SAFETY LAWS
AND POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION PROVIDED AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND MADE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ADVANCING
UNDERSTANDING OF FIREARM
VIOLENCE- INSIDE THIS DATA
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED. TO THOSE
OF US WORKING TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE YOU WANT TO CREATE
SUCCESSFUL POLICY OUTCOMES
WITHOUT THE RESEARCH YOU'RE
FLYING BLIND. WITH THE EVIDENCE
WE CAN TAKE A LOCK IN
CALIFORNIA AND MAKE IT WORK IN
NEW YORK ILLINOIS NBC. AB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN WILL PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE ANALYSIS
ULTIMATELY USED. TO PREVENT THE
SENSELESS LOSS OF LIFE DUE TO
GUN VIOLENCE FREE APPS FOR YOUR
EYES OUT I WOULD ALSO JUST SAY
THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL BY
DIFFERENCES WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT WEEK
THE HOUSE- LET'S SEE I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM
TO- WHO WISHES TO SPEAK SO
LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL- WITNESSES- WHO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AB. TWO
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IF
SUPPORTERS AB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE SEVEN
ZERO I COMMANDED IN ONE ZERO.
LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO HEAR
MY COULD TALK WITH. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TO HEAR MIKE IS
UP BUT. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD
OPENS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TEN MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLACE. THE LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. SWINE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WHITE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
YEAR MIKE IS UP IN. CLASS AND
SONOMA A GUN VIOLENCE SURVIVOR
WITH THE EVERYTOWN SURVIVOR
NETWORK AND VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE. THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BLIGHTED
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. CHRIS PAULA QUINN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT UCLA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
ONE TWO HUNDRED FORTY NINE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. HI CRYSTAL
LOPILATO VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
FOR OPPOSITION WE HAVE A FIRST
WIN THIS SAMPLE READY SO WITH
GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
YOU ON THE LINE MISTER PAREDES.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN IS SAMPRAS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF GUN
OWNERS CALIFORNIAN I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
WOULD ASK YOUR LATITUDE IN THAT
THIS BILL WAS. HEARD IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE AND
THAT COMMITTEE PETTY WELL
TRUNCATED SOME OF THE TESTIMONY
AND PUNCH IT TO THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE ON THE- ON THE VERY
IMPORTANT PRIVACY ISSUES THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO DISCUSS. SO WE
REQUEST YOUR INDULGENCE ON
THAT- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL. IS IN RED
BAST. IT IS DIRECTING MULTIPLE
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES
HEALTH AGENCIES ALL OF THAT.
THE AGENCIES IN MENTIONED.
EXCLUDING THE ONES THAT WERE
AMENDED OUT TODAY- BUT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS UPON
MILLIONS OF RECORDS OF NOT ONLY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CRIMINAL USED
FIREARMS BUT LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS WHO HAVE PURCHASED
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION AND
PRECURSOR PARTS. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THEM TO OF THIS
RESEARCH CENTER- WITHOUT THE
PERMISSION OF THE NOT EVEN THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PEOPLE WHO WHO
ARE ARE ARE- PURCHASING
FIREARMS OR AMMUNITION OR THOSE
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS ARE ON
THE APPS. PROGRAM OR OR ANY
OTHER PERSON THERE TRANSFERRING
THIS WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE.
WE KNOW THE DATA BREACHES ARE
POSSIBLE. THANK GOD AND THEY
THEY HAVEN'T HAPPENED THERE SO
FAR BUT IT HAPPENED AT STANFORD
WE JUST HEARD THAT IT HAPPENED
AT FACEBOOK THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS HAD NO DATA
BREACHES OF WHICH I WAS-
LITIGANT AGAINST. SO THE AMOUNT
OF INFORMATION THAT IS GOING TO
BE HANDED OVER TO THESE
RESEARCHERS AND WE DON'T KNOW.
WHO THEY ARE WHAT KIND OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS OF LOOK AT IT
THEY HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCES
OR WHAT AND NOT ONLY TO THEM
BUT TO THEIR ASSOCIATES. WE AT
THE WAY WE READ THE BILL THIS
CAN GO TO RAND CORPORATION OR
GOOGLE OR ANYBODY ELSE IF THEY
ARE WORKING WITH THE RESEARCH
CENTER TO CRUNCH THE NUMBERS
AND- YOU UTILIZED THE MILLIONS
UPON MILLIONS OF RECORDS. AND
FINALLY. IT IS AUSTIN'S GIVES
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE THE
OPPORTUNE TO GIVE IT TO OTHER
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS WILL
IMPACT THE LAND WHICH CLEARLY
GIVES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHERRY PICK WHO IT IS THEY THEY
ALLOWED TO UTILIZE THIS
INFORMATION THOSE ARE SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS AND I WOULD-
EXPRESS OUR PART STRONG
OPPOSITION FOLKS YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT PRIVACY ISSUES
ALL DAY LONG ALL COMMITTEE
LONG. THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU
HAVE BEEN. WORKING TO PROTECT
AND THIS BILL WILL CHECK THAT
DOOR WIDE OPEN- AND SO WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI THIS IS KATHLEEN
AND SHE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA. MISTER LYNCH ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE AFTER A
LONG DAY- THE SPONSOR WHEN
ASKED WHY HE NEEDED PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE STATED THAT AND I
QUOTE PART. PUBLIC RECORD
MESSAGE REQUIRE FOLLOWING
INDIVIDUAL CASES WE TALK ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE THROUGH
MULTIPLE RECORDS SYSTEMS. AND
QUOTE THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO TRACK INDIVIDUAL
UNKNOWINGLY FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THERE IS NO OPT IN
PROVISION FOR THE CONSUMER. AND
THIS CROSSES A NUMBER OF
AGENCIES OF MR FREDDIE HAS
POINTED OUT. SOME OF THE
TROUBLING BASEMENT THEN THE
BILL INCLUDED YOU SEE SAYS IT'S
NECESSARY RESEARCH BUT PROVIDES
NO DEFINITION OF NECESSARY. AND
THEY MAKE IT AN INTERNAL
DECISION ABOUT THAT. THIS BILL
IS A CLASSIC. NOW AS BEEN
POINTED OUT THAT THEY CAN GET
THE NUMBER TO THEIR A FEELING
OR A NON. RESEARCH THERE'S NO.
OF A- FOR NONPROFIT RESEARCH
HAS PROVIDED SURE CAN
DISCUSSION HERE ABOUT WILL THE
CONSUMER BE AFFORDED AN OXY AND
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY SO THEY
KNOW WHERE THEIR INFORMATION IS
GOING FROM INSTITUTION TO
INSTITUTION. THE OVERSIGHT WILL
BE BY THE RESEARCHERS OWN
INTERNAL INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW
BOARD. AND OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
GOING TO CHANGE HANDS IN A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR PERIOD WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
BACKGROUND IN. THE UC RECENTLY
REPORTED IN A NEWSPAPER ARTICLE
THAT THEY WOULD PROTECT PRIVACY
BY A SECURE PASSWORD SERVER WE
ALL KNOW HAS BEEN STATED THAT
DEAL JD UC'S HAVE BEEN HACKED.
AND MOST RECENTLY STANFORD AND
THE- COURTS TO HELP THEM AS ONE
OF THEIR SPONTANEOUS. I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY TO CHECK THE I AM
GOING TO ASK YOU TO WRAP THAT
SIN. OKAY I'LL BE HAPPY TO DO
THAT- THIS IS A VERY BAD
PRECEDENT FOR ALL RESEARCH
PROGRAMS AND THERE ARE MANY
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH-
REASONS WHY PEOPLE WOULD WANT
ACCESS TO PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THIS IS A- HUGE LIABILITIES AND
THERE'S NO. CONSEQUENCES FOR
THE RELEASE OF THIS INFORMATION
THERE'S NO REASON GOOD ENOUGH
TO CREATE LESS. ACTUALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA EXERCISING THEIR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU SEE NO ONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY THAT. PHONE
LINE FOR A CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL. WHICH
IS THE AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAT IS THE ROW
SACRAMENTO AGAIN ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AN LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX YOUR MIKE IS UP. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROY GRIFFIN SPEAKING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED WE STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. I TRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB NUMBER ONE TO
THIRTY SEVEN AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE KEN COOLEY
BILL WENT A. B. FOUR SEVENTY
TWO I WAITED ALL DAY TO HEAR
ABOUT ONE AND YOU'RE SAYING
THIS IS THE LAST BILL WHERE DID
IT GO- MAN THANKS FOR THE CALL.
THE COOLEY BILL IS ON CONSENSO
IT'S BEEN ADOPTED AND APPROVED
TO SELL ARE YOU CALLING ABOUT
THIS ONE AS WELL. I WAITED ALL
DAY FOR THE COOLEY THING I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT YOU JUST
SAID TO ME SOMETHING ABOUT
CONSENT WHAT ABOUT ME ARE YOU
SPEAKING A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE.
YEAH I'M CALLING AGAIN TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN AND I'M ONE. YES
WE ARE CURRENTLY ON TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN- THIS. AND AS FAR
AS THE COOLEY BILL IT PASSED.
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE. ON THE
CONSENT. AGENDA MEANING THAT
THE ALL THE REASONS OTHER
ISSUES HAVE BEEN RESOLVED. A
BOTH SIDES AGREED TO A PASSED
BILL SO WOULD YOU WHICH I TO
TELL US WHO YOUR NAME TO
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL PLEASE. SHE. ARE YOU
STILL THIS SITE IS SO THAT'S-
YES I'M STILL HERE I'M SAYING
NO. NO TO TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY I
DIDN'T GET TO SAY NO TO FOR
SEVENTY TWO WHERE DID THE COOK
DON'T GO BY WHAT IT PRESENTED-
AS I EXPLAINED EARLIER. THE
BILL PASSED ON WHEN YOU ARE
SPEAKING THE OTHER LANGUAGE
BECAUSE YOU PEOPLE ARE NOT.
YEAH MAN THANKS FOR YOUR CALL
THE BILL ALREADY PASSED EARLIER
TODAY. THAT COOLEY BILL AND
WE'RE ON TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
CURRENTLY SO I THINK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR CALL AND- WE HAVE
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SO
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COLORS. ALL LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY YEAR MIKE IS UP
AND. GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
FINISHED WITH THE RPA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTEEN TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT PLEASE.
MY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS CARLENE ELLIS AND I'M A
COMPETITIVE PERSON SHOOTER
ALONG TO THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION. SACRAMENTO
DEFENSIVE PISTOL SHOOTERS AND
SEVERAL OTHERS AND I STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN ON MY RIGHT TO
PRIVACY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH ON EXCEL CALLER PLEASE.
WIND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN THAT
WELL I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND GUNNERS
CALIFORNIA- AND I STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK.
THANK YOU- NEXT PLEASE. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SIX IF I
COULD OPEN. HI MY NAME IS STEVE
RODDA GERMAN OF THE MENTAL LIKE
CINEMA COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION NRA LIFE MEMBER AN
U. S. NAVY THAT AND I STRONGLY
URGE OPOSITION AB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT- PLEASE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY OR MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
RON LANDER I'M CHAIRMAN OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE RIVERSIDE CHAPTER
THE C. A. R. P. WE HAVE WHO ARE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY PLUS MEMBERS
WE STRONGLY RECOMMEND A NO. IN
OPPOSITION DUE TO BABY TO
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT CALL OF THESE. ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
LINE. SIXTY SEVEN. MR STRICTURE
THE SENATE PLAN ON THE FUTURE
OF THE SOUTH STARTS MENTAL
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION A
MINORITY MEMBER STRONG
OPPOSITION. Q- NEXT PLEASE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
SPEAKS FOR SOME TERMINATE THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY GUN OWNERS
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION-
I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
PROPOSAL I THINK IF YOU'RE
PLACING A LOT OF FAITH IN AN
ORGANIZATION'S WHICH THANK YOU
HAVE NUMBER ONE. THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR WE'RE
NOT- TAKING TESTIMONY AT THIS
POINT SO BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL WE REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU- CALLER PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME I THANK YOU
MISS RAFI- LET'S LET'S BRING
BACK TO CONVENE A VICE CHAIR
KILEY GO AHEAD PLEASE I JUST
WANT TO ASK ABOUT THIS CONCERN
THAT'S BEEN RAISED THAT WERE-
DESIGNATING YOU KNOW WHAT ONE
PARTICULAR OFFICE OR RESEARCH
INSTITUTE AS SORT OF THE
PRIMARY RECIPIENT OF THIS- DATA
AND THEN YOU KNOW SECONDARILY-
OTHERS MIGHT GET IT- IF THERE
ARE APPROVED BY AN OFFICE
THAT'S HEADED BY SOMEONE WHO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS OFTEN
TAKEN VERY. STRONG POSITIONS
ON- POLITICAL ISSUES PERTAINING
TO THE TOPIC OF THE RESEARCH SO
I YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT HOW DO YOU
ANSWER THOSE CONCERNS THAT THIS
PROCESS BY SPECIFICALLY NAMING
ONE- INSTITUTE AND THEN HAVING
A PERHAPS POLITICIZED PROCESS
FOR THE SELECTION OF OTHERS
MIGHT- SORT OF RUN AGAINST THE
IDEA OF HAVING A SPIRIT OF
INQUIRY- AND ASCERTAINMENT OF
TRUTH AND MAY INSTEAD LEAD TO A
PROCESS WHERE- YOU KNOW
RECIPIENTS ARE SELECTED MORE
BASED UPON THE- OUTCOMES THAT
THEY'RE LIKELY TO REACH. I CAN
M. REFER THAT TO MISTER WINTER
I DO THINK I'M- ONE
CORPORATIONS I THINK
INSTITUTIONAL VIEWS ACTUALLY
DON'T UC DAVIS I THINK YOU
SAID. IT WAS DONE BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE WAS
THAT THE QUESTION WAS WHERE.
IT'S THE TO DO THE DAVIS
SISTERS REQUIRED- TO GET THE
INFORMATION AND I BELIEVE- THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE WILL ALSO
ACT- OTHER. RESEARCH INSTITUTES
THAT- THAT MAY ALSO ASK FOR IT
OKAY MISTER INTERNET YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS THAT. SURE I'D BE
HAPPY TO- FIRST OFF THAT DOES.
THE SHALL LANGUAGE AS IT
APPLIES TO THAT STATE FUNDED OF
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER- WAS PART OF THE
CENTER'S INITIAL AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SO WHICH IT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR NEARLY FIVE YEARS
NOW BUT THE CURRENT BILL DOES-
IS RESHAPED AND CLARIFY A
MANDATE IN LIGHT OF SUBSEQUENT
DEVELOPMENTS WITH DOJ- NOT
ABIDING BY THE LANGUAGE AS IT
WAS ORIGINALLY PROVIDED- WHAT
DOJ HAS ALSO DONE IS
ESSENTIALLY BLOCK ALL ACCESS TO
THESE DATA- ON THE PART OF
INSTITUTIONS OTHER BANDS. THAT
STATE FUNDED- CENTER AND- YEAH
I'M TO REACH NOT THE
LEGISLATURE BUT I DO THAT THE
INTENT HERE IS TO CREATE A
PROCESS THAT MIGHT FUNCTION
SOMETHING ALONG THE LINES OF
THE PROCESS AT. THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH WHERE
FIRST TOP INSTITUTIONS NEED TO
BE RECOGNIZED IN THEIR STATE
LAW HONEST AS BONAFIDE RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS BUT THEN THERE
WOULD BE SOME SORT OF FORMAL
MERIT BASED PROCESS. FOR
EVALUATING PROPOSALS FOR ACCESS
TO DATA FROM RESEARCH AND I AND
I SHOULD MENTION THE TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. I WILL SAY
CONVENIENTLY IGNORED THAT. ALL
OF THE TIME IN THE PAST AND
INTO THE FUTURE ALL OF THIS
WORK OPERATES UNDER. A VERY
TIGHT SECURITY BLANKET THAT
INCORPORATES STATE LEVEL
POLICIES UNIVERSITY LEVEL
POLICIES FUNDING AGENCY
POLICIES. YOU ARE PROJECT
MAKING USE OF. THE STATE ARE
ONLY PROVIDES ACCESS TO THOSE
SPECIFIC TEAM MEMBERS WHO MUST
HAVE ACCESS IN ORDER FOR THE
TEAM TO DO ITS WORK. ACCESS IS
KEPT AS RESTRICTED AS IS
POSSIBLE TO ALLOW WHILE
ALLOWING THE PROJECT TO
CONTINUE. YOU SAID THAT THE DOJ
BLOCKED ACCESS BEFORE COULD YOU
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT. EIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- I CAN'T GIVE YOU A
DEFINITE ANSWER BECAUSE DOJ.
OVER TO NOW SEVERAL YEARS OF
EFFORT HAS REFUSED TO PROVIDE
ONE- WHEN DATA BECAME HARDER TO
GET- SENATOR HAND ACTUALLY
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION THAT
BECAME FOURTEEN TO THIRTY ONE
POINT FIVE. OF THE PENAL CODE.
PERTAINING SPECIFICALLY TO GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER DATA
AND I CAN CLOSE OUT THAT
INSTANCE IF YOU'D LIKE THAT ALL
STATE GENERAL. FOR SEVERAL
YEARS WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
GET ANY STATEMENT FROM D. O. J.
AS TO WHY THE DATA WERE NOT
BEING PROVIDED THE CLOSEST I
GOT WAS A MEETING WITH THE HEAD
OF THE BUREAU OF RESEARCH AT
DOJ. AND TWO MEMBERS OF- THE
DOJ'S LEGAL STAFF WHO DID NOT
GET THEIR LAST NAMES WHO SAID
THAT THE DECISIONS WERE BEING
MADE BY TO USE THEIR TURN EXACT
UNQUOTE. THAT NO FURTHER
INFORMATION IS FORTHCOMING NO
THIS NO TIMELINE FOR RESOLUTION
OF THE DISPUTE- WOULD BE
PROVIDED. WE TRIED A GREAT MANY
AVENUES TO RESOLVE THIS BLOCK
INFORMALLY BEFORE. RESORTING TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. I WELL
I JUST KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
THAT'S IT'S THIS BILL GIVES
DISCRETION TO DOJ STILL IN
TERMS OF THE SELECTION OF
RECIPIENTS OF WE'VE HAD. A BAD
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM BEFORE I'M
WONDERING WHETHER THIS IS THE
RIGHT. PLACE TO BE PLACING THAT
DISCRETION THANK YOU. I'M SORRY
HE HAD COMING TO ME. I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS A QUESTION THANK
YOU. YEAH THAT WAS A COMMON YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ASKING- EITHER A-
ADDITION. COMMENTS ALMOST
IDENTICAL JUST VERY QUICKLY TO
SAY THERE'S A GREAT RESIST TO
RE. OF GUN RESEARCHING CENTER I
THINK THAT DEPENDING ON TO.
CONTROL THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TURN WHETHER DOJ IS GOING BE-
OF COOPER OR NOT AND THIS BILL
MOVES THAT RESEARCH THAT'S SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED- FORWARDS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUT SEEN NO OTHER COMMENTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU I COULDN'T AGREE MORE
MISTER BENNETT I THINK THIS
REACHES RESEARCH IS CRITICAL
AND I THINK WE SHOULD DO IT ON
MORE OF OUR LEGISLATION LOOKING
AT. HOW EFFECTIVE ARE
LEGISLATION IS AN IMPROVING AND
SAVING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SO MOVING THIS
WORD I THINK IS CRITICAL AND
pBELIEVE WE PASSED THAT
LEGISLATION OF CLASS. BY
CREATING THIS RESEARCH
INSTITUTE AND PROVIDING THAT
DATA AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH'S
FAILURE TO COMPLY REQUIRES THIS
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
HAVE A- VERY GOOD I BELIEVE THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED TO HAVE MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
AB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAP HI CHECK
OUT I KILEY. KILEY NO BARRICADE
HIGH. POWER QUE HAN I BENNETT.
BENNETT HI CORREA. YEAH I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
GABRIEL WELL YES YEAH GABRIEL
HI GALLAGHER- WHEN I- WHEN I
LEE LEE AYE WICKES WICKES HI
THAT'S EIGHT. BOTH SET UP BILL
IS OUT AND- THAT WAS THE LAST
BILL- MEMBERS AND- WE ARE GOING
TO. LISTEN BECAUSE AND- DO SOME
ADD ONS BUT INSTEAD OF DOING
THEM SEPARATELY I'M JUST GOING
TO GO DOWN THE LIST UP-
STARTING WITH IT- CONSENT
AGENDA- MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALLTHE ABSENT MEMBERS SO ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA. AT THE SAYS
THE CONSENT AGENDA- KILEY.
KILEY I PARA QUE HAVE RK HANNAH
I GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN HI-
WHEN I THAT IS UNANIMOUS
UNANIMOUS- THAT IS OUT LET'S
START FROM THE TOP THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX UP OUR QUE HAN- PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS- AT THIS
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CARILLO. CARILLO
I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING. THAT'S. EIGHT SIX EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT TO
TWO OF EIGHT OKAY GOT IT I'M
SORRY GOT IT I NEXT BILL IS
ITEM TWO AB THREE NINETY BERMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AREA I LEE. LEE HI THAT IS
UNANIMOUS THAT ONE IS OUT.
THIRD ITEM EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN BALLOON PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS CAREER. AREA
I GALLAGHER. WICKS HI WICKS HI
THAT HAS. TEN VERSUS TEN BILLS
HAVE BILL IS OUT NEXT- BILL IS
ON CONSENT WHICH HAS ALREADY
BEEN PASSED- ITEM FIVE IS ON
CALL THAT'S AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO
THAT'S A CHILD BILL- HI WILL
NOW LIFT THE CALL PLEASE CALL
YES MEMBERS. THIS IS TWELVE
FIFTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CORREA. AREA
I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING GABRIEL APRIL AYE
GALLAGHER. LAKE LEHIGH. SEVEN
SEVEN I HAVE EIGHT EIGHT OKAY
THAT DOUBLES UP NEXT BILL IS
ITEM SIX A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR CHU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CORREA. AREA I LEE HI
WE I. HAS NINE VOTES NINE THAT
BILL IS UP NEXT BILLS ON WHAT'S
GOING ON CONSENT- NEXT ONE IS
AT THE ALSO ON CONSENT WAS ON
CONSENT NUMBER EIGHT NUMBER
NINE IS A B. TWELVE- SIXTY TWO
CUNNINGHAM PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS MISSION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN
NOT IRWIN NOT VOTING THAT BILL
HAVE HAS TEN VOTES TEN VOTES
SET UP THOSE UP- NEXT BILL WAS
ON CONSENT- YOU NEXT BILL IS
ELEVEN ITEM ELEVEN AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIX FRIEDMAN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CORREA. I AT
LEAST. WE HI THAT'S UNANIMOUS
UNANIMOUS. NEXT IS ITEM TWELVE
WHICH IS ON CALL AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN GABRIEL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS IS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
JUDICIARY KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTING AREA. I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. GALLAGHER. IRWIN
HI- WHEN I WITH WICKS HI. THAT
IS NINE VOTES NINE BILLS THAT
BILL IS OUT THERE NEXT BILL IS
ON CALL ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX SO LORENA GONZALEZ-
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE MOTIONIS TO PASS A AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR KILEY YEAH
KILEY NARROW. CARILLO HI
GABRIEL. GABRIEL HI GALLAGHER
IRWIN HI- WHEN I WICKES WICKES
HI. THAT HAS NINE VOTES WITH
ONE NOW NINE ONE THAT BILL IS%
OUT NEXT BILL IS ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TEN EIGHTY NINE GRAYSON
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS POWER
QUE HAN. OUR QUE HAN HI CARILLO
AREA HI. AT. HE HAS EIGHT VOTES
AND ONE OF EIGHT ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT NEXT- ITEM FIFTEEN IS ON
CALL AB TWO SIXTY EIGHT OR ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS POWER QUE HAN
OKAY HAND I CARILLO. YEAH I
GALLAGHER LEE LI I THE BILL HAS.
EIGHT TWO ONE EIGHT TWO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT NEXTERA. I AM
SIXTEEN WAS ON CONSENT ITEM
SEVENTEEN- IS A B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR LEAD PLEASE CALL THE
I. FROM MEMBERS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR. AREA FIVE CARILLO I GAVE
REAL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER. WICKS
WICKS HI. THAT HAS NINE VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT THE ITEM
EIGHTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN SEVEN
FIVE LOCAL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR. AREA I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
GALLAGHER- WHEN I- WHEN I WICKS
WICKS HI THAT BILL HAS TEN
BUCKS THANK YOU ARDABIL IS OUT
NEXT- ITEM NINETEEN IS ON CALL
AB THIRTY FOUR MEMBERS SU CHI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. KILEY HIGHLY NO
BARRICADE HIM PARA QUE HAN I
CARILLO. AREA I GAVE REAL
GABRIEL I IRWIN HI- WHEN I.
THAT IS NINE TWO TWO NINE TWO
THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT ITEM
TWENTY EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
THREE OF US US- PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KILEY. AYE KILEY
AYE GALLAGHER. IRWIN FIVE- WHEN
I WICKS WICKS NOT VOTING THAT
BILL HAS. SIX SURELY I NUMBER
NINE VOTES NINE VOTES THAT BILL
IS OUT ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
FIFTEEN OH THREE SANTIAGO.
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AN
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AREA.
TWENTY FIFTEEN OH THREE FIFTY
FIFTY THREE SANTIAGO. AT
CARILLO I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HI GALLAGHER. IRWIN
FIVE- WHEN I WICKS WICKS HI
LAST ITEM TWENTY TWO AB. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN TEN BILL PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS- THANKS
A LOT GALLAGHER. THAT WOULD
CONCLUDE THE CALLS AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
NEXT FEW MINUTES I THINK
THEY'RE JUST GALLAGHER HE'S NOT
HERE YET SO I'LL WAIT A FEW
MINUTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MEMBERS SO FOR EURO WHAT AND-
YOUR ATTENTION. SIX TWENTY-
CHECK. I HAVE YOU AS AN AYE
VOTE ON TWENTY. I DON'T THINK I
HAVE ANY MAYBE THEY WOULD. I
DON'T KNOW. SEPARATELY. RIGHT-
AFTER. LOOKING. YOU SEE A YEAH
RIGHT NOW THE.
AND IT IS. THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.